SORRY MISTER MISTER OUR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN ARCHULETA. ATKINS BATES
BILL BURGESS BRADFORD CAPPIELLO
CHAIN DALLY DODD DURAZO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HILL HUESO TITLE
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORE LOCKED.
WELL NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE
NUMBER Y. CASKEY WINNER WILK
THIS PRESIDENT A CORPSMAN.
MEMBERS ARE QUORUM IS PRESENT
WORKED OUR MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED EMPEROR TODAY BY OUR
CHOPPED IN SISTER MACHIKO
GORMAN AFTER WHICH WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. SELECT A CENTER
OURSELVES IN GOD'S PRESENCE ONE
MORE TIME. AS YOU COME TO THE
END OF THE SESSION I LEAVE YOU
WITH THE WORDS OF SISTER MARY
BAPTIST RUSSELL WHO STATURE
GRACES THE LAWN OUT THERE
SOMEWHERE. TO SOME YOUNG
SISTERS WHO ARE JUST PROCLAIM
THEIR FINAL VOWS SHE SAID. YOU
MUST NOT NOW IMAGINE ALL IS
DONE. ON THE CONTRARY YOU ARE
JUST NOW BEGINNING. SO AS YOU
TRANSITION FROM THE SPACE WE
ASK GOD'S CONTINUAL BLESSINGS
ON YOUR ENDINGS AND NEW
BEGINNINGS. MAY YOU EXPERIENCE
THE GOD OF SURPRISES HIDDEN IN
THE POCKETS OF YOUR DAILY LIFE.
MAY YOU EXPERIENCE THE GOD OF
GENEROSITY AS YOU BRING FORTH
AN ABUNDANCE OF INSIGHTS AND
CREATIVITY. FOR IMPROVING OUR
STAYS AND OUR WORLD. AND MAY
YOU EXPERIENCE THE GOD OF PEACE
AS YOUR RETURN HOME TO NEW TO
WHEN YOU READ THEM OF GROWTH
AND TRANSFORMATION. AND UNTIL
YOU RETURN TO THE SENATE FLOOR
AT THE APPOINTED TIME MAY GOD
HOLD YOU IN THE PALM OF GOD'S
HANDS A MAN. BETTER. GOD BLESS
AMERICA I PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA HAS. AND ONE
UNDER OUR INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AS WE ALL
KNOW WE HAVE GALLAGHER BE
GATHERING HERE FOR OUR LAST DAY
OF LEGISLATION SUCH LEGISLATIVE
SESSION TODAY WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK THERE WERE GONNA DRESS
PROVES OF BEFORE THERE WILL BE
NONE TODAY. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WOULD BE DEALING DEEMED READ.
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR
SEPTEMBER NINTH THROUGH THE
THIRTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
THE DAILY FILE. CENTER
HERTZBERG FOR WHAT PURPOSE
THANK YOU AN EMOTION
RESOLUTIONS I QUICKLY GETS OFF
THE DESK AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS PLEASE MOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEASURES SEVENTEEN TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A CORREO AND
FILE ITEM FORTY A. B. FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK TO THE INACTIVE FILE TO
LESS BILLS TO WORK. THANK YOU
THIS WILL NOTE THANK YOU. NOW
MOVING ON TO THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE ANY OTHER. OKAY LET'S GO
I SORRY SENATOR LEYVA SORRY IS
MISTER PRESIDENT I WAS A LITTLE
SLOW WASN'T YOU I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY SIX FROM
ENGROSSING AND ROLLING AND HOLD
THE MEASURE AT THE DESK. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER ITEMS. TO BE
ADDRESSED HERE UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. SEEING NO
FURTHER WE'RE MOVING ON DOUBTS
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE WE'RE GONNA MOVE FIRST
THIS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FIRST UP IS ITEM THIRTY TWO. IS
THE. DO WE HAVE A MANAGER FOR
THAT ITEM. WHY BECAUSE YOU'RE
YOU'RE A READY FOR ITEM THIRTY
TWO. MISTER CLARK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AN
ACRYLATE HOUSING. THROUGH A
COLLEGE BEFORE GEORGE GOOD
MORNING THIS RESIDENT AB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE SIX TO REDUCE SOME OF
THE BARRIERS TO EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION BY UPDATING AND
CLARIFYING THE COAT. THE
MEASURE THE SEVERAL THINGS
FIRST CLARIFY SOME DEFINITIONS
OF REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING THE
DEFINITION OF PUBLIC TRANSIT
AND EIGHTY USE DISTANCE FROM
TRANSIT AND THE TYPES OF
EXISTING STRUCTURES THE CAN BE
CONVERTED TO EIGHTY USE SECOND
IT REMOVES PROVISIONS THAT HAVE
GIVEN CITIES AND RECENTLY
BROAD. DISCRETION FOR DENYING
EIGHTY YOU PERMITS AND FINALLY
IT REMOVES THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENT IN THE EXISTING
STATUTE WHICH UNFAIRLY SUBJECTS
EIGHTY USE TO REQUIREMENT THAT
DOES NOT EXIST FOR ANY OTHER
KIND OF HOUSING. COULD RESULT
NEEDY USE BEING DEMOLISHED
INCREASE LONG TERM UNCERTAINTY
AROUND A UNITS FUTURE. AFTER IT
HAS BEEN BUILT THE FIVE YEAR
SUNSET TO OWNER OCCUPANCY
PROVISION OF THE BILL. WAS
ADDED TO GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
IMPACT REMOVING THAT LANGUAGE
COULD HAVE AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE
WILL HELP EIGHTY USE REALIZE
THEIR FULL POTENTIAL AND WITH
THAT I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DESCRIPTION OF
THE BAIT ON THIS ITEM. TURNING
SEEN NONE INSTRUCTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS AYE BATES NOBEL I
PORGES. BRADFORD I CAN BE AT
ALL. CHIANG DELHI. I DODD I
DORADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER NO
GONZALEZ HI GROW. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. TADO I JACKSON.
JONES NO LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL. HI MONEY BY MORE LARK
I'M A REAL. NIELSEN. BY PAN BY
PORTANTINO. I ROTH BY RUBIO
SKINNER AYE STERN NO STONE I AM
BURKE. BY WHAT CASKEY I WINNER.
BY WILK. THROUGH I BECAUSE HE
MOVES CALL. NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE CENTER
MITCHELL WAS PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE MON AN ACT
RELATING TO CONSUMER LOANS.
MITCHELL FOR JURORS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT AB
FIVE THREE NINE COLLEAGUES IS
AN IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL THAT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS YEARS OVERDUE.
BECAUSE OF OUR LACKS LINDY LAWS
EXTREMELY HIGH COST LOANS HAVE
EXPLODED IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
PAST DECADE. THESE LOANS ARE
OFFERED IN PAYDAY AND TITLE
LOANS STORES AND OVER THE
INTERNET WITH LOAN AMOUNTS
STARTING AT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO AVOID THE INTEREST
RATE CAPS IN EXISTING LAW.
THESE HIGH COST LOANS AT
INTEREST RATES FROM ONE HUNDRED
TO MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT. AND FAR TOO OFTEN
CONSUMERS ARE UNABLE TO REPAY
THEM. IN FACT THE SENATE
BANKING COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
CITED A STUDY COMMISSIONED BY
HIGH COST LENDERS THAT FOUND
THAT NEARLY 40% OF THEIR
BORROWERS INTO IN COLLECTIONS.
THIS PROCESS RESULT IN DAMAGE
CREDIT RATING FOR THE CONSUMER
AND CAN LEAD TO THEIR PAYCHECK
BEING GARNISHED THEIR BANK
ACCOUNT CLOSED OR THEIR CARS BE
REPOSSESSED. THE AUTHORS OF
THIS BILL HAVE WORKED HARD TO
FIND A COMPROMISE THAT COULD
EARN SUPORT FROM BOTH CONSUMER
GROUPS AND REASONABLE LINDA IS
A LIE. AND THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF THOSE LONG
NEGOTIATIONS. THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A STRONG COALITION
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS AND VETERANS
GROUPS TO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
INCLUDING MY OWN BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AFTER SO ANY YEARS OF
FAILED ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM WE ASK YOU. TO ADVANCE
THIS IMPORTANT POLICY THAT WILL
BENEFIT BOTH CONSUMERS AND
REASONABLE LENDERS ALIKE I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. MANY
ADDITIONAL DESCRIPTION DEBATE
CENTER Y. COSTLY YES MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THREE NINE
AS A CO AUTHOR AND URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN ME IN
STANDING UP FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS NO FOR TOO LONG A
PREDATORY LENDERS HAVE HELD
SWAY OVER THIS LEGISLATURE AND
BLOCKED ATTEMPTS TO SET A RATE
CAPS. THAT PROHIBITS THEM FROM
CHARGING YOU SERVICE FEES FROM
CONSUMERS WHEN I STARTED
PRACTICING BANKRUPTCY LAW
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO THE
CREDITORS FIRE SAY THROUGHPUT
CHARGE 18% ON A FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR LOAN. IN WE THOUGHT MY
GOD IT'S BEYOND THAT TWELVE TO.
10% THAT PEOPLE WOULD HAVE I
KNOW ALL TOO WELL THAT THESE
PREDATORY LOANS SOON TURNED
INTO A MOUNTAIN OF DEBT THAT
CAN NEVER BE REPAID RESULTING
IN WAGE GARNISHMENT AND BANK
LEVEES WHICH I'VE PERSONALLY
SOUGHT. TO REIN IN ON MY OWN
LEGISLATION I URGE AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS LONG OVERDUE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH. THINK OF IT PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I TOO AM A CO AUTHOR
OF THIS MEASURE BECAUSE- THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE SORELY NEEDED
FOR ALL BORROWERS AND THAT
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDES ARE
VULNERABLE VETERANS. YOU KNOW
FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS LENDERS
FROM CHARGING MORE THAN 36%
INTEREST TO ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE%
FOUGHT VERY VERY HARD FOR THESE
PROTECTIONS BECAUSE OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS FRANKLY SHOULD NOT HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL STRESS PUT ON
THEM BY CERTAIN LENDERS THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE VETERANS AND
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE PROTECTED
FROM UNCONSCIONABLE FEES AND
INTEREST RATES. WHICH CAN
FRANKLY HAUNT THEM LONG AFTER
THE PRINCIPAL AMOUNT HAS BEEN
PAID OFF SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE SENATOR DALLY. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I SAW
THIS BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY VOTED
FOR AND THEN I GOT PUT ON
BAKING WHEN I GOT IN THE SENATE
FIRST TIME I'VE EVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE UNDER
GREAT CHAIR BY THE WAY. THIS
BILL BEEN AMENDED SOME I THINK
THIS IS GOOD FOR CONSUMERS IT'S
ABI SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
AND I KNOW THAT ARE A CAUCUS
HOUSING OPPOSE ON THE BILL BUT
I THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO FOR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IN MANY
SITUATIONS SO I REGION I VOTE
ON THIS BILL. CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU I AM RISE IN A-
OPPOSE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AND- WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
WHERE ARE PEOPLE GOING TO GET
CREDIT. IF YOU HAVE BAD CREDIT
AND YOU HAVE. NOT FULFILLED
YOUR OBLIGATIONS IN THE PAST OF
PAYING YOUR BILLS. AND MAKING
SURE THAT YOUR CREDIT IS GOOD.
THEN YOU CAN'T JUST EXPECT. OF
A IN A FINANCIAL INSTITUTION TO
TAKE A RISK ON YOU WHEN YOU'RE
A BAD RISK IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE WAY PEOPLE GET OUT OF THAT
SITUATION IS THEY GET THE SHORT
TERM LOANS AND YES THEY ARE A
VERY HIGH INTEREST RATE BUT
ONCE THEY GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS. THEN THEY GO TO. A
REGULAR FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
AND THEY GO LOOK. I USED I HAD
BAD CREDIT BUT OVER THE LAST
YEAR I'VE MAINTAIN MY PAYMENTS.
AT THIS HIGHER INTEREST RATE
AND THE EASE BACK INTO THEIR
CREDIT RATING SO THAT THEY CAN.
ESTABLISH A GOOD CREDIT AGAIN.
BUT TO REQUIRE OR CAT PEOPLE'S
INTEREST RATES AND I REALIZE
THAT THEY DO HAVE HIGH INTEREST
RATES. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT. YOU IF YOU CAP IT ARE
THEY REALLY GOING TO TAKE A
RISK AND INVEST AND LET PEOPLE
HAVE HIGH RISK LOANS. OUT THERE
SO THEY CAN TRY TO RE ESTABLISH
THEIR CREDIT. YOU'RE ASKING THE
BANKS OR THEIR ASKING LENDING
INSTITUTIONS ARE THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT LAND TO
THESE. PARTICULAR PEOPLE THAT
WANT. TO RE ESTABLISH THEIR
CREDIT AFTER DESTROYING IT. FOR
WHATEVER REASON. AND TO HAVE
THAT TO HAVE THAT CAP AND NOT.
AND NOT HAVE A LENDING
INSTITUTION AVAILABLE FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS CREDIT TO
REBUILD THEIR CREDIT. IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WILL
CAUSE A DETRIMENT TO HARM. TO
THEM IN THE LONG TERM THE
FUTURE MEYER J. NO VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR DORADO. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THESE. A PAYDAY. LOANS
AND DIDN'T HAVE A VERY
FAVORABLE ATTITUDE BUT I DIDN'T
THINK KIND OF THOUGHT THE WAY
MY COLLEAGUE JUST DESCRIBED
THAT. IT WAS AN OPPORTUNE FOR
POOR PEOPLE TO GET ACCESS TO
SOME MONEY BUT WHEN I SAW
ACTUAL AGREEMENTS. COPIES OF
AGREEMENTS. WHERE THEY HAD
BORROWED TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
MAYBE AND IT WENT UP TO TEN AND
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS
WHAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY GOING
TO PAY BACK. I WAS FLOORED I
WAS SHOCKED HOW COULD WE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF POOR PEOPLE THAT
WAY THAT MEANS THEY BECOME FOR
EVER INDEBTED. AND THEY CAN'T
KEEP UP AND THAT JUST SEEMED
LIKE A COMPLETE ABUSE SO
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TAKING A RISK AND COMPLETELY
ABUSING OF POOR PEOPLE AND
FORCING THEM TO STAY IN POVERTY
FOR MANY MORE YEARS SO THAT'S
FRANKLY WHAT CONVINCED ME TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. SENATE ALLEN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IS
ONE OF ALSO MENTION THAT WE DID
PUT IN THE SENATE FINANCIAL
LITERACY IN THIS BILL SO THAT
WE CAN EDUCATE THOSE FOLKS TO
WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY PAYING IN
A CAPTIVE SO I WANTED TO BRING
THAT POINT UP I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL IT WAS IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK THOSE
FOLKS WHO ARE TRYING TO GET
THAT THE LOANS NEED TO KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IN AND
HOPEFULLY IN THE FUTURE WE
WOULD TEACH THESE KIND OF
THINGS IN SCHOOL WHERE THE
COMPOUNDING INTEREST AS YOUR
FRIEND IF YOU'RE SAVING MONEY
AND IT YOUR ENEMY IF YOU'RE
BORROWING MONEY NO TO THE
THINGS. THAT PEOPLE TO BORROW
MONEY NEEDED NO. THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I WANT TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
HARD WORK ON IT THIS IS NOT AN
EASY SPACE TO DO WORK IN AND
THE REASON THAT IT'S NOT IS
THAT WHILE WE MAY NOT LIKE THE
INTEREST RATES THEY GET CHARGED
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT PEOPLE
NEED ACCESS TO MONEY. AND THEY
NEED A REGULATED INDUSTRY IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO GET ACCESS
TO THAT MONEY OTHERWISE IF WE
CLOSE OFF ALL THE ALTERNATIVES
THEY END UP GOING TO AN
UNREGULATED MARKET AND SO I
WANT TO JUST SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK THAT
WENT INTO THIS I APPRECIATE THE
COMPROMISES THAT WERE MADE AND
I WOULD. ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL. THE BILL
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUES CENTER
MATURE YOU MAY COSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I WOULD STRONGLY
SUGGEST THAT WE NOT. PAYING
THAT NINETY THE K. ABOUT CREDIT.
TO A SEARCH OR ASSUME THAT YOU
CAN EARN CREDIT BY BEING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF. BY SOMEONE WHO'S
GOING TO CHARGE YOU 2100% ON A
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR LOAN
IS JUST NOT THE CASE. HOW MANY
OF US HERE ON THE FLOOR KNOW
OFF THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD. THE
CREDIT THE INTEREST RATE YOU'RE
PAYING ON YOUR HOME LOAN OR THE
CREDIT CARDS IN YOUR BILL
FOLDER PURSE. HOW MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN LAID OR OUR DEBT
RATIO IS INCREASED AND OUR
INTEREST RATES HAVE INCREASED.
HAD IT BEEN PROACTIVE ENOUGH TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CALL THAT
CREDIT COMPANY OR THAT LOAN
HOLDER TO GET THAT INTEREST
RATE DOWN AND HOW QUICKLY DID
THAT INTEREST RATE DROPPED. SO
TO SUGGEST THAT ONE OF THESE
LOANS IS THE BEST WAY TO BUILD
CREDIT I THINK IS NOT ACCURATE.
IF THIS BILL PASSES WILL
BORROWER STILL HAVE ACCESS TO
CREDIT. THE ANSWER IS YES
LINDER THAT SUPPORT THE BILL
ARE ALREADY SERVING THE
MAJORITY BORROWS WHO CAN'T
QUALIFY FOR CREDIT CARD OR BANK
LOANS. THE AUTHOR HAS ALSO
HEARD FROM A NUMBER OF LENDERS
INTO HIS WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL WHO STATED THAT
THEY'LL RECONFIGURE TO COMPLY
WITH THE BILL WHY. BECAUSE THEY
ARE CLEAR THAT THERE IS A
MARKET OUT THERE. LET'S ALSO
NOT FORGET THAT MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
DEFAULT IN HIGH COST LOANS EACH
YEAR. THIS BILL WILL HELP TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE CREDIT
OPTIONS IN THE FUTURE. BECAUSE
THEIR FINANCIAL WELL BEING IS
NOT BEING RUINED BY ON
AFFORDABLE LOANS. IN THE EVENT
THAT NONE OF US HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE TO SECURE
ONE OF THESE LOANS LET ME WALK
YOU THROUGH A REAL LIFE
SCENARIO. JUST SO WE'RE ALL
CLEAR BEFORE WE CAST OUR VOTE.
HEY UNNAMEDCAR TITLE LOAN
COMPANY. GAVE A GENTLEMAN ALONE
FOR TWO THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS. WITH AN APR OF ONE
HUNDRED AND 23% WITH A THIRTY
FIVE MONTH TERM ON THE LOAN. BY
THE END OF THE LONG TERM THE
BORROWER WILL PAY EIGHT
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE DOLLARS IN INTEREST. A
TOTAL OF TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE DOLLARS TO
BORROW TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED.
THAT MAKES SENSE YOU THINK
THAT'S APPROPRIATE OR SAFE FOR
OR SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD
SIGN THE BOTTOM LINE WHEN
YOU'RE BACK WAS AGAINST THE
WALL AND YOU NEED TO TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS. THE LOAN
IS SECURED BY THE BORROWERS CAR.
AND IN THE FINE PRINT OF THE
CREDIT APPLICATION THEY ASK FOR
A COPY OF THE BORROWERS CAR
KEYS. THIS BORROWER WAS LURED
INTO THE STORE WITH SIGNS THAT
SAID THEY SPEAK SPANISH HOWEVER
NO EMPLOYEES SPOKE SPANISH AND
THEY GAVE HIM THE LOAN
DOCUMENTS ALL IN ENGLISH. THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF SCENARIOS THIS
BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO. ADDRESS.
I FOR ONE WOULD NEVER WANT A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE OR FAMILY
MEMBER TO BE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
WHEN THEY WERE ATTEMPTING. TO
DEAL WITH. ORDINARY REAL LIFE.
CHALLENGES AS I TELL RYAN THIS
CALL THE DAHLE TEAM. MOST OF US
ARE ONE OR TWO PAYCHECKS AWAY
FROM CRISES AS A RESULT OF A
HEALTH ISSUE WHEN THE CAR
BREAKS DOWN OR WHEN THE ROOF
LEAKS. EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
THEIR CARS PAY REASONABLE
CREDIT AND BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY IN AN
HONEST SINCERE WAY BUILD
CREDIT. TO BE ABLE TO TAKE YOUR
THEIR FAMILIES AND SECURE THEIR
FUTURES. LOTS OF EFFORT WENT
INTO THIS BILL IN TERMS OF
NEGOTIATIONS I APPRECIATE ALL
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE FLOOR AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE IN
AB FIVE THREE NINE. THANK YOU
ALL DISCUSSION DEBATE HAVEN'T
SEE SOME SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL BY
PORGES BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
BY CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD I
DORADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. FOR TITLE I
JACKSON BY JONES. NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI MONEY
I'M MORE LARK MORALE NIELSEN.
NO PAN HI PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE NO BURKE. OUR COUNTY
I WINNER HI WILK BY. THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES. FOR JUST. GALGIANI
GROWTH NO WAY SO. MORE LOCK NO
MORRELL. VICTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FROM ONE LAST
SHOT BATES. FOR JUST. GALGIANI
HUESO. MORRELL. ICE THIRTY FOUR
KNOWS FIVE. I'M SORRY ICE
THIRTY KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
IMPORTANT NONSENSE PURSUANT TO
SENATE ROLE FORTY THREE A VOTE
BY WHICH A BILL WAS PASSED ME
NOT BE RECONSIDERED ON THE
LAST. LEGISLATIVE DAY PRECEDING
ANTRUM RECESS WITH THAT SAID
MEMBERS PLEASE PAY ATTENTION TO
YOUR VOTES FOR TODAY. TURNER
MITCHELL FOR WHAT PURPOSE UNDER
MOST OF THE RESOLUTIONS IF I
MAY. THE GRANITE. I'D LIKE TO
MOVE AB ONE HUNDRED WHICH IS A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL I DON'T
HAVE A FILE NUMBER TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THIS WILL NOT.
AB ONE HUNDRED. THE BUDGET
TRAILER
. IT WAS LIKE FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN. THE WITH A
MISTER PRESIDENT IGNORE WHAT I
JUST ASK OF YOU. REVERSE DO WE
KNOW IT. REVERSE. SIR WAYS OF
WHAT PURPOSE UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MISTER PRESIDENT I
REQUEST. MISTER PRESIDENT I
READ. I REQUEST SILENCE THANK
YOU. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RETURN SENATE BILL
FOR SIXTEEN TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR
FURTHER ACTION THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THIS WILL NOTE.
JENNER MCGUIRE ONE IS RESIDENT
THANK YOU SIR WOULD YOU MIND
REMOVING FILE ITEM. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY NINE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RIVER. TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. DOES WILL NOTE.
IS THERE ANY OTHER ACTIONS
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
IF NOT WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK TO
SIMPLY THIRD READING. ITEM NEXT
ITEM UP IS ITEM FORTY SEVEN.
MADAM PROTIUM YOU'RE PREPARED
FOR THAT ITEM MISTER CLARK
PLEASE READ. A SOME OF THE ONE
EIGHTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACT REALLY TO
HAZARDOUS WASTE. MADAM PROTIUM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO PRESENT AB
ONE EIGHTY ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
THIS BILL RECONCILES A CONFLICT
BETWEEN FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
BY CLARIFYING THAT MILITARY
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO PAY ADVANCED
FEES FOR PERMIT APPLICATIONS TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC. SUBSTANCES CONTROL TO BE
CLEAR THE MILITARY WILL STILL
BE REQUIRED TO PAY ALL OF THE
REASONABLE SERVICE CHARGES
ASSOCIATED WITH PERMIT RENEWAL
AND ALL OTHER CHARGES APPROVED
BY SPECIFIC APPROPRIATION OR
FEDERAL LAW. THE BILL IS NEEDED
BECAUSE A NEW LEGAL CONFLICT
WAS BROUGHT ABOUT BY A TWENTY
SIXTEEN TRAILER BILL WHICH
CREATED A NEW FEE FOR SERVICE
PROGRAM REQUIRING 25% OF THE
COST TO BE PAID UP FRONT. FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITY
PERMITS THE CONFLICT IS THAT
FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS THE
MILITARY FROM ENGAGING IN
ADVANCE PAYMENTS. THE MILITARY
OPERATES SEVEN HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
ON A TEN YEAR PERMIT TIMELINE
IN SUPPORT OF THE MILITARY'S
NATIONAL SECURITY MISSION AND
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT SPECIFICALLY AFFECTS
A NAVAL BASE IN MY COMMUNITY
WHERE THE PERMIT IS CURRENTLY
UP FOR RENEWAL. THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITY ON NAVAL BASE
CORONADO AND CITY COUNTY TREATS
AND CONSOLIDATES A VARIETY OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE STREAMS I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER. HERE IN
SEEN NINE A MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS BY BATES
HI BILL. I PORGES. I BRADFORD
ART HI CAMBIADO I CHIANG AYE
DALY AYE DODD. BY DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROW BY HERTZBERG
AYE HILL. I HUESO BY TADO BY
JACKSON BY JONES. LEYVA I
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. BY MONNING
BY MORE LARK TIME REAL I
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR
CASSIE I WIENER AYE WILK HI.
SIR COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES BY. ALL
EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT CENTER PRO TEM
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS I
DON'T MISS SECTOR PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA. AND
ACTUALLY IN WATER. INTERACTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. ARE
PURE WATER SAN DIEGO IS THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO'S
GROUNDBREAKING WATER SUPPLY
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO SUPPLY ONE
THIRD OF THE CITY'S WATER
SUPPLY. THIS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PROJECT HAS BEEN TIED
UP AND WASTEFUL LITIGATION THAT
THREATENS THE COMPLETION OF OUR
PURE WATER. PROJECT AT A TIME
WHEN CLIMATE CHANGE AND CYCLES
OF DROUGHT IMPERIL OUR WATER
SECURITY. SINCE JUNE THE
PROJECT HAS BEEN STALLED DUE TO
LITIGATION CLAIMING THE PROJECT
VIOLATES PROPOSITION EIGHT
WHICH IS A TWENTY TWELVE LOCAL
BALLOT MEASURE. THAT PREVENTS
THE CITY FROM MANDATING PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS ON
CONSTRUCTION EXCEPT WHEN
REQUIRED BY STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW. AB TWELVE NINETY CLARIFIES
THAT THE PROJECT IS ONE FOR
WHICH STATE LAW REQUIRES
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS AND
WITHOUT THIS CLARIFICATION THE
COSTS ARE PROJECTED TO INCREASE
BY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EACH MONTH OF DELAY. WITHOUT
LEGAL CERTAINTY STATE FUNDS FOR
THE PROJECT OF WELL OVER SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ALREADY
INVESTED WOULD BE IN PERIL. AB
TWELVE NINETY IN THE PURE WATER
PROJECT TO ENSURE OUR WATER
RELIABILITY FOR THE SAN DIEGO
REGION FOR DECADES TO COME. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. CENTER STONE GOOD
MORNING MR PRESIDENT
CONGRATULATIONS COLLEAGUES ON
THE LAST DAY. THIRTEEN MORE
HOURS OF SESSION I RESPECTFULLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE
NINETY SPONSORED BY THE UNION
CAUCUS OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
THIS BILL WILL FORCE THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO TO JOIN A UNION
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT. IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE STATE FUNDING
FOR THEIR PEER WATER PROJECT
WATER WOULD BE AN ADVANCE
TREATMENT FACILITY THAT CAN
PRODUCE THIRTY MILLION GALLONS
OF PURIFIED WATER EVERY DAY.
FIGHTING FOR A THIRD OF SAN
DIEGO'S DRINKING WATER. WHICH I
THINK IS VERY INNOVATIVE. WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT CLEAN WATER
ON THE FLOOR THIS YEAR SO I'M
CURIOUS WHY ARE NOW TALKING
ABOUT STOPPING CLEAN WATER FROM
BEING DELIVERED TO MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE SECOND
LARGEST CITY. BUT LET ME GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BACKGROUND ON THIS
BILL. THE PEOPLE SPOKE BUT
PROPOSITION EIGHT PASSED BY 58%
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE NONE OF
THE CITY'S PROJECT OPPOSED
APPEAL A REQUIREMENT BUT I
GUESS THE BIG LEAD LABOR UNION
BOSSES DIDN'T LIKE WHAT THE
PEOPLE DECIDE AGAIN THE PEOPLE
AREN'T BEING LISTENED TO AND
SAY TO CALIFORNIA AND FRANKLY I
THINK HER GET A LITTLE BIT
UPSET. SO IN NOVEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO IN THE BIG LABOR
UNION BOSSES PASSED AN
ORDINANCE THAT KEPT. NON UNION
APPRENTICESHIPS. AND
APPRENTICES FROM WORKING ON
THREE OF THE PURE WATER
PROJECTS. IF BIG LABOR BOSSES
COULDN'T CONVINCE THE VOTERS. I
GUESS THEY FIGURE THEY CAN
INTIMIDATE THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO GIVE THEM THEIR
NGUYEN. BUT ABOUT A YEAR LATER
A LAWSUIT WAS FILED AGAINST THE
BIG LABOR UNION BOSSES. THE
COURT RULED THE CITY WAS WRONG.
AND THE FORCING ONLY UNION
APPRENTICES TO BE USED VIOLATED
THE PEOPLE'S INTENT OF
PROPOSITION A- AFTER THAT
RULING LEGAL KNOWS OF
NEGOTIATIONS BEGAN. AND THEY'RE
STILL GOING ON WHICH BRINGS ME
HERE TODAY. AB TWELVE MIND USE
GOAL IS TO RESOLVE A CITY LEGAL
DISPUTE OVER. AS THEY CONTROL
THIS LEGISLATURE THIS MEASURES
INTENT IS TO VIOLATE LOCAL
CONTROL AND THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS IN THE NAME OF BIG LABOR
UNION BOSSES. HOW MANY BILLS
ARE WE GOING TO SEE THIS YEAR
WHERE THE UNION CAUCUS. IS MORE
IMPORTANT TO THE VOTING MEMBERS
OF THIS BODY THAN THE CITIZENS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AB
TOLD MINE IS NOTHING MORE THAN
ANOTHER AGENDA ITEM FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE'S FAMED UNIT CAUCUS.
BIG LABOR'S Là BIG LABOR LOSS
IN SAN DIEGO WHEN THEY LOST
PROPOSITION EIGHT. THIS BILL IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A WAY FOR BIG
LABOR BOSSES TO GO. TO THEIR
FRIENDS ON THE LEGISLATURE TO
CHANGE THE RULES AFTER THE FACT
TO SUPPORT. THE WILL. OF THE
VOTERS IN SAN DIEGO MY FRIEND
YOU CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT THIS
IS THE WILL OF THE VOTE VOTERS.
AND IN SOME CASES ON ISSUES
YOU'RE AGREE WITH THEM. AND
SOME YOU JUST EGGS NOR THERE
WILL. IN ANOTHER ISSUES YOU
JUST DISAGREE WITH THEM ON
THOSE ISSUES THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE IS JUST THAT YOU CAN
PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH ISSUES
YOU THINK THE PEOPLE GOT RIGHT
AND WHICH ONES YOU THINK THEY
GOT WRONG. IF YOU'RE REALLY A
BELIEVER IN LOCAL CONTROL. IF
YOU'RE REALLY A BELIEVER THAT
THE CITIZENS OF THE STATE
REALLY CONTROL THIS STATE YOU
SHOULD VOTE NO ON THIS BILL. IF
IT PASSES IT SHOWS THAT THIS
BODY CARES MORE ABOUT TAKING
CARE OF THE UNIONS AND THEIR
BOSSES THAN LISTENING TO THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE. IN HONOR OF
THE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE THAT-DEPEND ON US TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS FOR THEM. AND NOT FOR
THE UNIONS I URGE A NO VOTE IN
AB TWELVE NINETY. THANK YOU
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT TIE RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWELVE
NINETY. COLLEAGUES PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS DO NOT HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL TRACK RECORD I WILL
SPARE YOU THE DETAILS BUT I CAN
GIVE YOU PLENTY. FROM THE CITY.
AND COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO. ARE
CURRENTLY. SOME 10% OF BUILDING
CONTRACTORS IN SAN DIEGO OUR
UNION SHOPS. WHY SHUT OUT 90%
OF THIS INDUSTRY. ESPECIALLY AS
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM TEMECULA
POINTED OUT WHEN SAN DIEGO
VOTERS RECENTLY VOTED AGAINST
REQUIRING PLA'S UNLESS FORCED
TO. THE COURT UPHELD THIS
BALLOT MEASURE JUST LAST MONTH.
SO IF YOU FAIL AT THE BALLOT.
AND IF YOU FAIL AT THE BENCH.
YOU COME TO THE BANKS OF THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER. AND ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO AN END RUN.
THAT MY COLLEAGUES IS CLASSIC
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS. TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS BODY TO DO AN
END RUN WE SHOULD BE POOR. AND
WE SHOULD BE INDEPENDENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
ON A. B. TWELVE NINETY THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWELVE NINETY. BUT JUST WANTED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I BELIEVE
IT WAS JUST YESTERDAY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM TO MACULA DURING
THE DEBATE ON THE- STUDENT
BUILT TALKED ABOUT. HOW HE
ENJOYED THE DIP THE DEBATE AND
HE WISHES WE'D HAD MORE OF THAT
KIND OF DEBATE. AND YET IT'S MY
VERY SAME COLLEGE FROM TO
MEDICAL WHOSE AND GAVE THE NAME
CALLING AT ELEVEN THIRTEEN AM
THE FIRST HOUR OF OUR SESSION.
WELL I WOULD HOPE THAT IN THE
NEXT THIRTEEN HOURS THAT WE CAN
ALL. OF SHY AWAY FROM LANGUAGE
THATGENERALLY LACKS CIVILITY
AND ENGAGING HEARTY DEBATE ON
THE POLICY ISSUES THAT. AFFECT
THE FORTY MILLION CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WITH THAT I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE NINETY.
THURSTONE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
KIND OF CAME IN MY COMMENTS ON
THE FLOOR OVER THE PAST YEAR
BUT I BRING UP WHAT I CONSIDER
TO BE A PROPER DESCRIPTION OF A
UNION CAUCUS BUT I'M GONNA TELL
YOU ONE THING THAT I STRONGLY
RESENT ON THIS FLOOR I STRONGLY
RESENT BY TWO OR THREE MEMBERS-OF THIS LEGISLATURE LECTURING
TO ME LIKE I'M ONE OF THEIR
KIDS. YOU DON'T. I GOT A LOT
LECTURES WHEN I WAS
UNIVERSITIES I GOT A FEW
LECTURES FROM A JEWISH MOM. BUT
I DON'T NEED ANYBODY ON THE
FLOOR THE SENATE TO LECTURE TO
ME. ABOUT HOW I SHOULD DEFEND
THE CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THOSE OF
MY DISTRICT. AND SO I WILL
CONTINUE. TO ADVOCATE I HAVE
ALWAYS DISPLAYED I THINK COMMON
COURTESY TO PEOPLE ON THIS
FLOOR I DON'T ENGAGE IMPORTER
ATTACK IN ORDER ALTHOUGH I'VE
BEEN CALLED A RACIST THE
FOLLOWING ORDER ORDER WE RUN
OUT FOR THE ONE ON THE ROAD%
MORE AND I'M JUST GOING TO PUT
UP WITH IT ANYMORE MISTER
PRESIDENT. AND FURTHER REASONER
STONE I'M CALLING YOU TO ORDER
WE'RE GONNA YES SEIZE WITH THIS
RIGHT NOW THAT I JUST WANT YOU
KNOW MISTER PRESIDENT THAT I'M
NOT GOING TO TOLERATE BEING
LECTURED TO ANYMORE I HAD WILL
BE CENTER STONE WE- HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR I'M NOT GOING TO LET
THE INSTITUTION. STONE WHEN I
SEE PRESIDENT A QUORUM. WE'RE
ASKING ALL MEMBERS TO IT HERE
TOO A BIT OF STABILITY INTO
CORN TODAY THIS IS OUR LAST DAY
OF SESSION SO. YES MISTER
PRESIDENT OR TO BRING PUBLIC IN
CAUCUS PLEASE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WERE ASKING YOU TO TAKE
YOUR SEATS WERE ASKING YOU GO
BACK TO YOUR DESK AND SIT DOWN.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE BOX LOUNGE
ROW FOR WHAT PURPOSE. AS A
REPUBLICAN LEADER POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE. RENDON YOU
MAY PROCEED. THE DECORUM IN
THIS HOUSE GETS THROWN OUT OF
WHACK BY MAINLY ONE GROUP ONE
PERSON. AND MY COLLEAGUES ARE
DONE. AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT DECENCY AND RESPECT GOES
BOTH WAYS. AND WHEN THEY HAVE
POINTS ON A BILL THAT ARE VALID
AND THAT ARE NOT OUT OF ORDER
FOR YOU TO BULLY THEM INTO A
PLACE OF WITH YOUR ROLE LEAN
EYES YOUR SMIRKS SMILES. YOUR
HOSTILE LOOKS TO MY MEMBERS IT
IS AN ACCEPTABLE FOR YOU TO
COME ON THIS SIDE OF THE FLOOR
AND COME OVER TO THE DESK OF
ONE OF MY MEMBERS WHEN THE
CHAIR OR THE PRESIDENT. IS
CALLING THE HOUSE BACK TO ORDER
IS AN ACCEPTABLE AND I'M ASKING
YOU PERSONALLY TO REFRAIN FROM
YOUR CONTACT CENTER GROW WERE
ASKING EVERYONE TO. THE COLUMN
TODAY SO LET'S NOT SINGLE OUT
ANY IN. WHY WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT MISTER PRESIDENT I
THINK IT'S JUST ONE INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS CAUSING THAT CONFLICT ON
THE FLOOR WITH NO. NO CALLING
OUT INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS SENATOR
GROW DIDN'T NAME A PERSON DID
THE SAME THING THAT SHE DOES TO
US WHEN SHE LOOKS ACROSS THE
FLOOR SENATOR GROW WORK WE'RE
GONNA SHOOT TO REFRAIN FROM THE
HOUSE OKAY. AGAIN I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO CALL THE QUORUM IN THIS
HOUSE AND I WOULD LIKE THE
BULLEEN TO STOP. THANK YOU.
MEMBERSHIP. HELLO BACK ON THE
BILL. IF MY COLLEAGUES WOULD
ALLOW. AB TWELVE NINETY AND THE-
I APPRECIATE. I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION I
CAN I CAN MAKE POINTS I WOULD.
I WOULD. POINT OF PRIVILEGE
BEFORE I GO INTO THE LANGUAGE
OR THE BILL. I HAVE THE
GREATEST OF RESPECT FOR EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IN THIS CHAMBER. WE
HAVE POLITICAL AND
PHILOSOPHICAL AGREEMENTS AND
DISAGREEMENTS WE ALWAYS WILL
HAVE. WHERE IN THE LAST DAY OF
SESSION. I WILL ASK EACH
COLLEAGUES. TO REMEMBER IT'S
GOING TO BE A LONG AND TOUGH
ENOUGH DAY AS IT IS. AND I YOU
KNOW WE CAN TAKE THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND TO OUR
VARIOUS CACUSES AS NEED BE.
AND I EXPECT WE WILL. BUT I
WOULD JUST ASK FOR US TO MOVE
ALONG AND LET'S GET SOME WORK
DONE AND AFTER I DO THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
TO MY COUNTY. I AM HAPPY TO
ENGAGE IN CONVERSATION OFF THE
FLOOR WITH ANY INDIVIDUAL THAT
WOULD LIKE TO COME TALK TO ME.
MISTER PRESIDENT CAN I CONTINUE
WITH AB TWELVE NIGHT SHE MAY.
CONTINUE THANK YOU THE POINTS
ARE THAT WERE MADE AND I DO
KNOW THAT THIS ISSUE. ARE
RELATED TO HOW PROJECTS GET
DONE IN PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS AND- HOW LOCAL
PROJECTS GET DONE WILL ALWAYS
BE A MATTER OF CONTENTION. ON
THIS PROJECT I WANT TO MAKE A
COUPLE OF POINTS. THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY IS IN
SUPPORT AND ASK MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO BRING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FORWARD. FOR A VERY.
VERY SIMPLE REASON. BOB FOR THE
WATER AUTHORITY WHICH IS MADE
UP OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CITIES. IN THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO EIGHTEEN CITIES IN THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
PARTICIPATE ARE PART OF THIS
WATER AUTHORITY. THEY HAVE
ENGAGED ON THIS PURE WATER
PROJECT TO HELP SAN DIEGO
BECOME MORE WATER RELIABLE AND
SELF SUSTAINING. WE ARE THE END
OF THE PIPELINE THIS PROJECT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO US IN
TERMS OF FRANKLY NOT JUST FOR
THE COUNTY AND OF SAN DIEGO IN
THE REGION BUT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE MORE. SELF
RELIANT WE ARE AND WE'VE DONE
INCREDIBLE WORK IN SAN DIEGO MY
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE KNOW THAT OUR DELEGATION
KNOWS HOW MUCH WORK SAN DIEGO
HAS DONE ON CONSERVATION
CERTAINLY ON STORAGE. BY ON
PURE WATER ON DESALINATION WE
HAVE BEEN VERY CREATIVE. THIS
PROJECT IS IMPORTANT. THE
RESOURCES TO GET THIS PROJECT
DONE MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS HAVE COME FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BASICALLY
IN YES WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT I WILL OWN IT BASICALLY
SAYS THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
WILLING TO DO PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS. WE STAND TO LOSE
THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE WORK SO HARD TO GET AS
PART OF THIS PROJECT. AND SO WE
CAN MAKE IT ABOUT ARE ALL KINDS
OF ISSUES. TODAY I SIMPLY STAND
HERE TO TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE A
PROJECT THAT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR COUNTY AND
THEIR CERTAINLY SEEMS TO BE
SOME DISCUSSION OVER THE
LANGUAGE IN OUR LOCAL
PROPOSITION. PROPOSITION A FROM
TWENTY TWELVE IF YOU LOOK AT
THE ANALYSIS IT SAYS THERE IS
NOTHING IN MEASURE A TO IMPEDE
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WE
ARE SIMPLY TRYING TO GET OUR
PROJECT DONE. SO FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WANT TO LOOK AT
IT MULTIPLE WAYS YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT
PHILOSOPHICALLY WHAT DO SUPPORT
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS OR
NOT. I WOULD ALSO SAY I'M
PRETTY SURE THAT THERE'RE ARE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE GONE WELL
AND NOT WELL BUT- YOU KNOW
EXAMPLES OF SUCCESSFUL PLA'S
INCLUDE THE HOOVER DAM DISNEY
WORLD. OUR NEW STATE BUILDINGS
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION AT
TWELFTH AND NEW COURTHOUSE
CONSTRUCTION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IN ONE OF OUR MAJOR
PROJECTS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WAS UNDER AND TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FROM THE SOUTH BAY IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. REMEMBER AS WELL
THAT WE DID A VERY SUCCESSFUL
FIRST TIME EVER PL A PROJECT
THROUGH THE WATER AUTHORITY AND
WE SAVED MONEY AND THE PROJECT
WAS DONE. BY EARLY NOT ON TIME
BUT EARLY SO WE CAN DEBATE
THOSE THINGS WE HAVE EXAMPLES
OF GOOD PROJECTS. THAT HAVE
GOTTEN DONE BUT TODAY WHAT I
WOULD ASK IS THAT YOU SUPPORT
MY LOCAL COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE
ARE TRYING TO GET ARE PURE
WATER PROJECT DONE WHICH IS
GOING TO HELP OUR COUNTY BE
MORE. WATER SUSTAINABLE SELF
SUSTAINABLE AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS MEASURES ABOUT TODAY SO TO
GIVE THE CLARITY SO THAT WE CAN
KEEP THE RESOURCES AND NOT
INCREASE THE COST OF THIS
PROJECT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE IN SUPPORT. OF MY
LOCAL. COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO
TO GET THIS PROJECT DONE. THANK
YOU ALL DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
HAVEN'T SEES TO MISTER SECTOR
ISLAND MR TO CENTER JONES.
SORRY MR PRESIDENT HAS A BIT
LATE GETTING MY MICROPHONE UP I
DO WANT TO RISE IN. OPPOSITION
TO AB TWELVE NINETY AS I'VE
SHARED ON THIS FOR MANY TIMES.
YOU KNOW I COME FROM A UNION
FAMILY AND I TRY TO SUPPORT
LOCAL UNION PRODUCTS IN EFFORTS
WHEN I CAN. AND WHEN THE PRICE
IN THE QUALITY IS COMPETITIVE.
THE PROBLEM WITH AB TWELVE
NINETY IS THAT IT SEEKS TO
FORCE THE PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT WHERE ONE IS NOT
NEEDED OR APPROPRIATE. VOTERS
IN SAN DIEGO HAVE ALREADY MADE
THE DECISION THAT P. L. A.'S.
SHALL NOT BE REQUIRED IMPROPER
ON PUBLIC PROJECTS OKAY UNIONS
SHALL NOT BE SENATE DISTRICT.
UNIONS SHALL NOT BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. NOR
SHALL THEY BE GRANTED
FAVORITISM. I CAN LIVE WITH
THAT DECISION BY THE VOTERS AND
I'M MYSTIFIED WHY THIS KEEPS
COMING UP AND THE MAJOR IS SO
AGAINST FOLLOWING THE WILL OF
THE VOTERS. THE PURE. INCREASES
WATER RELIABILITY AND SECURITY
FOR YEARS TO COME. FRIVOLOUS
LEGISLATION SUCH AS AB TWELVE
NINETY WILL ONLY INCREASE
LITIGATION WHICH WILL CONTINUE
TO DELAY THE WATER THE PURE
WATER PROJECT I SINCERELY
URGING NO VOTE ON A. B. TWELVE
NINETY THANK YOU. NOW THIS IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IF NOT
MADAM PROTIUM YOU CAN CLOSE
ONCE AGAIN I WILL CLOSE ONE
MORE TIME BY SAYING. THE
RESOURCES IN THE ADDITIONAL
FOUR MILLION ON A MONTHLY BASIS
IN THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY HAS GOTTEN. IF WE
DON'T SUCCESSFULLY DEAL WITH
THIS ISSUE THIS COSTS WILL BE
PASSED ON TO OUR RATE PAYERS.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE HAPPEN IN MY COUNTY WERE
WERE COST WE ALREADY ARE PAYING
COSTS TO SUPPORT. THE SELF
STORAGE CONSERVATION PROGRAMS
THIS PURE WATER PROGRAM THERE'S
A LOT RIDING ON THIS AND I
WOULD JUSTSAY. I REALLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT ON SOMETHING AND
THAT WILL SAVE TAXPAYERS
DOLLARS AND AT THE SAME TIME
HONOR OUR COMMITMENT. TO
PROVIDE RELIABLE WATER IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE. GOSH IN A DEBATE I'VE
SPECIES MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES NO.
ATKINS I BELL BY BURGESS NO
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG.
DALY DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ BY GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
TADO BY JACKSON HI JONES. NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
BY MONEY BY MORE LUCK NUMBER
RAIL NO NIELSEN NO PAN. BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
BY SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NO BERG BY WHAT COUNTY I WINNER
BY WILK NO. SECURE PLEASE
CALLED UP TO MEMBERS CHIANG.
DALLY GLAZER. OURS TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS NINE THEN THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SENATOR
WALKER YOU PREPARE TO TAKE UP
THAT ITEM. YES MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR WORK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN LIBERATED
GONZALEZ FLETCHER I AM PROUD TO
INTRODUCE A CA FOURTEEN AS A
RESOLUTION TO PLACE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY STANDARDS ON THE
BALLOT. EACH OF YOU WILL BE
SURE VOTE ON YOUR OWN CRITERIA.
FOR SOME OF YOU THE ISSUE IS
EQUITY. THE STATE AUDITOR
REPORTED TO US IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN THAT OUTSOURCED
SERVICE WORKERS WOMEN AND MEN
WHO CLEAN THE TOILETS CUT THE
GRASS. COOK THE FOOD AN EMPTY
THE BED PANS EARN ON AVERAGE
THREE DOLLARS AND EIGHTY SIX
CENTS LESS PER HOUR THEN YOU
SEE EMPLOYEES WHO DO THE EXACT
SAME WORK. THE STATE AUDITOR
FOUND THAT MOST OF THE SEVEN
THOUSAND TO NINE THOUSAND OUT
SOURCE SERVICE WORKERS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTH INSURANCE. AND HE'S
CALIFORNIANS ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
IN THE GRANTS IN AFRICAN
AMERICANS. OTHERS IF YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE WORTHY OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. I
WILL REMIND YOU THAT THE LAST
CONSTITUTIONAL MINUTE WE PUT ON
THE BALLOT. WAS SCA NINE HE
WENT TO THE BALLOT WITH
UNANIMOUS VOTE. OF THIS AND
PREP PRACTICALLY EVERY EVERY
SENATOR ON THIS FLOOR. PAST
SAID IT WAS APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS THAT AMENDED ALLOWED
HOMEOWNERS TO INSTALL RAIN
WATER CAPTURE SYSTEMS IN THEIR
HOMES WITHOUT HAVING THOSE
SYSTEMS ADD O INCREASE
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENT.
VALUATIONS WELL THERE HASN'T
BEEN A SINGLE HOME THERE HAS
BEEN MANY HOMEOWNERS WHO'VE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE THIS PROPERTY
DID TAX BREAK TODAY WE HOPE
THERE WILL BE. OTHERS OF YOU
MIGHT BE CONCERNED ABOUT HAM
STRINGING YOU SEE MEDICAL
CENTERS AND DENYING THEM
NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY TO MEET
FLUCTUATIONS IN PATIENT COUNTS
OTHER TEMPORARY STAFFING NEEDS.
I WANT TO DIRECT YOU TO YOUR
ATTENTION TO PAGE FIVE OF THE
ACA WE ACTUALLY AMENDED INTO
THE MEASURE UC'S OWN PER DIEM
EMPLOYEE POLICY TO ALLOW THAT
FLEXIBILITY. AND THE SENATOR
FROM SANTA ANA ADDED AN
AMENDMENT TO FURTHER GUARANTEE
FLEXIBILITY FOR YOU SEE MEDICAL
CENTERS. IN ADDITION TO EQUITY
ANOTHER CONCERN THAT I
PERSONALLY HAD WAS COST. AN
ANALYSIS WAS CONDUCTED BY MIKE
GYMNAST WHO MANY YOU KNOW WAS
THAT THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
FOR OUR LAST REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER.
IN HIS ANALYSIS WAS CLEAR THAT
HE CA FOURTEEN MEETS THE
STANDARDS OF REPUBLICAN FISCAL
PRUDENCE. THE INCREASED COST OF
WISHING BENEFIT PARITY FOR THE
SERVICE WORKERS IS COMPLETELY
OFFSET BY THE SAVINGS IN
OVERHEAD AND STILL LEAVES
ACCORDING TO MY CHEN S. THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR ANY
OVERHEAD OR ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS YOU SEE MIGHT INCUR.
ALLOW ME TO READ THE LAST
SENTENCE OF HIS ANALYSIS QUOTE
WE CONCLUDE THAT YOU SEE CAN
ABSORB THE COST TO BE CA
FOURTEEN WITHIN THE AMOUNTS
CURRENTLY BUDGETED FOR THE
EXISTING CONTRACTS IN QUOTE.
SENATORS THE WORK HAS BEEN DONE
THIS CASE IS CLEAR AND CLEAN
AND IF WE HAVE THE POWERS OF
BODY TO ADOPT A CA FOURTEEN. I
AM CONFIDENT WE WOULD. BUT THAT
POWER IS RESERVED TO THE VOTERS
SO LET'S GIVE THE PEOPLE WHO
ELECT US THE CHANCE TO ADOPT
THE EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY STANDARD ACT.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
PROJECT. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA
FOURTEEN. SOME MAY WONDER WHY
THE LEGISLATURE'S TAKEN UP THE
ISSUE AND I THINK THE ANSWER TO
THAT IS SIMPLE WE MUST. WE MUST
BECAUSE THE STATE CONSTITUTION
GIVES THE UC REGENTS POWER OVER
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS THE ONLY WAY TO
ADDRESS AN ISSUE PLAGUING THE
SYSTEM. I AND THAT IS THROUGH A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. WE
MUST BECAUSE WORKING PEOPLE
EMPLOYED IN OUR RENOWNED
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM ARE GETTING
CUT OUT OF JOBS. THEY'RE
GETTING CUT OUT OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS. HIGHER EDUCATION IS THE
BACKBONE OF OUR MIDDLE CLASS
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS THE CROWN JEWEL
OF OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM.
BUT THE UC UNDERMINES ITS
BENEFITS TO THE MIDDLE CLASS BY
FAILING TO PROVIDE STABLE A
STABLE LIFESTYLE FOR THE
WORKERS THAT THE UC DEPENDS ON.
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS THE UC
HAS CONTRACTED OUT THOUSANDS OF
SUPPORT SERVICES JOBS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY IT'S AN ECONOMIC
DECISION SEEMINGLY MADE WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION OF HOW THESE
CHOICES MADE BY THE UC AFFECT
THE LIVES OF THEIR WORKERS.
EACH TIME THE UC MAKES THIS
CHOICE ELIMINATES THE STABILITY
OF A JOB THAT HAS HEALTH
BENEFITS AND A SECURE
RETIREMENT. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TRIED TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN
RECENT YEARS WITH MULTIPLE
BILLS AN AUDIENCE UNFORTUNATELY
NONE OF THIS HAS LED TO THE
UNIVERSITY CHANGE LET THE
UNIVERSITY TO CHANGE ITS
BEHAVIOR DESPITE THE CLEAR
INTENT. AND MESSAGE SENT BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THIS IS BEEN AN
ISSUE FOR DECADES. THE UC HAS
BEEN CONTRACTING OUT AND
ATTEMPTING TO CIRCUMVENT ITS
OWN WORKERS FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS. BACK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE UCLA HARDEN
OUTSIDE CUSTODIAL FORM TO
SERVICE A GYMNASTICS
CHAMPIONSHIP. AND THREATEN TO
USE CONTRACT ESTONIANS FOR THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR OLYMPICS.
THE HIRING CHOICES MADE IN THE
EIGHTIES WERE A SHORT SIGHTED
THEN AS THEY ARE TODAY. FARMING
OUT LOW WAGE JOBS RESULTED
WORKERS BEING FORCED TO LIVE ON
THE FRIENDS AND HAVING TO RELY
ON GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES AND
HEALTH CARE. CHOOSING TO
PROVIDE STABLE JOBS ON THE
FRONT IN INSURES THAT PEOPLE
CAN PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
BENEFITS RETIREMENT EVERY UC
EMPLOYEES SHOULD HAVE THAT
STABILITY. THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO RAISE THEIR CHILDREN TO
FLOURISH AND HOPEFULLY ONE DAY
IN ROLE AT ONE OF OUR GREAT
UNIVERSITIES THAT IS THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM THAT BUILDS A
STRONGER MIDDLE CLASS. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NURSING
ASSISTANTS COOKS CUSTODIAN
STERILE PROCESSING TECHNICIANS
GROUNDS KEEPERS. THESE ARE THE
WORKERS DOING THE DIRTY TOUGH
JOBS THE WORKERS WHOSE EFFORTS
MIGHT NOT BE TOP OF THE MIND
WHEN YOU THINK OF YOU SEE ARTS
MEDICAL CENTERS. BUT THEIR
INTERNAL TO THE SUCCESS OF OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THE AVERAGE
SUPPORT SERVICE WORKER YOU SEE
IS PAID ON AVERAGE AS I SAID
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR. WHICH IS IRONICALLY
THE AVERAGE TAKE HOME PAY. FOR
THE UC SENIOR EXECUTIVES PER
MONTH. WILL A CA HINDER THE
UC'S ABILITY TO RUN THEIR
MEDICAL CENTERS I THINK THE
MANAGER OF THE BILL RESPONDED
TO THAT ISSUE SO I DON'T NEED
TO GO FURTHER INTO THAT. THE
ACA FOURTEEN MAKES PROVISIONS
FOR THOSE SITUATIONS.
CONTRACTING OUT HAS ITS PLACE.
AND THIS MEASURE CONTINUES TO
ALLOW FOR PER DIEM EMPLOYEES AS
ALSO WAS MENTIONED SO I THINK
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD SEE WHAT CHANGE NEEDS TO
HAPPEN NOW. IT IS A PHENOMENAL
INSTITUTION THAT WE'RE ALL
PROUD TO CHAMPION ACA FOURTEEN
INTERESTS THAT ARE PRIVATE ALSO
CAN EXTEND TO THE UC'S
PRACTICES AS AN EMPLOYER.
COLLEAGUES WE PASSED A LAW THIS
WEEK THAT HOLDS CORPORATIONS TO
A HIGHER STANDARD AND DISALLOWS
CLASSIFYING EMPLOYEES AS
CONTRACTORS IN ORDER TO SKIRT
FAIR WAGES AND BENEFITS. WE
SHOULD HOLD THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE SIMILAR HIGH
STANDARDS. IN THE END A CA
FOURTEEN SIMPLY ALLOWS FOR THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA TO DECIDE
WHAT IS BEST FOR THE UC AND ITS
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES. ON
A MORE PERSONAL NOTE YOU KNOW I
KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE I'VE ALREADY
TALKED A LOT THIS MORNING. BUT
IN FACT I'VE MANAGED ONLY THREE
BILLS ALL DISTRICT RELATED
BILLS ONLY THREE. AND ONE MAJOR
BILL THE TENET PROTECTIONS BILL
I AM SPEAKING ON THIS ONE
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IF WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE ACTIONS THAT
WE TAKE HERE TO SUPPORT WORKERS
I DON'T SEE HOW WE CANNOT TAKE
THIS ACTION TODAY AND AT LEAST.
GIVE THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON
THIS ISSUE THEY HAVE THAT RIGHT
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON A CA FOURTEEN. THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT MEASURE.
YOU CENTER OUR GELATO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY IS PROUD CO AUTHOR.
AC A FOURTEEN GREAT LEADERS IN
OUR NATION ARE FOR SERVICES
HAVE ALWAYS MADE SURE THAT OUR
SOLDIERS HOLDING THE LOWEST
RANKS ARE BEING TAKEN OF TAKING
CARE OF EACH AND EVERY DAY WE
SAY THAT AGAIN GREAT LEADERS IN
OUR NATION'S ARMED SERVICES
HAVE ALWAYS MADE SURE THAT OUR
SOLDIERS HOLDING THE LOWEST
RANKS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN TAKEN
CARE OF FIRST. LEADERSHIP THAT
IS BEING TAUGHT IN OUR MILITARY
INSTITUTIONS EMPHASIZED THAT AN
OFFICER SOMEONE AND LEADERSHIP
POSITION MUST ALWAYS TAKE CARE
OF HIS SUBORDINATES FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE GOVERNMENT WE LEAD
IT SHOULD DO THE SAME SADLY OUR
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
DEVIATED FROM THESE CORE VALUES.
EVEN IF YOU'RE COOKING CLEANING
CUTTING THE GRASS YOU'RE
WORKING FOR THE UC SYSTEM YOU
SHOULD BE PAID AS A UC EMPLOYEE.
TERRY RUNS ON THE PRINCIPLE OF
EQUALITY AND MERIT AND SO
SHOULD OUR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM THIS IS WHY I
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU SENATOR
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO A CA FOURTEEN. IT'S SORT OF
COMES INTO THAT WHO'S YOUR
DADDY. CATEGORY IS IT GONNA BE
MANAGEMENT OR IS IT GOING TO BE
LABOR. COLLEAGUES THE UC SYSTEM
HAD AN UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT
THE LAST TWO YEARS OF NINETEEN
BILLION DOLLARS. THIS IS DUE TO
GRANTING GREAT BENEFITS TO ITS
WORKFORCE. MAINLY THE AN. PAID
RETIREE MEDICAL LIABILITIES. SO
THE UC SYSTEM IS FACING FISCAL
STRESS. TAKING COST SAVING
OUTSOURCING OFF THE TABLE. WILL.
AT THE END RESULT IN INCREASED
TUITION. THE MONEYHAS TO COME
FROM SOMEWHERE. NO WONDER THE
UC SYSTEM ITSELF OPPOSES AC
EIGHT FOURTEEN. THE BORDER
REGIONS WILL POINT TO THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE VOTERS
SHOULD THE PROPOSITION SUCCEED
WHEN IT ANNOUNCES ITS NEXT
TUITION INCREASE. AND THEY WILL
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO SO.
CONSEQUENTLY. I BELIEVE THE
VOTERS WILL OPPOSE THE BALLOT
MEASURE. BUT WE SHOULD SAVE
THEM THE FRUSTRATION OF TELLING
SACRAMENTO TO LET MANAGERS
MANAGE. I RESPECTFULLY URGE A
NO VOTE ON A CA FOURTEEN THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER WHITE HOUSE. MISTER
PRESIDENT YESTERDAY DURING THE
PRAYER OUR OWN SYSTEM MICHELLE
GORMAN QUOTED FROM ALICE WALKER
IN YOU MAY RECALL IT WAS WAKE
UP THE WORLD HAS CHANGED. YOU
KNOW WE CANNOT IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE TELL PRIVATE
INDUSTRY TO TREAT THEIR
EMPLOYERS THEIR EMPLOYEES AS
EMPLOYEES AND NOT INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WHILE TOLERATING
THE SAME BEHAVIOR WITHIN OUR
OWN UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM. THE FACT THAT YOU SEE
ITSELF ESTIMATES THAT THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT WOULD
FORCE THEM TO INCREASE WAGES
AND BENEFIT LEVELS BY AT LEAST
25% THE THAT MEANS THAT THEY'RE
UNDER COMPENSATING HUNDREDS OF
CONTRACT WORKERS FOR TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. WE NEED TO COMBAT
COMBAT THIS DOWN RULES PRESSURE
ON WAGES IN OUR OWN HOUSE I'M
ALSO CO AUTHOR ENERGY NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS.
THANK YOU A MISTER PRESIDENT TO
AND MEMBERS I KNOW THAT THE
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE IN THE
SUPPORTERS COME AT THIS ISSUE
WITH IT WITH A GOOD HEART THEY
CARE ABOUT ARE WORKING PEOPLE
AT THE UNIVERSITY AND ELSEWHERE
THEY WANT THEM TO HAVE A DECENT
LEVEL OF PAY AND BENEFITS AND I
KNOW THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
I CERTAINLY SHARE ON I BELIEVE
EVERYBODY ON THE FLOOR SHARES.
BUT THIS MEASURE IS A IS A
DRASTIC ONE. AND IF I COULD I'M
GONNA REFERENCE THE ANALYSIS
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED EACH
MEMBER. ON THIS. IT'S A THIS
ONE SECOND. IT SAYS THIS THAT
IT PROVIDES THE REGION'S FOR
THE CAMPUS. MAY CONTRACT FOR
LABOR TO PERFORM SUPPORT
SERVICES ONLY IF AUTHORIZED TO
DO SO BY STATUTE AND ONLY FOR
LIMITED EXCEPTIONS INCLUDE
AMONG OTHER THINGS A BONAFIDE
EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCE. SO TO
CHANGE FROM OF THE PROVISIONS
IN THIS MEASURE REQUIRES THAT
THEY HAVE LIMITED EXCEPTIONS
AND THEY HAVE TO DO SO BY
STATUTE AND DO SO BY STATUTE
MEANS THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO
PASS A LAW TO ALLOW. THAT
CONTRACTING OUT PROVISIONS. SO
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW. THE
MEASURE BEFORE US IS A COMPLETE
BAN ON CONTRACTING OUT FOR A
WIDE RANGE OF SERVICES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES. AND THEIR HOSPITALS
NO MATTER HOW SHORT TERM. AN
EXPECTED OR NECESSARY THEY MAY
BE. AND AS I SAID THE ONLY.
SIGNIFICANT SECTION TO THAT IS
IF THEY GOT STATUTORY APPROVAL
THAT MEANS THEY WOULD BE
LEGISLATION FIRST TO ALLOW AT
THE HIRING OF SHORT TERM
EMERGENCY HOSPITAL WORKERS.
LIKE STAFFING UP TO RESPOND TO
A NATURAL DISASTER CAN YOU
IMAGINE THEM COMING IN ASKING
FOR A LAW. DO WITH THAT. IT
REQUIRES THE LEGISLATION TO
TRAIN YOU SEE EMPLOYEES. ON
SAFETY IMPROPERLY USE SPECIAL
EQUIPMENT. IT WOULD REQUIRE LAW.
FOR AND TO ANTICIPATED SPECIAL
EVENTS I EVEN WHEN THE
UNIVERSITY HAS LESS THAN THIRTY
DAYS TO PLAN FOR IT SUCH AS
SPEAKERS I CAMPUS REQUIRE AN
EXTRA SECURITY AND CLEAN UP.
AND EVEN REQUIRES LEGISLATION
FOR STAFF FOR SOME STUDENT
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS. THE TAKEN
AWAY THAT FLEXIBILITY ON
CLINICAL CARE STAFFING
DECISIONS. FROM MY POINT OF
VIEW IS GOING TO CREATE IMPACT
ON VULNERABLE PATIENTS AND BY
THE WAY 60% OF. YOU SEE
PATIENTS ARE MEDI CAL FOR
MEDICARE. SUPPORTED NOW THIS
WOULD ONLY APPLY TO UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA NOT TO ANY OTHER
HOSPITAL OR INSTITUTION IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU SEE WOULD HAVE
TO HIRE FULL TIME EMPLOYEES FOR
WORK HE NEEDS DONE ONLY
OCCASIONALLY. TURN OF LATE YOU
SEE WOULD HAVE TO DECREASE THE
SERVICES IT PROVIDES THE
STUDENTS. PATIENTS AND THE
PUBLIC. AND THINK ABOUT THIS
YOU SEE WITH A WITH A SHOULD I
DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD BE
FORCED. THE HIRE WORKERS FOR
THINGS THAT THEY NEED DONE A
FEW TIMES A YEAR CAN YOU
IMAGINE IF YOUR HOUSE YOU EDIT
CUT A TREE DOWN. DO YOU HAVE
THE EQUIPMENT TO DO THAT NO YOU
HAVE TO HIRE SOMEBODY IF YOU'RE
A BUSINESS AND IN YOU'RE NOT IN
THE AIR CONDITIONING BUSINESS
BUT YEAR CONDITIONS GOES GOES
DOWN. IMAGINE HAVING AIR
CONDITIONING REPAIR PEOPLE ON
ON YOUR STAFF ALL THE TIME FOR
THINGS THAT AREN'T EVEN THAT
CENTRAL CORE OF YOUR BUSINESS.
SO THERE ARE REQUIREMENTS IN
HERE THAT. REALLY AREN'T A
FISSION AND READ SIGNIFICANTLY
RAISE COSTS. THANK YOU SEE AND
ITS WORKERS CAN BARGAIN AND
THEY DO WE THEY HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND THEY AND THEY
HAVE SHOWN THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CLOSE CONTRACTS YOU
SEE IN ITS UNIONS OF
SUCCESSFULLY CLOSE CONTRACTS.
WITH ALL THE OTHER UNIONS. AND
KEEP IN MIND. IF THE CRITICISM
IS SOMEHOW THIS CONTRACTING OUT
HAS LED TO A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN YOU SEE EMPLOYMENT
IT'S JUST THE OPPOSITE THAT WE
SEE. UNION EMPLOYMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S BEEN
GOING UP FOR MANY MANY YEARS
NOT THE OPPOSITE. MEMBERS WE
HAVE NEW MEMBERS IN LEADERSHIP
AT THE BOARD OF REGENTS I KNOW
YOU KNOW MANY OF THEM. AND THEY
HAVE INDICATED TO ME THAT THEY
ARE COMMITTED. TO CREATING A
FAIR CONTRACTING PRACTICE. AND
I TRUSTED THAT LEADERSHIP THAT
THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
REGENTS IS JOHN FOR AS A FORMER
UNION LEADER AND HE HAS MADE IT
CLEAR THAT HE WANTS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
HAVE THE BEST CONTRACTING OUT
PROVISIONS STANDARDS OF ANY
PUBLIC INSTITUTION IN THE
COUNTRY AND I THINK HE SHOULD
BE GIVEN THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY. BUT A CONSTITUTIONAL MEN
NOW. COULD PASS AND IT WOULD BE
PERMANENT. HI DOES SET A
PRECEDENT. AND IT DOES CREATE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MANY OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
OCCASIONALLY. WITH THAT
INSTITUTION THAT SOMEHOW BE NOW
SUBJECT TO. ANOTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL CHANGE COULD
HAPPEN EVERY YEAR COULD HAPPEN
EVERY SESSION. I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD GIVE THE UNIVERSITY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO WORK
THESE ISSUES OUT THIS THIS.
THIS CONSTITUTIONAL MA'AM IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE PASSED TODAY
WE COULD TAKE THIS MATTER UP IN
JANUARY AND HAVE THE SAME
RESULT TO THE BENEFIT THAT THEY
DESIRE PUTTING THIS MEASURE ON
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT. SO IN
SUMMARY. WE HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA HARD FOUGHT. WE
SHOULD ALLOW THAT. PROCESS TO.
RESOLVE A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
INCLUDING THIS ONE. NUMBER TWO
YOU SEE DOES HAVE A DEGREE OF
IT AYE TANAMI. BUT THE BOARD
CHAIR IS MADE AS KIM IS A CLEAR
HIS COMMITMENT TO HAVE HIGH
STANDARDS FOR CONTRACTING OUT
HE SHOULD BE GIVEN THAT CHANCE.
AND NOT ADDRESSING THIS BILL
TODAY DOESN'T. STOP THE
CONVERSATION DOESN'T PREVENT
THE RESULTS THAT THIS MEASURE
DESIRES WHICH IS A BALLOT
MEASURE NEXT OF AMBER. AND
BECAUSE OF THOSE REASONS I
THINK WE SHOULD VOTE NO ON THIS
MEASURE TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR GALGIANI. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I WAS
AROUND IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN WE
WENT THROUGH THE BUDGET CRISIS
IN THE UC SYSTEM PUT EMPLOYEES
ON FURLOUGH THEY INCREASE
CONTRACTING OUT AND THEY
REDUCED PAY AND THEY RAISED
TUITION FOR STUDENTS AND WITHIN
A YEAR. IT WAS LEARNED THAT
SECRETLY THEY HAD GIVEN BONUSES
TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT THREE
POINT ONE MILLION OR THEY WERE
PLANNING TO FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
POP EXECUTIVE EMPLOYEES AND
THEY WERE DOING THAT AFTER
HAVING MADE RAISES TO TUITION
AND FOR LOW'S TO EMPLOYEES THAT
WAS A BLATANT DISREGARD AND
DISRESPECT FOR THE EMPLOYEES
AND IN MY VIEW OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL BECAUSE WE
AGREED TO THE TERMS AT THAT
TIME. BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
THE WE WERE IN OUR WHERE WE
WERE WITH THE ECONOMY I THINK
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY I TRUST
ARE FORMER SPEAKER WHO IS NOW
ON THE BOARD OF REGENTS TO DO A
GREAT JOB AND TO DO ALL THAT HE
CAN WHILE HE IS ON THE BOARD
BUT JUST LIKE THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSES BILLS BECAUSE SOMETIMES
WE HAVE A GOVERNOR THAT WE FEEL
WE CAN WORK WITH AND TRUST AND
OTHER TIMES WE MAY NOT IN THE
FUTURE. THIS IS A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE WE NEED TO LOOK BEYOND
JUST WAS ON THE BOARD AT THIS
POINT IN TIME BUT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HAVING A STRUCTURE
THERE SO THAT WE DON'T SEE
THINGS LIKE THIS HAPPEN AGAIN
AND WE DON'T SEE. THINGS HAPPEN
ON THE BACKS OF EMPLOYEES WHO
QUITE FRANKLY ARE BARELY
GETTING BY AND JUST JUST MAKING
ENOUGH ONLY. TO RAISE THEIR
FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT HI TO RELUCTANTLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO ACA
FOURTEEN THE CONTRACTING
PROHIBITIONS CONTAINED IN THE
MEASURE WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
AND DISASTROUS FISCAL IMPACTS
ON THE UNIVERSITY IN
SPECIFICALLY OF THE UC SYSTEM
CALCULATES THE INCREASED
OPERATING COSTS ALMOST A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR BASED
ON THE ADDITIONAL WAGE AND
BENEFIT PREMIUMS ASSOCIATED
WITH BRINGING CARL THIS
CONTRACTED WORK IN HOUSE. FOR
UC SAN DIEGO WHICH IS NOT
DIRECTLY IN MY DISTRICT BUT
CERTAINLY IN MY EGION THEY
ESTIMATE THAT THIS WILL
INCREASE FACILITIES MAINTENANCE
COSTS BY TWENTY ONE POINT EIGHT
ALMOST TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS DURING THE FIRST YEAR
OF IMPLEMENTATION IN BY SIX AND
A HALF MILLION FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEARS SINCE UC SAN
DIEGO MUST ENSURE FUNDING FOR
OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITY STUDENTS THESE
ADDITIONAL COSTS WILL DEAL A
HEAVY FINANCIAL BLOW TO THE
CAMPUS AS A WHOLE. AND IT'S
MEDICAL ENTERPRISE AND THE COST
OF TUITION YOU SEE MEDICAL
CENTERS ON THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION ARE STILL
IN OPPOSITION TO A CA FOURTEEN
STATING IT ALSO THREATENS UC'S
MEDICAL CENTERS ABOUT
JEOPARDIZING PATIENT SAFETY IN
INCREASING HEALTHCARE COSTS THE
UC HEALTHCARE SYSTEM HAS A
SPECIAL PLACE IN CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE PLANS GATE
ADMISSION FOCUSED NOT ONLY ON
CLINICAL CARE BUT ALSO RESEARCH
AND EDUCATION. DELIVERING FOR
PATIENTS AND COMMUNITIES IN
EACH OF THESE AREAS RELIES UPON
A ROBUST STAFFING FRAMEWORK
THAT INCLUDES BOTH DIRECT
EMPLOYEES AND CONTRACT STAFFING
THE MEDICAL CENTERS ARE OFTEN
THE ONLY LEVEL ONE TRAUMA
CENTERS IN THE REGION PROVIDING
THE MAJORITY OF HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED SERVICES. HALF OF
ALL THE TRANSPLANT PROCEDURES
STATEWIDE IN A QUARTER OF THE
SEVERE BURN CARE DELIVERY. TO
CALIFORNIANS PROVIDING THIS
HIGH LEVEL OF. SHOULD CARE
DEMANDS THE DELICATE BALANCE OF
STAFFING RESOURCES WITHOUT
HAVING TO COME TO THIS JUST
LATER WITH EVERY SPECIAL NEED
THEY MIGHT HAVE. WITHOUT THE
ABILITY TO SUPPLEMENT STAFFING
WITHOUT COMING BACK HERE WITH
CONTRACT LABOR THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES WILL BE LAID CAN
AFFECT OUR ACCESS TO CARE SO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
TREASURED UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. I
URGE MY SENATE COLLEAGUES TO
OPPOSE ACA FOURTEEN. THANK YOU
SENATOR BILL. MEMBERS SO I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF A CA FOURTEEN.
MEMBERS LONG AGO WELL AS A
STUDENTS OUT OF THE STATE.
STUDENTS AT THE UC BERKELEY
ASKED US TO ATTEND A RALLY. FOR
THE MAINTENANCE WORKERS TO GET
THE FAIR WAGES AT THE
UNIVERSITY. I BRING THIS UP TO
ILLUSTRATE HOW LONG THIS ISSUE
HAS OF FAIR TREATMENT OF LOW
PAID WORKERS AT THE UC SYSTEM
HAS BEEN WITH US. TO HAVE THIS
ON MATT SOCIAL SERVICES ISSUE
HANG OVER THIS STATE. FOR SO
LONG. IS APPALLING AND IT IS AN
EMBARRASSMENT. THE COMMON
EXCUSE IS TO YOU LET THE
REGENTS HANDLE THAT HAS BEEN
USED MANY FOR MANY YEARS. TO
EXCLUDE THESE WORKERS FROM FAIR
TREATMENT BY USING THE STATE
CONSTITUTION AS AN EXCUSE ONE
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD RECEIVE
BETTER TREATMENT UNDER OUR LAWS
IS DISCRIMINATORY. I BELIEVE
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
HAVE THE CHANCE TO CORRECT THE
UNFAIRNESS. BY SUPPORTING A CA
FOURTEEN. AS THE STUDENTS STAFF
TEACHERS VISITORS WALK THROUGH
THE BEAUTIFUL GARDENS AND
BUILDINGS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT LESSONS ARE
LEARNED BY PERPETUATING THIS
UNFAIRNESS TO THE WORKERS WHO
WORK HARD MAINTAINING OUR
UNIVERSITY. MARTIN LUTHER KING.
SAID BEFORE THE MARCH ON SELMA
HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE. HE
ANSWERED HOW LONG NOT LONG. NOW
THAT SHOULD BE OUR ANSWER. LET
US BEEN TOWARDS JUSTICE. LET
THE VOTERS DECIDE. IT'S BEEN
TOO LONG URGE SUPPORT FOR A CA
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR BORDERS. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I THINK THERE
ARE REALLY GOOD PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE I THINK
SOME OF THE POINTS THAT HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT UP BY THE
PROPONENTS OF AC FOURTEEN ARE
LOOKING AFTER IN THEIR
ESTIMATION THE BEST INTEREST OF
WORKERS IN UNIVERSITY
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM.
ON THE FLIP SIDE I THINK THERE
ARE CERTAINLY COMPELLING
ARGUMENTS AS TO WHY I EMPLOYEES
SHOULD TO. OR UNIVERSITY SHOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY AND
FLEXIBILITY TO PROVIDE SERVICES
IN CONTRACT FOR SERVICES AS
NEEDED BECAUSE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS EBB AND FLOW OF THE
NEEDS CHANGE. ON DEPENDING ON
THE ECONOMY WE CAN EXPECT THAT
EVEN FURTHER SPECIALLY AS WERE
EXPECTING OUR ECONOMY TO
CONTINUE TO SLOW DOWN AS CYCLES
OR INEVITABLE. WHAT I'M HEARING
THOUGH IT. FROM FOLKS WHO WERE
SUPPORTING A CA FOURTEEN. ARE
THAT. THE BARGAINING UNIT
PROCESS HAS NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
I WOULD THINK THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY WON TODAY. HOWEVER THIS
VOTE PLAYS OUT BECAUSE YOU
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE TO THE
FOREFRONT TO THE HEIGHT OF
POLITICAL AWARENESS AND I WOULD
THINK THAT THIS. JUST BY VIRTUE
OF WHAT HAS OCCURRED TODAY.
HE'S GOING TO COMPEL FOLKS
WITHIN THE REGIONS WITHIN THE
BARGAINING UNITS TO TRY TO
REACH AN ACCOMMODATION. AND
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN OF THE OPINION
THAT THAT WIN WIN COMMON SENSE
AND URGENCY ARE PAIRED RESULTS
OCCUR. AND I THINK THAT CAN
OCCUR RIGHT NOW. MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM DOWN SOUTH HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER. THIS IS A BROAD SWORD
BEING BROUGHT TO A FAIRLY
LIMITED ISSUE. TO REQUIRE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY. OR ANY
CHANGES TO OCCUR IN STAFFING.
IT JUST SEEMS TERRIBLY TERRIBLY
CUMBERSOME AND FRANKLY IT'S A
FAIT ACCOMPLI AT THAT POINT IT
JUST WOULDN'T HAPPEN SO WE HAVE
NEW LEADERSHIP AT UC WE'VE
WE'VE GOTTEN RENEWED
COMMITMENTS THAT THEY WANT TO
TAKE IN EARNEST ANOTHER STAB AT
ALL REACHING AN ACCOMMODATION
TOWARD UNDERSTANDING OF FOR THE
BARGAINING UNITS IN TERMS
CONDITIONS OF EMPLOYMENT. WHY
WOULDN'T WE BRING THIS MATTER
BACK. LET THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE TASKED WITH REACHING A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING DECISIONS
GIVE THEM IN ANOTHER FEW MONTHS.
WHAT IT HURT IF THIS ISSUE WERE
BROUGHT BACK IN JANUARY AND I
ASKED THAT TO THE MOVERS OF
THIS LEGISLATION. WHAT WOULD BE
THE DOWN FALL WE COULD TAKE
THIS MATTER UP IN JANUARY ALL
OTHER BE ENOUGH TIME I SUSPECT
TO PUT IT ON ON THE BALLOT IF
IT IT'S STILL PROVED SO I THINK
THAT IS AN OPTION I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN THE OPINION THAT WHEN
LEGISLATORS PANIC BAD POLICIES
MADE. AND I THINK GRAY HERE
WE'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE WERE
PANICKING AND USING A BROAD
SWORD ON A DISCREET AND LIMITED
ISSUE THAT FRANKLY MAKES FOR
BAD POLICY. SO I THINK WITH
THAT. I WOULD. I'M CERTAINLY
GOING TO BE RECOMMENDING EITHER
A NO OR A NEUTRAL ON THIS TO MY
COLLEAGUES. JUST BECAUSE I
THINK THAT COOLER HEADS CAN
PREVAIL NOW THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO THE FOREFRONT. AND
LET'S GIVE THE AND YOU SEE AN
OPPORTUNITY. WITH THEIR NEW
LEADERSHIP TO FIND THEIR
ACCOMMODATIONS I KNOW THAT
FOLKS HAVE SAID. ENOUGH TIME
HAS PASSED AND THEY'VE LOST
CONFIDENCE IN THE PROCESS. BUT
I THINK WITH NEW LEADERSHIP.
THERE IS RENEWED HOPE AND I'D
LIKE TO GIVE THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO OR
NEUTRAL ANY CA FOURTEEN. THANK
YOU SENATOR TANK. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS HIGH
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACA FOURTEEN.
THE UC SYSTEM HAS OVER SIX
HUNDRED ADMINISTRATORS AND
STAFF WITH REPORTERS SALARIES
OVER HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S MORE THAN TWICE WHAT THE
GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA MAKES.
TWENTY FISCAL YEARS TWENTY
TWELVE TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESENCE AYE
MINISTERS SPENDING INCREASED BY
20% OR EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WE CAN MAKE SURE JANITORS
ARE TREATED EQUALLY. THE UC
SYSTEM IS PUBLICLY FUNDED WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE TREATED FAIRLY. I
REMEMBER WE ARE MERELY VOTING
TO PUT THIS ON THE BALLOT. FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO DECIDE. SO WITH
THAT I ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON ON MY
COLLEAGUE FROM DIAMOND BARS.
ACTIVE AND I WANT TO BROADEN
THE SOCIAL REFLECTION A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE I AM VERY PROUD TO
BE A CO AUTHOR OF A CA FOURTEEN
AND- THE REASON THAT I MADE THE
DECISION TO BECOME A CO AUTHOR
WAS AFTER. HEARING AND READING
ABOUT ONE OF THE UNIVERSITIES.
AT THE ACTIONS THAT THEY HAD
TAKEN AGAINST THE WORK FORCE TO.
BASICALLY LAY THEM OFF AND
BRING IN CONTRACT WORKERS AND I
WAS SO APPALLED BY THAT I JUST
FELT COMPELLED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT AND HOW THIS GETS BACK
TO WHAT WHAT WHAT I'VE WORKED
ON AND HOW IT'S IMPORTANT ME IS
THIS AND I HAD A I HAVE HAVE A
BILL THAT THAT THAT WAS OVER IN
THE ASSEMBLY GOT OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY. THAT WOULD HAVE SUS
STARTED TO SET SOME TARGETS FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REDUCE POVERTY IN
OUR STATE AND DEPENDING ON
WHICH REPORT YOU READ OUR
POVERTY LEVEL HAS STAYED
BETWEEN TWENTY AND 25% FOR THE
PAST TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS AND
IT'S GOTTEN THAT WAY ECAUSE
EXACTLY BECAUSE OF WHAT. MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM DIAMOND BAR
HAS TALKED ABOUT IT IS THE FACT
THAT THE LOWER. AID WORKERS ARE
ARE LAID OFF OR THE REPLACED BY
CONTRACT WORKERS WHO COME IN
AND GET NO BENEFITS THEY GET NO
RETIREMENT THEY GET NO HEALTH
INSURANCE. THEY GET NO VACATION
AND SICK LEAVE PAY AND THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO WORK TWO OR THREE
JOBS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES. AND AT
THE TOP YOU SEE HUGE BONUSES
GOING OUT YOU SEE CEO'S AND
CFO'S BETTER EARNING IN THE
MULTIPLE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND THIS IS AT THE SAME TIME
THAT WORKERS ARE GETTING
DISPLACED AND SO. WHAT ACA IS
THE ACA IS ATTEMPTING TO DO IS
TO STOP THAT PRACTICE TO SAY
THIS IS NOT APPROPRIATE NOW ARE
THERE SOME THINGS IT. PROBABLY
SHOULD BE FIXED ABSOLUTELY NO
BILL IS EVER PERFECT BUT BY THE
SAME TOKEN WHEN WE SAY WELL.
YOU KNOW MAYBE WE SHOULD WAIT
TILL JANUARY AND I GET IT THAT
PROBABLY MAKES SOME SENSE WE
CAN ALSO. IMPLORE OUR NEWLY
ELECTED LEADERSHIP. ON THE
BOARD TO GET IT RIGHT SO THAT
THIS A CA DOESN'T NEED TO END
UP ON THE BALLOT. IN IN MARCH
IN NOVEMBER AS WELL. I JUST YOU
KNOW WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO STAND UP AND SAY OUR
LOWEST PAID WORKERS. DESERVE
THE OPPORTUNITY I'M AND I AND I
GOT TO SAY YOU KNOW I'M FROM
I'M FROM A COPPER MINING
FAMILY. AND PART OF WHAT THEY
ORGANIZED FOR AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO WIN AFTER MANY MANY
YEARS IS A PENSION. IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO EARN
A LIVING WAGE THEY COULD BUY
THEIR OWN HOMES. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE HEALTH CARE
AND SICK LEAVE AND VACATION
LEAVE ALL OF THOSE. ARE THE
BENEFITS THAT WE COME TO TAKE
FOR GRANTED IN WHEN YOU'RE
WORKING IN THIS TEMPORARY.
COUNTRY CONTRACTED KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT YOU DON'T HAVE
THOSE KINDS OF PROTECTIONS AND
SO. I'M I'M VERY PROUD TO BE
ABLE TO STAND. HAPPENED TO SAY
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY BY THE WAY MY BILL
IN THE ASSEMBLY WAS HELD AND
IT'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE AND-
AND I'M I'M IN A CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE AND FIGHT FOR IT
BECAUSE I THINK IF YOU DON'T.
SET GOALS YOU NEVER GET THERE
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE WE GOT
TO GET THERE WE GOT TO DO THIS
RIGHT. IT'S SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR DORADO. COLLEAGUES
WE ARE SO PROUD. THAT WE
DELIVER A FIRST CLASS EDUCATION
FOR EVERYONE WHO GOES THROUGH
THE UC SYSTEM AND I BEFORE I GO
ON I WON IT KNOWLEDGE ALL MY
SISTERS AND BROTHERS WHO ARE
HERE WHO WORK FOR US. ON THOSE
UC CAMPUSES. BECAUSE WE DELIVER
FIRST CLASS EDUCATION WE NEED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FIRST CLASS
WORK THAT IS DONE AND THEREFORE
FIRST CLASS TREATMENT. THEY
SHOULD BE GIVEN TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK SO HARD TO HELP
OUR STUDENTS SUCCEED. CHEAP
LABOR ON OUR OWN STATE RUN UC
CAMPUSES SHOULD NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE. AND SISTERS A
LEAGUES. TAXPAYERS PAY WE PAY
FOR IT. EVERYONE WHO GETS
CONTRACTED OUT. DOESN'T MAKE
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY.
THEY NEED THEN OUR SOCIAL
SERVICE NET TO HELP THEM. WHAT
I'M TELLING YOU I'VE JUST MANY
MY LIVE NEXT TO HARD WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK FOR FAR
LESS THAN THEY DESERVE. WILL BE
FOR A HAND UP NOT A HAND OUT.
LET'S REWARD THE HARD WORK OF
THESE MEN AND WOMEN WHEN I HEAR
THE TERM USED BY SOMEONE OF
FLEXIBILITY THAT SOUNDS LIKE
THE UBER CODE FORTY NINE BASIC
NEEDS THAT WORKING FAMILIES
NEED. THIS PROBLEM HAS BEEN
GROWING FOR DECADES AND THERE'S
MORE AND MORE AND MORE
SUBCONTRACTING OUT AND THE
CREATION OF CHEAP LABOR ON OUR
CAMPUSES WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO A FEW NEW GOOD LEADERS AT
THE BOARD OF REGENTS. THEY ARE
NOT CALLING THE SHOTS. WHEN
THEY NEED BACK UP FROM US THEY
NEED BACK UP FROM US TO SHOW
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT ALL
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN SHOULD
HAVE THE DECENT GOOD STANDARD
OF LIVING. COLLEAGUES ASK FOR
YOUR AYE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THIS IS A
DIFFICULT ISSUE IN AN EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT MEASURE FOR ME
FRANKLY THE EASY THING TO DO
WOULD BE TO JUST STOP THE ISSUE.
OR TO EXCEED TO THE PRESSURE
FROM OUTSIDE THIS BUILDING THAT
SOME OF US HAVE BEEN FEELING
OVER THE LAST. WEEK OR SO
WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY
EXPLANATION. FOR MY CONCERNS
ABOUT. THE MEASURE AND NOT THE
CAUSE BUT I CAN'T DO THAT. I
OWE YOU AN EXPLANATION AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY I THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE IN OUR GALLERY IN
THOSE WHO HOPEFULLY ARE
WATCHING OUTSIDE THIS BUILDING.
AN EXPLANATION FOR OF MY
CONCERNS AND AN EXPRESSION OF
MY SUPPORT FOR A FIX. SHORTLY
AFTER I WAS ELECTED IF MYMEMORY SERVES ME RIGHT ONE OF
THE FIRST PICKET LINES AND ONE
OF THE FIRST WORKER PROTESTS. I
ADDRESSED WAS IN ASKS ME ACTION.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE. I'M SURE YOU CAN
IMAGINE IT WAS QUITE A
METAMORPHOSIS FOR A- LABOR
MANAGEMENT ATTORNEY FOR
RIVERSIDE.FROM RIVERSIDE
STRANGE HOW THINGS CHANGE IN
OUR LIVES. I PARTICIPATED IN
THAT PICKET LINE BECAUSE I
RECOGNIZED AT THAT TIME AND I
CONTINUE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
PRIOR ADMINISTRATIONS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
FOR DECADES FAILED TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF SOME OF UC'S
MOST VALUABLE. BUT LOWEST PAID
EMPLOYEES CONCERNS ABOUT PAY
CONCERNS ABOUT JOB DISPLACEMENT
CONCERNS ABOUT BENEFITS AMONG
OTHER ISSUES. THESE ARE
CERTAINLY NOT THE ACTIONS THAT
WE EXPECT. FROM ANYONE IN
POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WHEN I
REVIEWED THE A. C. A. FOURTEEN
THIS PROPOSED CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT I DID SO FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE THE PERSPECTIVE OF
TRYING TO HELP THOSE WHO NEED
HELP THE MOST. BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE TRY TO DO IN THIS
CAPITAL. IN DOING SO IN A NOD
TO THE PROPONENTS OF THIS
MEASURE I RECOGNIZE THE LONG
HOURS IN THE EXTREMELY HARD
WORK. PUT INTO TRYING TO GET
THIS THING RIGHT. UNFORTUNATELY
AS I REVIEWED I NOTED SOME
STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES IN THIS
MEASURE THAT COULD CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION AND HARM
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
SEOUL IT'S BEEN SAID BEFORE BUT
I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHTED WHAT IS
THIS PROPOSED CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT DO AT ITS CORE IT
PROHIBITS CONTRACTING FOR
SERVICES UNDER SOME VERY VERY
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES. LET'S
TAKE A DEEPER LOOK. THE BILL
THIS PROPOSED CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT COVERS ALL UC
CONTRACT WORKERS PAID TO
PERFORM SUPPORT SERVICES AT
VARIOUS UC FACILITIES INCLUDING
UC MEDICAL CENTERS CLINICS
RESEARCH FACILITIES AND
LABORATORIES SO IN ADDITION TO
IMPACTING THE AVAILABILITY OF
WORKERS AT UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES
WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
WORKERS PROVIDING PATIENT CARE
SERVICES THAT ARE YOU SEE
MEDICAL SERVICE AROUND THE
STATE OUR TOP TIER HOSPITALS
PROVIDING CRITICAL CARE. TO OUR
MOST SERIOUSLY ILL. ARE VERY
SICK. AND OUR MOST VULNERABLE
PATIENTS. IN MANY CASES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROVIDING CARE
AND EMERGENCY BASIS THAT
FRANKLY CANNOT BE OBTAINED
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE AND
THE PATIENT'S CENSUS AT THESE
HOSPITALS CAN VERY FROM DAY TO
DAY. AND EVEN FROM OUR OUR. ARE
YOU SEE MEDICAL CENTERS NEED TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO THESE
CHANGES IN CRITICAL PATIENT
LOADS IMMEDIATELY RIGHT NOW NOT
NEXT WEEK BECAUSE THEY MUST
ACCEPT PATIENTS THAT SHOW UP AT
THE DOOR AND PROVIDE CARE THEY
SIMPLY CAN'T SAY WAIT A DAY OR
TWO UNTIL WE FIND SOMEONE. TO
DO SO. SO HOW DOES THIS
PROPOSED CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FORCE UC TO DEAL WITH
THAT QUICKLY MOVING TARGET AT
THESE HEALTH CENTERS. YOU SEE
MAY CONTRACT FOR SUPPORT
SERVICES ONLY IF CONTRACTING IS
NECESSARY TO DEAL WITH
SPECIFIED CIRCUMSTANCES
OUTLINED IN THIS AMENDMENT
INCLUDING THE FOLLOWING. TO
SUPPLY THE UNIVERSITY WITH A
LICENSED CLINICALLY TRAINED
WORKERS FOR A CLINICAL REGISTRY.
HOW THEY USE THAT'S WHAT THEY
USED TO GET TEMPORARY WORKERS
WHEN THEIR LISTS OF PART TIME
PER DIEM WORKERS ARE
INSUFFICIENT. AND TO ADDRESS A
BONA FIDE EMERGENCY
CIRCUMSTANCE WHICH MAY INCLUDE
BUT NOT BE LIMITED TO INSURING
THE CONTINUOUS OPERATIONS OF
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND
PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE TO
ADDRESS LIFE THREATENING
SITUATIONS DURING AN EMERGENCY.
AMONG A FEW OTHER LISTED
SITUATIONS. THE USE OF
CONTRACTING AUTHORITIES TO
SECURE WORKERS TO DEAL WITH
THIS BONA FIDE EMERGENCY
CIRCUMSTANCE OR THE USE OF A
REGISTRY TO DEAL WITH THE
CRITICAL PERSONNEL SHORTAGE IS
ONLY PERMITTED IF WE FIRST
AUTHORIZED SUCH ACTION A BILL
WHICH WE PASSED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND WHICH IS THEN
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO FACT CHECK ME
ON THE POINT AND I DON'T BLAME
YOU. SECTION NINE POINT FIVE C.
ONE STATES IN PERTINENT PART
THE REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA MAY CONTRACT FOR.
CONTRACT LABOR TO PERFORM
SUPPORT SERVICES ONLY IF
AUTHORIZED TO DO SO BY STATUTE.
NOW THEY'RE VERY CERTAINLY
VARIOUS LEVELS A BONA FIDE
EMERGENCIES BUT IMAGINE HAVING
TO WAIT FOR OUR BILL PROCESS IN
ORDER TO RESPOND TO EMERGE ANY
EMERGENCY. PARTICULARLY IN
EMERGENCY AT A HEALTH CARE
FACILITY. NOT PERHAPS A LIST OF
PART TIME PER DIEM EMPLOYEES.
WILL BE SUFFICIENT. BUT WHAT
HAPPENS IF IT ISN'T. CLEARLY WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS WORKER
CONCERNS. CLEARLY WE HAVE TO
PROTECT ALL WORKERS INCLUDING
THOSE AT UC PARTICULARLY OUR
HARDEST WORKING LOWEST PAID AND
MOST VULNERABLE BECAUSE THAT'S
OUR JOB AND CLEARLY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
FAILED TO DO SO FOR DECADES.
BUT THIS PROPOSED
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT JUST
DOESN'T WORK. OBVIOUSLY WE
CAN'T PREDICT THE FUTURE
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO
EMERGENCIES OF THE NATURE OF
THE REQUIRED RESPONSE BUT IF
THE PROPONENTS ARE WRONG IN
THEIR PREDICTIONS AS TO THE
IMPACT ON ARE YOU SEE HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. AND THIS
NEW PROCESS WITH THE LANGUAGE
THAT I'VE IDENTIFIED. WHICH IS
FLOOD. NEEDS TO BE CHANGED. OUR
EFFORT TO DO SO IN THE PROCESS
TO DO SO WILL BE HERCULEAN. AND
WE JUST CAN'T WAIVE IT. THERE
HAS TO BE A BETTER WAY IN THE
FORM OF A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO IT TO ACHIEVE THE
OBJECTIVES THAT ARE ATTEMPTED
TO BE ACHIEVED HERE WE NEED TO
TAKE BETTER CARE AND PAY BETTER
ATTENTION TO THE LANGUAGE WHEN
WE DRAFT AMENDMENTS TO OUR
STATE CONSTITUTION BECAUSE- FOR
THOSE OF US. CERTAINLY HERE WE
KNOW LANGUAGE FRANKLY IS
IMPORTANT. SO UNFORTUNATELY I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT AS
DRAFTED AT THIS POINT HOWEVER I
COMMIT TO WORKING DILIGENTLY
WITH THE PROPONENTS THE UC
REGENTS IN THE ADMINISTRATION
TO PIN DOWN A PERMANENT
SOLUTION TO THE ISSUES IS
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT IS ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS IN A MORE CRAFT
CAREFULLY CRAFTED
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT AND
STAND READY TO DO SO AND HAVE
BEEN STANDING READY TO DO SO
DURING THE LAST WEEK OR SO
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS.
OBVIOUSLY IF THIS MEASURE
PASSES TODAY AND IS APPROVED BY
THE VOTERS WELL ASSUMING I'M
STILL HERE. I'LL DO MY BEST TO
ENSURE THAT THE FIRE AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES THAT WE HAVE INDOOR
AND SEEMINGLY AND DERON
INCREASING BASIS MONTH AFTER
MONTH. COORDINATE WITH OUR
LEGISLATIVE SCHEDULE SO WE CAN
PASS AN APPROPRIATE BILL. TO
TAKE CARE OF THESE ISSUES
BEFORE IT GETS WORSE. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
PERMANENTLY FIX THIS ISSUE FOR
THOSE IMPACTED IN IN IN A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. MONTH
JUST NOT THIS WAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU CENTER
STIR. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. AS A AS A CAL GRAD.
GO BEARS ANYBODY. AND AS A
FORMER TEACHER AT UCLA I HAVE
DEEP AFFECTION FOR THIS SYSTEM
I THINK IT IS THE FINEST PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD. AND I DON'T INTEND. WITH
THE VOTE HERE TODAY. THAT WE
BREAK THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN FACT I THINK WE
CAN STRENGTHEN IT. I WANTED TO
ADDRESS TWO ISSUES ONE OF WHICH
IS ABOUT MONEY. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE FISCAL ANALYSIS ON THIS
MEASURE IT TALK ABOUT A ABOUT A
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLAR IMPACT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE OUTPUT OF THIS
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THE SCALE OF
ECONOMIC PRODUCTIVITY THE
SOCIAL MOBILITY THAT WE COULD
POSSIBLY ENABLE. I THINK THAT
IS A MORE THAN FILLABLE GAP.
AND IN MY VIEW. WE'VE BEEN
SHORT CHANGING THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA FOR TOO LONG. I AM
VERY EXCITED THAT WE MAY BE
PASSING A AN EDUCATION BONDS.
THAT WOULD PUT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION
GOING FORWARD. WE KNOW THE
BUILDINGS ARE STARTING TO FAIL
THERE SEISMIC ISSUES UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA UCLA AND BERKELEY IN
OTHER CAMPUSES. BUT EVEN ON AN
ANNUAL BUDGET CYCLE WE GO
THROUGH EVERY YEAR. I THINK
VOTING FOR THIS MEASURE ENTAILS
AN OBLIGATION TO STEP UP TO THE
PLATE FOR THIS LEGISLATURE. TO
HELP FILL THIS GAP. BUT WHAT I
WANNA SAY IS THAT. WE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN. OUR
WORKERS FAIRLY AND HAVING A
FIRST CLASS UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
I THINK WE CAN DO BOTH. I
SHOWED UP ON CAMPUS. I FIRST
YEAR LAW SCHOOL ON BANCROFT IN
MEMBER WALKING OUT TO GET A
BITE TO EAT AT THE
INTERNATIONAL HOUSE WHICH IS
RIGHT UP THE STREET I SAW THESE
FOLKS IN GREEN. STANDING OUT ON
THE STREET. I WONDERED WHO ARE
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE. SO I
EIGHT I STARTED CONVERSATION
AND IT TURNS OUT. THEY'RE THE
PEOPLE WHO KEPT MY SCHOOL CLEAN.
MADE MY CAMPUS SAFE. SO I COULD
KEEP MY HEAD IN THE BOOKS THEY
GRINDED. AND FOR STUDENTS.
FACULTY ADMINISTRATORS OR EVEN
US IS LEGISLATORS TO PRETEND
LIKE THOSE PEOPLE ARE INVISIBLE
JUST WRONG. SO. WHEN WE VOTE
HERE TODAY WHEN I TAKE THIS
VOTE I'LL BE THINKING OF THOSE
PEOPLE UP THE STREET. TO WORK
DAY IN AND OUT TO MAKE OUR
SYSTEM GO. BUT I DO NOT THINK
THIS IS GOING TO BE. A FATAL
BLOW. TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. I THINK WE CAN
ACTUALLY ESTABLISH THE MORAL
HIGH GROUND FOR THIS UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AND TRULY FORM A
PARTNERSHIP. THAT WILL REQUIRE
SOME ADDITIONAL STATUTORY WORK
ON OUR PART. I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE OUR NEEDS FOR
ENHANCED FLEXIBILITY. AND THAT
EXPRESS STATUTORY AUTHORIZATION
TO ALLOW FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
STEP IN. FOR A VARIETY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES NOT ONLY IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT COULD
SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE BROUGHT
UP BUT ALSO I BELIEVE IN NINE
POINT FIVE G. TALKS ABOUT THE
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIS ACT. I
THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE AMPLE
FLEXIBILITY FOR US HERE TO STEP
UP BUT WE CAN'T JUST TAKE THIS
VOTE AND WALK AWAY. TO PUT OUR
MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH. WE HAVE
TO FIND A WAY STATUTORILY TO
MAKE SURE THE SYSTEM CONTINUES
TO BE EXCELLENT. AND GROWS
ITSELF. SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE MEASURE HERE TODAY. BUT I
HOPE WE CAN START TO TURN THE
PAGE AND END THIS YEAR OF
ENMITY THAT IS PLAGUE IS
UNIVERSITY FOR FAR TOO LONG. WE
DO NOT NEED TO BE AT ODDS. AND
THERE IS A TABLE SOMEWHERE WE
CAN ALL SIT DOWN. AND I HOPE
FOR MY FRIENDS OF THE REGION'S
OR THE LEADERSHIP OF THIS
UNIVERSITY. THEY WILL TAKE THIS
NOT AS SOME REVIEW. BUT AS A
CHARGE THE COME TO STEP UP TO
THE PLATE. AND FIND A WAY TO
WORK WITH US TO TRULY MAKE THIS
UNIVERSITY THE GYM THAT IT IS.
THANK YOU. SENATOR PAT. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS
SIDE RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ACA I KNOW THAT MANY PEOPLE
HERE ARE GRADUATES OF THE YEAR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AND IT HAD
CERTAINLY TREMENDOUS EXPERIENCE
THERE I ACTUALLY UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE NOTS HOWEVER I SERVED AS A
FACULTY MEMBER AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY OF YOU HAVE
SERVED ON IS AFFECTING THEIR
FULL TIME FACULTY MEMBER AT THE
MERCY CALIFORNIA. AFFECTED BEEN
TOLD US OF FIRST FULL TIME
FACULTY MEMBER UC'S EVER BEEN
ELECTED TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE BUT IF SOMEONE FIND
SOMEONE ELSE LET ME KNOW AND I
STAND SUPPORT. ACTUALLY FOR.
BOTH AS A FORMER FACULTY MEMBER
AND ALSO AS A PHYSICIAN BECAUSE
I KNOW MANY PEOPLE BROUGHT UP
THE HEALTH SYSTEMS. SO
CERTAINLY AS A FACULTY MEMBER I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE TEACH OUR STUDENTS. AND SET
A GOOD EXAMPLE FOR THEM AS TO
HOW WE DO BUSINESS. AT OUR
STATE RUN UNIVERSITY OUR STATE
UNIVERSITY OUR PREMIER THAT
CROWN JEWEL WE CALL DIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. AND SO WHAT KIND OF
EXAMPLE. ARE WE SETTING OUR
STUDENTS WHEN THE UNIVERSITY.
DECIDES TO LAY OFF EMPLOYEES
REPLACING THE CONTRACT WORKERS
OR EVEN HIGHER CONTRACT WORKERS
INSTEAD OF EXPANDING THEIR
EMPLOYMENT WORKFORCE. THE. NOW
CERTAINLY THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
THERE ARE TEMP YELP AND THERE
IT'S OUTLINED HERE THAT YOU MAY
HAVE SITUATIONS WHERE YOU HAVE
A CERTAIN EVENT OR SOMETHING
WHERE YOU MAY NEED SOME
FLEXIBILITY BUT I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE TEACH OUR
STUDENTS AND THE LEARNERS WHO
ARE AT THE MERCY CALIFORNIA HOW
ONE CAN DO BUSINESS AND YES WE
HEAR IS THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP
SUPPORT. OUR UNIVERSITY IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS THEM TO ADHERE
TO THE VALUES. I DO APPRECIATE
THAT MY GOOD FRIEND TO STOCKING
THE BILL FROM SANTA CLARITA HAS
POINTED OUT THAT ACTUALLY THE
FINANCIAL COST. IS ACTUALLY
BEARABLE WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY.
AND SO I DO THINK AS A FACULTY
MEMBER. WHO WANTS TO NOT ONLY
JUST TEACH. MY LEARNERS THROUGH
LECTURES ARE OTHER EDUCATIONAL.
ALL ACT. THAT WE SHOULD SET
THAT EXAMPLE AND I THINK THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND THIS
IDEA OF EQUITY. BECAUSE WHAT
THIS. MANY DOES AND MANY OF YOU
SPOKE TO THE FACT THAT BY THE
WAY I KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE
SAID WELL IS THERE A RUSH TO
JUDGMENT HERE. I MEAN THIS IS
AN ONGOING ISSUE FOR A LONG
TIME I MEAN THROUGHOUT MY
ENTIRE TIME THE LEGISLATURE
BEFORE EVER GOT THE LEGISLATURE
WENT. BEFORE SOME OF YOU ARE IN
THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE I WAS IN
THE LEGISLATURE I MEAN THIS IS
NOT A RUSH TO JUDGMENT THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR A VERY LONG TIME. AND I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
SET THAT EXAMPLE NOW I KNOW
THAT MANY PEOPLE ALSO RAISE THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE MED CENTER'S.
AND HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS AND-
OTHER POSITION YOU PRACTICED
NOT ONLY OUTPATIENT BUT ALSO
INFORMATION I DID YOU KNOW THE
WORD ATTENDING THAT OTHER
THINGS. AND BELIEVE ME YES I
AGREE. THE IT GOES UP THE ****
OUT IN TERMS OF THE DEMANDS
RIGHT I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THAT PERHAPS THE BIGGEST
LIMITATION ANY CAPACITY IF SOME.
NO MAJOR EVENT HAPPENS IS NOT
JUST STAFF. ALTHOUGH CERTAINLY
THAT'S ONE PLACE IT'S ACTUALLY
THE FACILITY ITSELF. AND SO WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT ACTUALLY THE- UC HOSPITALS
WE THOUGHT TALK ABOUT ME EVER
VERY SPECIALTY PROGRAMS. THOSE
ARE NOT THE ONES WHO ARE
SUFFERING THE LARGE SWINGS IN
DEMAND OKAY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE MERCHANTS YOU ROOM THERE'S
A DISASTER OR SOMETHING. RIGHT
WE DO HAVE FIRST OF ALL PLANS
AND THAT INVOLVES ACTUALLY THE
EXISTING STAFF. SO THERE THERE
IS ANY WE'RE WE ACTUALLY DO
PLAN FOR AND ORGANIZED TO
HANDLE VARIATIONS IN PATIENT
VOLUME INCLUDING EVEN. THINGS
TO HAPPEN TO THE VIRGIN THREW
ME OFF THERE IS A SCHOOL BUS
ACCIDENTS WE HAVE WE ARE WE ARE
ORGANIZED TO RESPOND TO THAT
WITH EXISTING STAFF NOW. THERE
IS MENTION IN THE AC ITSELF THE
SAYS IF THERE'S ACTUALLY A
LARGE SCALE EMERGENCY THE
GOVERNOR CAN DECLARE AND WEAK
AND THE UNIVERSITY CAN'T PULL
IN MORE PEOPLE TO DO THAT THE
HANDLE THAT AS WELL SO
CERTAINLY IF THERE IS THERE IS
IT IS A LARGE SCALE EVENTS
WHERE WE DO NEED. TO BRING IN
MANY MORE PEOPLE INTO THE
FACILITY THERE IS THAT CAPACITY
AS WELL. SO. NOW MAYBE THERE
YOU KNOW MAYBE WE DO NEED TO
LEGISLATIVE FIX IF THIS IS
PASSED BY THE VOTERS AND POINT
OUT THIS GOES TO THE VOTERS
BUT- I'D- IT THIS IS NOT. A
THIS ACA IS NOT GOING TO
CRIPPLE. ARE YOU SEE HEALTH
SYSTEM TO SOMEONE WHO'S
ACTUALLY WORKED THERE OKAY AND
SO. I THINK THAT THIS
RESOLUTIONS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT RESOLVES A PROBLEM THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON FOR A LONG TIME
AT UC. CLEARLY LIKE ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IT'S
GONNA GO TO THE VOTERS BUT I AM
ALSO PROUD OF THE FACT THAT. WE
CAN ALSO IT HAS THOSE SPACES
WITHIN THEIR FOR US TO FINE
TUNE THE PARTS THAT NEED TO BE
FINE TUNED IN THERE BUT I THEY
DO WANT TO JUST SAY AGAIN I
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION BECAUSE
AS BOTH A FACULTY MEMBER WE'D
HAVE TO SET THE RIGHT EXAMPLE
AND ALSO AS A PHYSICIAN I WANT
TO SEE. OUR STAFF THE STAFF
THAT'S ACTUALLY TAKING HELPING
US TAKE CARE TO PATIENTS. WE
NEED TO BE SURE WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO BOTH KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING. RIGHT YELP BELIEVE NOT
IF YOU'RE THE PERSON HAVE TO
CLEAN UP BLOOD VOMIT UNIT YOU
ACTUALLY SORRY AND- SO THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS IN A HOSPITAL. YOU
KNOW YOU YOU IT'S NOT YOU DON'T
JUST PULL SOMEONE OFF THE
STREET THEY NEED TO NOT HANDLE
IT. IT AND BUT THERE SHOULD
ALSO KNOW THAT THEY'RE BEING
PAID THE SAME TO GAIN THE SAME
BENEFITS THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT
EVERYONE'S IN IT TOGETHER
THAT'S HOW HEALTH SYSTEM WORKS
ALOT THINGS WORK BUT THAT'S HOW
HEALTH SYSTEM WORK. AND SO THIS.
I THINK IS IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AND I HEARD TONIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT FISHING YEAH YOU
RECOGNIZE ME. THE YOU KNOW IT
SOUNDS LIKE THIS MORNING. WE
HAVE A LOT OF AGREEMENT. ON THE
FLOOR HERE TODAY THAT THERE ARE
SOME CHALLENGES WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM. AND YOU KNOW THAT'S
PROBABLY ACCURATE. AND I DO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND- THE CO
AUTHOR OF THE SENATE CO AUTHOR
FROM SANTA THREE TO. AND HIS
WORK THIS YEAR ON THIS PROJECT
ALONG WITH THE ASSEMBLY AUTHOR.
IN BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO US
AND- MAKING IT KNOWN. AND HIS
ADVOCACY. FOR THIS TODAY. BUT
THE I THINK WITH THE MAIN
SOURCE OF THE DISAGREEMENT ON
THIS IS WERE USING A
SLEDGEHAMMER. TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE.
SOLVED WITH A SCALPEL AND. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT THAT WAS
MADE EARLIER IN THE DEBATE
REGARDING FIRST CLASS WORKERS.
AND I DO AGREE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AGREE
DESERVES THE VERY BEST AT FIRST
CLASS WORKERS AND THE
SHORTCOMINGS THEIR OF ON SOME
OF THE POSITIONS THAT THAT
THAT. COMMENT WAS REGARDING.
BUT LET ME TALK ABOUT SOME
FIRST CLASS WORKERS THAT THIS
BILL UNFORTUNATELY AS A SLEDGE
HAMMER IS GONNA AFFECT. AND.
MOST LIKELY REMOVE THEIR
PROFESSIONALISM FROM. THE UC
SYSTEM THIS MEASURE WILL
INCREASE I HAS BEEN ARGUED IS
ALREADY THE HIGH COSTS ON
PARENTS WHO WANT TO SEND THEIR
KIDS TO UC. THE SAVINGS AT THE
UC CURRENTLY RE REAL REALIZES
FROM CON FROM CONTRACTING WILL
BE GONE. AND THEY'LL HAVE TO
MAKE IT UP SOMEWHERE. AND PART
OF IT NO DOUBT WILL BE TUITION
INCREASES. AS MEASURE ALSO
BRING DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS TO A
NUMBER OF RESEARCH PROGRAMS.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST CLASS
WORKERS OF WHICH I STARTED WITH
ONE EXAMPLE FROM MY REGION OF
THE STATE IS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA A SAN DIEGO SCRIPTS
INTO THE INSTITUTION OF
OCEANOGRAPHY. FIRST THIS
MEASURE WOULD GOT SCRIPTS
ABILITY TO CONTRACT WITH CALL
QUALIFIED MARINERS TO
SUPPLEMENT THEIR FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES. WHICH IS VITAL TO
THEIR MISSION OF EXPLORING OUR
OCEANS AND STUDYING THINGS LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE SLEEP SEA LEVEL
RISE AND STORM SURGES WHICH
THEY'RE DOING VERY GREAT WORK
ON BY THE WAY. YEAH THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MARINERS THAT CAN
SET SAIL. THAT MEANS THAT THEY
CANNOT CONDUCT THEIR RESEARCH.
SCRIPT TIRES PART TIME
TEMPORARY MARINERS ON A PER
DIEM BASIS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
NATIONAL OCEANOGRAPHIC LABOR
SYSTEM. THESE ARE WELL
QUALIFIED AND CREDENTIALED
MARINERS THAT URGED CHOOSING TO
WORK IN THIS PART TIME SYSTEM
INSTEAD OF THE TRADITINAL
SCHEDULES THAT DO NOT SUIT THEM
FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY
CHOOSE. BUT THEY DON'T STUDENT.
ADDITIONALLY THE TEMPORARY AND
SHORT TERM SUBCONTRACTORS THAT
HELP REPAIRTHE INSTITUTE SHIPS
WILL NO LONGER BE ALLOWED
BECAUSE THEY'RE PROJECTS OFTEN
TAKE LONGER THAN TEN DAYS.
SCRIPT DOES NOT HAVE THE
EXPERTISE TO FIX THEIR OWN
VESSELS. NOR DO THEY HAVE A THE
A QUALIFIED SHIPYARD IN WHICH
TO MAKE THOSE REPAIRS. THE
SUBCONTRACTORS RUN THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES AND HAVE NO
INTENTION OF BECOMING EMPLOYEES
OF THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM. HAVE SCRIPTS
CANNOT CONTRACT WITH THEM THEY
HAVE PLENTY OF OTHER CLIENTS
THAT WILL. THE LOSS OF
EXPERTISE WILL FOR SCRIPTS TO
CUT BACK ON THE NUMBER OF SHIPS
IT SALES AND THE NUMBER OF
VOYAGES IT UNDERTAKES.
CONSEQUENTLY THE STORE SCRIPT
THE STORIED STRIPS INSTITUTION
OF OCEANOGRAPHY WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO FULFILL ITS ROBUST
RESEARCH MISSION. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I AGREE WITH THE AS
GOOD SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE
THAT F WE CAN COME BACK NEXT
YEAR AND USE A SCALPEL INSTEAD
OF A SLEDGE HAMMER I THINK WE
CAN SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED TODAY I
ORIGINAL VOTE THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND I RISE AND
I'M EXCITED TO BE A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS BILL. I WANT TO REPEAT
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT I
MADE WHEN WE HEARD THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW WHO ARE WE
AS A GROUP WHO ARE WE AS
LEGISLATORS IF WE CAN ALLOW. A
GROUP OF WORKERS TO BE TREATED
AS SECOND CLASS CITIZENS. AND
THIS IS WHAT I SEE THIS AS IS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE
THE UNIVERSITIES RUN SURE WE
NEED THE TEACHERS SURE WE NEED
ADMINISTRATORS BUT IF ALL THE
FOLKS THAT ARE IN THE GALLERY
WITH US TODAY. AND THE HUNDREDS
AND THOUSANDS OF MORE WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE DIDN'T SHOW UP
TO WORK EVERY DAY. THE UC'S
WOULD CLOSE THEY WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO RUN SO WHY IS IT THAT
WE DON'T VALUE THEM. LIKE WE
VALUE OTHER PEOPLE. AND ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS I THINK IS
INTERESTING AND VERY CONCERNING
TO ME. IS THAT WE HAVE OUR
FUTURE LEADERS GETTING AN
EDUCATION THERE AND WHAT ARE WE
TEACHING THEM ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE IF WE DON'T VALUE ALL
WORK. THIS IS ABOUT VALUING ALL
WORK AND MAKING SURE THAT
WORKERS ARE PAID A LIVING WAGE.
FIRST ONE TO REPEAT OME OF
THINGS THAT I SAID. IN
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE THINGS I HEARD
I THINK I HEARD SOMEONE SAY
THAT. YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST WE'RE
DOING THIS AND IT SHOULD BE
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED. BUT
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AND
SOMEONE COLLECT CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG. THEY'VE BEEN
NEGOTIATING FOR TWELVE YEARS SO
THAT'S OVER A DECADE THAT THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN TRYING TO COME
TO RESOLUTION. I THINK THAT'S
MORE THAN ENOUGH TIME AND I
THINK IT'S HIGH TIME THAT WE DO
SOMETHING. WE TALK ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS BUT
WHAT ABOUT TALKING ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE WORKERS
AT UC LET'S TALK ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING FOR THEM THE PEOPLE
THAT MAKE SURE. OUR YOUNG MINDS
ARE ABLE TO COME TO THESE
UNIVERSITIES AND BE OUR FUTURE
LEADERS. THE MEMBERS IT'S WITH
GREAT PRIDE THAT I AM A CO
AUTHOR AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SEEING NO
OTHER MIKE'S UP I BELIEVE
DISCUSSION HAS SEIZED. SENATOR
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
WOULD THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL AND CIVIL DEBATE
THIS MORNING ON ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. THE ONE THING
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT NO ONE
ARGUED THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
EDUCATION
ABOUT HOPE AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
OUR STUDENTS. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE SHOULD HAVE HOPE
AND OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL PEOPLE.
AND IN THIS MEASURE GETS US ONE
STEP CLOSER TO HAVING AN
EQUITABLE SOCIETY I LIKE TO
ADDRESS. SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE. THIS IS NOT
ABOUT EQUITY EQUITY IT MUST BE
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION AND COST.
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION. IF
THERE IS AN EMERGENCY THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT
SUPERSEDES THIS ANY ANY OTHER
MEASURE IN THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
RIGHT TO CALL THAT. IN IN TERMS
OF FLEXIBILITY UP TURNED TO PAY
AGAIN PAGE FIVE LINE THIRTY
NINE SEE NOTHING IN THIS
SECTION SHALL PRECLUDE THE
REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA OR ANY CAMPUS OR
OTHER ENTITY OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA FROM USING PER DIEM
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES TO
COMPLEMENT CAREER IN LIMITED
POSITION UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES.
WHAT IS NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN
STAFFING LEVELS FOR TEMPORARY
AND EMERGENCY PERIODS. SO THAT
DOES CREATE FLEXIBILITY AND IT
DOES ADDRESS THE MAYOR THE
MARINERS SITUATION WITH WITH
SCRAPS. TEN AND OBVIOUSLY THE
MEDICAL STAFF. IN TERMS OF
FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY THIS
MEASURE IS PRUDENT. I HAVE A
WHOLE LIST HERE OF ABUSES AT
THE UC SYSTEM HAS DONE IN THE
PAST I'M NOT GOING TO GO
THROUGH THEM YET SINCE IT'S THE
LAST DAY SESSION BUT THEY
CURRENTLY CLAIM THAT THESE
CONTRACTS. US FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS ABC A FOURTEEN WOULD LATER
ON ANOTHER A HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. HERE'S A
THE FAX OUR OWN SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE STAFF
AND MIKE GYMNAST WHO WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF FISCAL DIRECTOR FOR
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER HAVE
LOOKED IT LOOKED AT THE
INFORMATION AND THE TOTAL COST
OF THESE LABOR CONTRACTS ARE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. WE'LL TAKE YOU
SEE AT THEIR WORD THAT IT'S
GONNA COST ANOTHER A HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO MILLION SO WE ADD
THAT IN. THAT'S FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS LESS. THEY CLAIM
THEY'RE PAYING TODAY SO THERE'S
NOT GOING TO BE ANY TUITION.
INCREASES ON THIS MEASURE THIS
MEASURE. AT WORST IS FACE
FISCALLY EVEN MAYBE POTENTIALLY
EVEN SAVE MONEY FOR THE SYSTEM.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THE PRO TEM
IN THE SENATOR FROM SENSEI TALK
ABOUT HOW THIS IS BEEN AN
ONGOING BATTLE FOR DECADES. FOR
DECADES. FOR ME I LOVE
BASKETBALL AND I'M ALSO OLD SO
I REMEMBER BASKETBALL BEFORE
THERE WAS A SHOT CLOCK. AND I
PERSONALLY AM UCLA BASKETBALL
FAN BUT THOSE WHO WERE OLDER
REMEMBER DEAN SMITH AND IN
NORTH CAROLINA WHICH IS ALSO
HISTORICAL POWER. AND WILL AND
DEAN SMITH CREATED THE FOUR
CORNERS OFFENSE AND WHAT THAT
WAS BECAUSE IT WAS NO SHOT
CLOCK THE MINUTE HE GOT THE
LEAD. HE PUT HIS PEOPLE IN THE
CORNER AND THEY WOULD JUST
THROW THE BALL AROUND TO KEEP
IT FROM THE OPPONENTS. LADIES
AND GENTLEMENTHAT'S WHAT THE
UC REGENTS HAVE BEEN DOING FOR
FOUR DECADES EVEN PLAYING FOUR
CORNERS WITH OUR WORKERS AND
IT'S WRONG IT'S GOT TO STOP WE
NEED TO PASS THIS MEASURE TODAY
AND PUT THEM ON THE SHOT CLOCK.
IF THEY WANT TO FIX IN FOR THIS
GOES TO VOTERS THEY CAN DO THAT
BUT WE HAVE TO FORCE THEIR HAND
THERE IS NO LEADERSHIP. I HAVE
A MINUTES ABOUT RESPECT I STILL
COME SPEAKER PREZ AND IF
ANYBODY CAN GET IT DONE HE CAN
GET IT DONE BUT WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE THEM EXTERNE COURAGE ME TO
GET IT DONE. SO WITH THAT THIS
IS EQUITABLE. IT'S KLAY PRUDENT
INFIRM MY FRIENDS AND MY CAUCUS
WILL TALK ABOUT THE BEST
GOVERNMENT. IS A GOVERNMENT
CLOSEST TO THE PEOPLE. NOTHING
IS CLOSER THAN LETTING THE
VOTERS MAKE THIS DECISION. SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A CA
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU ALL DEBATE
AND DISCUSSION HAVING SEIZED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE SIDE. ALLEN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL I PORGES NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. I CHIANG BY DAILY NO
DODD. NO DURAZO HI GALGIANI. I
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG NO HILL AYE HUESO AYE
AUTO. HI JACKSON. JONES. NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
HI MONNING. MORE LOCK NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. RUBIO.
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER IOWA CASKEY BY WIENER
AYE WILK HI. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
JACKSON MONNING. ROTH RUBIO.
SIR WILL MOVE THE CALL. MEMBERS
ARE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
RECESS AND WE WILL RECONVENE AT
THREE PM SHARP AT THREE PM
SHARP THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS FOR THE NEXT TWO HOURS.
CENTER WINNER WHERE ARE. THE
FIRST RECOGNIZE SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU RESERVE RESERVOIR
PER PRISONER WINNER THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE SOMETIME
BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN WE READ TO
ME AND IF MEMBERS COULD JUST BE
AVAILABLE WILL LET YOU NOW THE
EXACT TIME WITH SOME NOTICE OUT
OF TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROWTH. OUR MEMBERS WE
WILL BE IN RECESS TO THREE JOHN
THIRTY THREE. LOOKING FOR
AUTHOR I MEAN A MANAGER FLOOR
MANAGER. SOON OR IS SENATOR
NELSON ARE WILL WORK. BOB
.
CENTER NIELSEN WE OUT FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE IF YOU'RE PREPARED
TO TAKE THAT UP. HE'S READY
MMHM SECRETARY GOVERNMENT IN
THERE PLEASE HURRY. THAT MISTER
PRESIDENT MADE LATE NUMBER SENT
TO MY APOLOGIES IF I'VE HELD UP
THIS WE'RE WE'RE GONNA MISS
MISS LOTTIE TODAY SENATOR.
RELATIVE SECRETARY OF THE DIAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE INTERNAL
SINCE LOS YET TO OFFER HOLD UP
FOLKS WE'RE GOING TO. GET GOING.
THIS IS A BILL HAS. THAT HELPS
WHAT WAS IT CALLED THE- IT IS A
THE EIGHTY USE. A JUDGE DAIS
INTO. HELPFUL IN AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE HI CONGESTION. IT'S KIND
OF AN INTENSIVE WAY OF HOUSING.
AND IT'S BEEN A BIG ASSET. IN
THE FUTURE. WHAT'S HAPPENED NOW.
THE. BUILDING OF HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES DOESN'T ALWAYS
ALIGN. WITH THE NEEDS THAT
HAPPENS FOR MANY REASONS. IN
THE WAR DEBTS HOUSING OFTEN IS
NOT. THE PREFERRED HOUSING. AND
THERE ARE ALSO BARRIERS. TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE HOUSING
UNITS. SO THE GOAL HERE. IS TO
IMPROVE AFFORDABILITY. AND
SUPPLY. IN PART BY GETTING
UNITS BUILT MORE QUICKLY. IN A
LOWER COST. MANY LOCAL AGENCIES.
IT APPEARS ON EVENLY. THOSE
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT THIS
DEVELOPMENT. THAT'S WHY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG HAS
INTRODUCED THIS LEGISLATION. IT
HELPS RAPIDLY OR MORE RAPIDLY
INCREASE DENSITY HOUSING. IN
URBAN AREAS. IT ALLOWS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF MULTIPLE.
AFFORDABILITY HOUSING UNIT. IN
THE EIGHTY YOU AREA ON SINGLE
FAMILY LOTS. CALIFORNIANS
THEREFORE CAN BUILD MORE
HOUSING. IT HAS HAD THUS FAR.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THERE'S
MERIT EVEN. ALTHOUGH THIS BILL
WOULD NOT REALLY APPLY TO. THE
LITTLE COMMUNITY OF PARADISE IT
WAS DESTROYED. BUT EVEN BEFORE
THE FIRE PARADISE WAS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW. TO HAVE MORE
MULTI FAMILY RESIDENCES. IN A
MORE CONFINED AREA EVEN IN THAT
LITTLE SMALL COMMUNITY. THE
ONLY TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE. THIS BILL WILL HELP IN
THAT REGARD. I WOULD ASK AN AYE
VOTE. AS ANOTHER. DEVELOPMENT
IN THE GREAT CONTINUUM OF DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA THAT BEING ACCESSORY
UNITS. THERE ARE MORE
AFFORDABLE. ECONOMIC AND
EFFICIENT. THANK SENATOR CENTER
Y. COSTLY THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THE AS THE FLOOR
MANAGER HAS INDICATED THERE'S
BEEN AND EVEN BARRIERS THROUGH
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EXCESS
REDRAWING UNIT WORK THIS THAT
THIS CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE
HAVES HAVE DONE OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS TO DEVELOP ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AB SIXTY EIGHT
HARMONIZES INCOME AND COMPLETES
A SUITE OF EIGHTY YOU BILLS
INCLUDING MY BILL SB THIRTEEN
BY REMOVING THESE REMAINING
BARRIERS TO EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION IN THIS BILL WE
INCLUDE SETBACKS MINIMUM LOT
SIZE AN ERROR AND FLOOR AREA
RATIO REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN A BARRIER I WILL POINT OUT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY HAS
CHAMPION THESE IDEAS IN AN
ALTERNATIVE. LEGISLATION I WILL
BE VOTING. ON A ON THIS
IMPORTANT HOUSING MATTER AND
IRISH AND I'VE OF. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
INTERNAL SO UNTIL IT CLOSED.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
LAYING DOWN THE SENATE THIS IS
AN EXAMPLE THERE ARE THREE
BILLS I THINK MOVING ALONG AND
IT SHOWS THAT. THERE CAN BE
BIPARTISAN COOPERATION ON THESE
ISSUES OF GREAT MOMENT. THESE
THREE BILLS DON'T PART THE RED
SEA BUT THEY ARE ALL PART AND
PARCEL OF THAT CONTINUUM OF
SUCCESS TO PROVIDE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. IT ALSO SHOWS. A
LINKAGE BETWEEN URBAN AND RURAL
WORDS SUCH CONCEPTS AT LEAST
CAN HELP THE ROLE AS WELL AS
URBAN AREAS I ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. AS YOU CAN SEE WE'RE
SHORT OF SEVERAL MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
ROLL CALL ONE TIME AND THEN
WE'LL PLACE TO MOUNT ON CALL.
THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES
BELL HI PORGES EFFORT I
CABALLERO HI CHIANG. DELHI I
DODD. ALSO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
TADO. JACKSON. JONES NO LEYVA.
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONNING
BY MORE LOCK RAIL. NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH BY
RUBIO HI SKINNER AYE STERN. NO
STONE. NO NUMBER IRA CASKEY BY
WINNER BY WILK NO. SURE NO
SOMOS A CALL. NEXT MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
FOUR. SENATOR GONZALEZ HE
PREPARED. THIS SECTOR PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AN ACT RELATING TO
FIREFIGHTERS INTERNALS ME
CENTER GONZALEZ I'M SORRY THANK
YOU. MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SIXTEEN
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR FIREFIGHTER PEER
SUPPORT PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
FOR CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN TRAIN PEER SUPPORT TEAM
MEMBERS AND THEIR FELLOW PEACE
OFFICERS IS A COMPANION MEASURE
TO THE PEACE OFFICER PETE
SUPPORT BILL WHICH PASSED OFF
THIS FLOOR UNANIMOUSLY
YESTERDAY EMERGENCY SERVICE
PERSONNEL WORKING UNPREDICTABLE
HIGH STRESS ENVIRONMENT SECOND
TAKEN OVERWHELMING MENTAL
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL TOLL A
SURVEY CO AUTHORED BY
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AN NBC BAY AREA
FOUND THAT NEARLY ONE IN SIX
FIREFIGHTERS. HAS CONSIDERED
SUICIDE AND FIRST RESPONDERS
ARE OFTEN RELUCTANT TO UTILIZE
EXISTING PROGRAMS AB ONE ONE
SIX I WILL INCREASE
AVAILABILITY AND USE OF PEER
SUPPORT IN CRISIS REFERRAL
SERVICES BY ALLOWING FOR
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN TRAIN FARE SUPPORT
PERSONNEL AND THEIR FELLOW
FIREFIGHTERS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. CENA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES HI BILL BY BURGESS BY
BRADFORD AYE AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD.
DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TADO
BY JACKSON I JONES. BY LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M REAL
AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG OUR CASSIE I WIENER AYE
WILK. BY CAN I. SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
ATKINS DOT GROWTH PORTANTINO I.
CONSIDER MOVES THE ITEM NEXT UP
IS FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE NINETY
SENATOR DODD AT HIS BEST.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
ONCE AND DODD AGAIN. LET'S SEE.
FILE I'M FIFTY TWOS SENATOR
HILL ARE YOU PREPARED. WHICH
ONE. I NOW FORTY ONE OR FORTY
ONE. YEAH THREE ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM. YEAH I
WOULD LIKE YOU. WHAT WE'RE
DOING FORTY ONE CENTER HELP. NO
DOT TO DOT FORTY ONE. WE DON'T
HAVE USED FORTY ONE ON HERE.
OKAY. FOR MOVING A FILE ITEM
FORTY THREES SENATOR HERTZBERG
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THE SIGHT
OF. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND ACT REALLY INTO
ELECTIONS. HERTZBERG WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THIS MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN SEEKS TO
SAFEGUARD THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS A TASK THAT IS NOT
ONLY BECOME MORE CHALLENGING
WITH THE INCREDIBLE ADVANCEMENT
IN TECHNOLOGY ONE OF THE MOST
TROUBLING RECENTDEVELOPMENTS
IS THE INVENTION AND
PROLIFERATION. OF DEEP FAKES
WHICH ARE EXTREMELY CONVINCING
FABRICATED PHOTOS VIDEOS AUDIO
RECORDINGS OF SOMEONE APPEARING
TO SAY OR DO SOMETHING THAT
THEY DID NOT. THE ABILITY TO
TRIBUTE A SPEECH AND CONDUCT TO
A CANDIDATE IS FALSE WITH HIS
NEVER EVEN HAPPENED MAKES DEEP
TAKES A POWERFUL AND DANGEROUS
NEW TOOL IN THE ARSENAL OF
THOSE WHO WANT TO WAGE MISSION
FORMATION CAMPAIGNS. IN JANUARY
OUR UNITED STATES DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE DAN COATS
WARNED THE DEEP BAKES WILL
PROBABLY BE AMONG THE TACTICS
USED TO DISRUPT THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTIONS AND WITH THOSE
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTIONS AROUND
THE CORNER. WE MUST DO MORE TO
CURB THE PROLIFERATION OF DEEP
FAKES OR OTHER MANIPULATED
MEDIA. THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
ON THE READ IT SPECIFICALLY
SAYS. A DEEP TAKE MEANS THAT
THAT A MATERNAL DECEPTIVE AUDIO
OR VISUAL MEDIA TO MEAN AN
IMAGE OR RECORDING VISUAL
RECORDING THAT HAS BEEN
INTENTIONALLY MANIPULATED. TO
ALTER THE APPEARANCE SPEECH
YOUR CONDUCT OF A CANDID SO AS
TO CREATE A SIGNIFICANT
LIKELIHOOD OF CAUSING A
REASONABLE PERSON TO UNDERSTAND
OF EXPERIENCED EXPRESSION
EXPRESSIVE CONDUCT CONTENT OF
THE IMAGE OR RECORDING IN A
MANNER THAT IS FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT. FROM THE
UNDERSTANDING OR EXPERIENCE
THAT A PERSON WOULD HAVE HAD IF
THE PERSON WE'RE HEARING OR
SEEING ARE THE ON ALTERED
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE IMAGE
OR RECORDING. IN THIS SAYS THAT
YOU'VE GOT THIS THIS BASICALLY
SAYS FOR SOME OF THE PERIOD OF
SIXTY DAYS OF THE ELECTION.
THAT MAKES IT ILLEGAL. THE LAST
THING I WANT TO RAISE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL OUT ALLEY THE
ISSUE AND I WANT TO RAISE. A
LETTER THAT WAS WRITTEN BY THE
UNITED STATES THE U. S. C. C.
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW DEAN.
ONE SHERMAN AND SKI AND WHAT HE
SAID IS WITH RESPECT TO THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY BECAUSE X.
IMPORTANT AS WE- TRY TO DEAL
WITH THESE BALANCES ON THE
FLOOR. ALTHOUGH THIS BILL WOULD
REGULATE ITS ITS PROHIBITION OF
DEEP THE IT REGULATE SPEECH. IS
PROHIBITION OF DEEP TAKES WOULD
NOT VIOLATE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. FALL SPEECH AT TIMES
IS PROTECTED BUT OFTEN THE
GOVERNMENT IS ALLOWED TO
PROHIBITED WITHOUT RUNNING
AFOUL OF THE CONSTITUTION. FOR
EXAMPLE LYING IN THE COURT ROOM
UNDER OATH PERJURY IS NOT
PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT EVEN THOUGH IT
SPEECH. THE SUPREME COURT HAS
BEEN CLEAR. THE FALSE AND
DECEPTIVE ADVERTISING HAS NO
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTION MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE BOARD HAS SAID
THAT SPEECH WHICH IS DEFAMATORY
OF PUBLIC OFFICIALS PUBLIC
FIGURES. HAS NOT FIRST ABED BUT
PROTECTION. THE SPEED OF THE-
BALL SIR AXE. OUT WITH RECKLESS
DISREGARD FOR THE TRUTH. SIX IN
THE PORTENTS OF PREVENTING
WRONGFUL HARM TO REPUTATION AND
PROTECTING THE MARKETPLACE OF
IDEAS JUSTIFIES. THAT LIABILITY
FOR FALL SPEECH AB SEVEN THIRTY
THE MATTER WHICH WE HAVE BEFORE
US SERVE THESE PURPOSES AND USE
THIS EXACT USES EXACT LEGAL
STANDARD. IT PROHIBITS DEEP
TAKES IN THE POLITICAL REALM
APPLIES ONLY WHEN THE FALSE
IMAGES WERE KNOWINGLY OR
RECKLESSLY CREATED OR
DISSEMINATE AND DISSEMINATED.
THE TECHNOLOGY FOR DEEP TAKES
ADVANCING QUICKLY THE LAW MUST
BE KEPT UP. AND DEAL WITH THE
SERIOUS PROBLEM I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR VERGES
ON THIS ITEM. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. COUPLE OF A QUICK
COMMENTS AND WE WITH YOUR TO
WITH YOUR UP TO LIKE TO POSE A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR OF IN
HER TOWARD WERE TO TAKE
QUESTION CERTAINLY THIS IS I
THINK VERY TELLING OF OUR TIME
WE NEED TO PROTECTIONS OF THIS
OF THIS SORT. AND I THINK ALL
OF US UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
INSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE CAN BLUR
THE LINES BETWEEN ADVOCACY AND
OUTRIGHT MANIPULATION AND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT BEING AS IT IS
WE'VE GROWN ACCUSTOMED TO
VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING BUT THOSE
DAYS. ARE ARE ARE CERTAINLY I
THINK OF IN THE PAST GIVEN THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT EXISTS RIGHT
NOW IN THE INTERFERENCE THAT WE
KNOW THAT HAS OCCURRED IN THE
LAST ELECTION IT WILL CAN OCCUR
IN ALL FUTURE ELECTIONS SO I
THINK THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL MY QUESTION TO THE
FLOOR MANAGER ON THIS. IS. THE
BONUS WILL THE ONUS MAY BE ON
THE AGGRIEVED PARTY. TO
VINDICATE THEMSELVES OR WILL
THE MEDIA OUTLET. THAT RELEASES
IT BE THE BE THOSE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY. FOR THE PLIGHT. TO THE
CHAIR THE PLAINTIFF WOULD HAVE
TO PROVE BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
LIKE THIS IF THERE WAS A
BROADCASTER WHATEVER. THEY
WOULD HAVE TO PROVE THE
PLAINTIFF IN THE CASE WHICH
WOULD NOT BE THE BROADCASTER
THE NEWS MEDIA IT. WOULD HAVE
TO PUT WOULD HAVE TO PROVE.
THAT THOSE WHO BROADCAST THIS
OR PRINTED THIS DID SO WITH
ACTUAL MALICE SO THE BURDEN
WOULD BE ON THE PLAINTIFF IN
THE STANDARD IS ABOUT THE
HIGHEST STANDARD YOU COULD
MAKE. BECAUSE IT IS VERY
CHALLENGING THIS THIS WHOLE
THING WE'VE GOT WHAT TECHNOLOGY
IS JUST MIND NUMBINGLY
DIFFICULT. WHERE WE HAVE THESE
VERY IMPORTANT PRINCIPLES OF
FREE SPEECH BUT WE HAVE THEM
BEING THAT THEY'RE BEING
RECKLESSLY DISREGARDED
TECHNOLOGY IN FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT. SO WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW TO DO IT SO
THIS APPEARS TO BE A PRETTY
CAREFULLY CRAFTED AND NARROWER
THAN THE OFFER ONE. MEASURE IN
ORDER TO BE RESPECTFUL OF THOSE
CONSTITUTION CONCERN SO.
EXAMPLE. IMAGINE A IN A STEAMED
LEADER IN OUR COMMUNITY. BOB
HERTZBERG. ALL OF A SUDDEN IS
PUT OUT THERE ON FACEBOOK AS
BEING PRO REPUBLICAN. BALLOT IF
THE WITH THE FACEBOOK ON
POSTING OF THAT. WHICH FACEBOOK
BE HELD TO ACCOUNT ARE ONLY IT
WOULD BE THROUGH A NEWS OUTLET
LIKE A MEDIA SOURCE. NO THE
UNDER THE UNDER THE LAW THE
UNDER SECTION TWO THIRTY OF THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS DECENCY
ACT NO SOCIAL PLATFORMS OUR
PLATFORMS ARE IMMUNE FROM
LIABILITY UNDER THOSE THEORIES
SO THAT IS PR EMPTED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THEY
ARE NOT OTHERWISE LIABLE OR
THIS IS DEFINITELY A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVEN THIRTY AND I THINK
THAT THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION
ENCAPSULATES THE REASON QUOTE
THE INEVITABLE RESULT IF A. B.
SEVEN THIRTY WERE TO BECOME LAW
WOULD BE A PROFOUND CHILLING
EFFECT ON POLITICAL SPEECH THE
VERY THING. THE FIRST AMENDMENT
WAS DESIGNED TO PREVENT FOR
THOSE REASONS SUPPORTING OUR
CONSTITUTION OR TO NOTE VOTE
AND AB SEVEN THIRTY. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEN IN
HEARING NINE SOONER HERTZBERG
WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE. THE POINT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE POINT
ABOUT A CHILLING EFFECT IS
IMPORTANT. VERY IMPORTANT THERE
IS NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT AND
THIS IS THE REAL CHALLENGE THAT
E FACE WITH THESE NEW KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGIES WE SAW THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE IN WASHINGTON.
BEING COMPLETELY MANIPULATED
THROUGH A VIDEO THREE MILLION
PEOPLE WATCH THAT AND IT LOOKED
LIKE IT WAS ACCURATE AND TODAY
THE TECHNOLOGY IS EVEN MORE
SOPHISTICATED. AND SO THIS
MEASURE HAS BEEN NARROWED IT IS
BEST AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN I
THINK THAT ONE SHERMAN IN SKIS
A POINT OF VIEW THE DEAN OF THE
LAW SCHOOL CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLAR. THE REASON I READ IT
SAID IT BEST BECAUSE AND VERY
SENSITIVE TO THOSE ISSUES. SO
THE ARGUMENT IS IN SO MANY OF
THESE THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT ON
THIS FLOOR THE LAST NUMBERS
TODAY'S THESE DELICATE
BALANCES. BALANCES IN TERMS OF
RIGHTS OF FOLKS AND OBLIGATIONS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES. AND SO
NOW WE HAVE THIS NEW ISSUE
WEAPON ISING THE INTERNET IN
THE WAY THAT. NO ONE COULD EVER
HAVE IMAGINED. AND SO HOW DO
YOU DEAL WITH THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS HOW DO YOU BALANCE THESE
THINGS THAT THE FRAMERS OF THE
CONSTITUTION NEVER WOULD HAVE
EVER DREAMED OF. AND SO THE
QUESTION IS I THINK AS IT'S
NARROWLY DRAFTED TARGETS THE
CORE POLITICAL SPEECH. WITHOUT
REGARD TO LEGITIMACY COMMENTARY
AND CRITICISM PARODY AND SATIRE
REENACTMENTS OF REAL EVENTS.
THE AND THE LIKE THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS ARE NOT BEING TAKEN ARE
ARE NOT BEING DRAWN IN THIS IS
ABOUT WHERE SOMEBODY ENGAGES
THE MALICIOUS BEHAVIOR. ALL ON
THE INTERNET. AND JUST IS
COMPLETELY FALSE AND TAKES THE
SITUATION WHERE IN THE VERY
SUPREME COURT CASES IN THE
PUBLIC OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN TOLD
LIMITED. TO GIVE NEW TOOLS IN
THAT REGARD AND I THINK BEING
PARTICULARLY SENSITIVE. TO
CHILL IN FACT I THINK IT
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE LAST
YEAR I BOUGHT. THANK YOU HALL
DEBATE HAPPEN SEIZED SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL BY PORGES ARE BRADFORD AYE
AYE AYE CABALLERO AYE CHIANG I
DALY. NO DODD DORADO GALGIANI I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO. JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA.
I'M MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK. MORRELL.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN BY PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER OUR
CASKEY. WINNER. HI WILK NO.
SENATOR HURTS MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY TWO SENATOR HILL ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM. THANK.
YOU MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWENTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS ANAK RULING OF
HEALTH. VIDEO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR I PROUDLY
PRESENT A. B. NINE TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN PETRIE-NORRIS
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY PROTECTION
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PATIENTS IN
RECOVERY BY REQUIRING ALL OUT
PATIENT TREATMENT PROGRAMS TO
BE LICENSED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THIS BODY
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED THIS
POLICY IN MY BILL SB THREE
TWENTY FIVE AND I APPRECIATE
OUR CO AUTHOR SENATOR FROM A
GOOD SENATOR FROM LAGUNA GAL.
THIS MEASURE HAS KNOWN NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION AND UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEGE. Q. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
SENATOR STONE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I STRONGLY STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE TWENTY IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT I HAD A BILL.
THAT WAS I HELD IN THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WOULD OF
PUT ALCOHOLISM BUT THE LAND
FROM AN ACT WHICH IS KIND OF
UNFORTUNATE BUT- THIS BILL. I
THINK IT'S GONNA STEM THE TIDE
OF INAPPROPRIATE THERAPIES THAT
ARE OUT THERE THAT ARE ROBBING
PEOPLE OF THEIR SAVINGS AND
TRYING TO HELP THEIR LOVED
ONES. THIS IS THE KIND OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE HONEST
PROVIDERS OUT THERE THAT ARE
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE SOME OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT ADDICTIONS.
NAMELY ALCOHOLISM IN THE STATE
AND SO I. FIRMLY REQUESTS AND
HIGH VOTE ON MAYBE NINE TWENTY.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT ON I'D
LIKE TO COMMAND TO OFF THE
FLOOR MANAGER AND THE AUTHOR OF
FOR PUTTING THIS FORWARD WE'VE
BEEN WORKING SO LONG NOW
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE TO TRY
TO RAINY AND NOW THOSE WHO
ABUSE THE MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR SOCIETY THOSE WHO
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE BECOME
ADDICTED TO SOME. OF SUBSTANCE
OR ANOTHER WHO ARE HONESTLY
SEEKING TREATMENT AND FIND
THEMSELVES INTO VERY REPUTABLE
OB TREATMENT CENTERS THAT
REALLY I USE THEM MERELY
OUTSIDE COULD CHECKING OUR TO
LINE THEIR OWN POCKETS SO WE
THINK THE AUTHOR THE FLOOR
MANAGER AND IT WAS MY PLEASURE
AND CERTAINLY ALL MY- MY HONOR
TO BE INCLUDED WITH THIS
BECAUSE WE- CONTINUE OUR
EFFORTS SIDE THERE'S STILL MORE
TO BE DONE. SO WITHOUT I GIVE
IT A HEARTY THUMBS UP AND WISH
EVERYONE TO STRONGLY SUPPORTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE
CENTER START STERN. THANK YOU
MISTER BRADFORD MISTER
PRESIDENT SORRY. THERE WAS
INADVERTENTLY REMOVED IS A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE BUT I
JUST WANTED TO REITERATED
HOPEFULLY I'M STILL CO AUTHOR
IN SPIRIT AND TRYING TO BRING
SOME CERTAINTY BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY TAKE CARE PEOPLE WHO
SUFFERING FROM ADDICTION BUT-
PROTECTING OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AS
WELL AND MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
RECOURSE FOR FRAUDULENT ACTION
IN OUR COMMUNITY SO WITH THAT
EXPECT THE AS FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU TINO FURTHER MIKE'S
UP SENATOR HILL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I JUST APPRECIATE THE
GOOD THE COMMENTS FROM OUR GOOD
FRIENDS AND GOOD SENATORS FOR
THEIR FOR THEIR SUPPORT THEIR
COMMITMENT AND THEIR PASSION
FOR THE BEST APPROACH WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT RECOVERY FOR
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE WE SEE IN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIVE COLLEGE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN. ARCHULETA BY ATKINS
AYE BATES BY BILL BY BURGESS I
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I COVER EURO.
I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD.
DURAZO. HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ HI GROW. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL. HILL. WHAT
I HUESO HI TITLE. JACKSON I
JONES I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING HI MORE
LOCK I'M A REAL I NIELSEN. I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. BY ROTH.
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
BY STONE I AM BURKE. BY KELSEY
I WINNER HI WILK. HI. SOONER
HILL MOVES THE CALL NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE SENATOR
GLAZIER YOU'RE PREPARED FOR
THIS MEASURE. THE SECRETARY
WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K. HAND
AN ACT RELATING TO PARKS AND
RECREATION. CENTER GLAZER FOR
GEORGE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT THIS BILL ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN THE BACK OF
OUR QUE HAN IT'S A BILL THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION TO SELL A
PORTION OF THE CARNEGIE STATE.
VEHICLE RECREATION AREA FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES. IF THE
DEPARTMENT DETERMINES IT'S IN
THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST.
CURRENTLY THERE IS AN OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE PARKED RIGHT
NEXT DOOR. HAS BEEN DOWN IN
RECENT YEARS. THIS PARCEL THIS
EXPANSION PARCEL HAS BEEN.
UNDER LITIGATION FOR QUITE SOME
TIME IT'S VERY CONTROVERSIAL.
AND THIS BILL ALL IT DOES IS IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE A SALE IT SAYS
THAT IF THE DEPARTMENT.
DETERMINES IN THEIR INTERESTS
THAT. SALE WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
TO GIVE THEM THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT. AND KEEP IN MIND THAT WE
HAVE AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE OF
OFF ROAD ENTHUSIASTS ADVISING
THE DEPARTMENT IS THE OFF
HIGHWAY. VEHICLE COMMISSION AND
SO THE DEPARTMENT IN
CONSULTATION OF THE COMMISSION
THEY MAKE THAT DETERMINATION.
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SELL THE
PROPERTY NOW ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL IS IT
SETS A MINIMUM SELLING PRICE.
DOESN'T THAT JUST FOLLOW THE
TYPICAL SALES SURPLUS LAND
PROTOCOLS IT SAYS YES THAT'S
WHAT WILL HAPPEN BUT IT CAN'T
KILL ANYTHING BELOW THAN WHAT
THE PURCHASE PRICE WISE. I WANT
TO SAY THAT THIS MEASURE
SUPPORTED BY CITY IN AND THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA. BECAUSE IT
IS SPECIAL ECOLOGICAL VALUE OF
THIS PARCEL THE SIERRA CLUB THE
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY THE
AUDUBON SOCIETY OF ALL COME OUT
IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BORCHERS. QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR OUR OR OF FIELDS OF FOR
MANAGER PLEASE ENTER GLAZER WE
TO QUESTION HAPPY TO YES. IS
THERE ANY REVERSIONARY LANGUAGE
THAT SHOULD A PURCHASER ASSUME
TITLE THAT WOULD KEEP THEM FROM
SELLING IT TO BY ANY OTHER
ENTITY. AND POCKETING THE FAIR
MARKET VALUE. I DON'T THINK
THAT THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION THERE'S NO INTENTION
TO HAVE THAT BE THE CASE IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S A
RULES IN WHICH WE DISPOSE OF
SURPLUS PROPERTY THE STATE.
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR TO
GO TO A PUBLIC AGENCIES FIRST
SO THE IDEA THAT IT COULD EVER
BE USED FOR THAT TYPE OF
ACTIVITY WOULD BE VERY LOW THIS
IS RURAL LAND IS NOT URBAN LAND
THIS IS OUT IN THE HINTERLANDS
OF. OF ALAMEDA COUNTY I DOES IT
HAVE THE TRADITIONAL DEVELOPING
RIGHTS ONE MIGHT EXPECT IN THAT
TYPE OF AREA SO I DON'T THINK
THAT. ISSUE IS REALLY IN PLAY
AND CERTAINLY THE DEPARTMENT
COULD TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT IF
THEY WERE TO CHOOSE TO BUY.
DECLARE THE LAND SURPLUS. ARE
MY ONLY CONCERN IS THAT WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH A- LAND
LIKE THIS. THAT IF YOU'RE A-
BASS LINE IS THE PURCHASE PRICE
BUT IT'S- THAT'S TWENTY. YEARS
DATED. WHY THEY WOULD BE USING
THE FAIR MARKET VALUE TODAY.
AND THE LAST WOULD BE A
REVERSIONARY CLAUSE THAT THE
PROPERTY OF SOLD TO A THIRD
PARTY OR INTENT TO BE SOLD TO A
THIRD PARTY WOULD AUTOMATICALLY
REVERT TO THE STATE. OF IN OR
SOME SORT OF CONSERVANCY I
WOULD SAY THIS THAT IF THAT WAS
EVER AN ISSUE I'VE CERTAINLY
HAS MY COMMITMENT AND I'LL
CHECK WITH THE AUTHOR AS WELL.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WOULD
NOT THAT'S NOT A PURPOSE OF
WHAT THIS MEAN THAT MEASURE
INTENDS TO DO AND WE CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T WANT THAT TO BE THE
RESULT OF A IT'S REALLY AN
ATTEMPT TO. IF THEY DECIDE THE
CONFLICT HAS GONE ON TOO LONG
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
LITIGATION HAS GONE ON FOR TOO
LONG. THAT THAT THERE'S A THAT
IT CAN BE PRESERVED IN
CONSERVATION AND PERMANENTLY
THAT'S REALLY THE GOAL TO GIVE
THEM THAT OPTION. IF THEY SO
CHOOSE. CENTER STONE. I THINK
IT WAS FAIR IF I IF I MAY ASK
THE AUTHOR OF THE LORD FOR
MANAGER QUESTION PLEASE. WE
TAKE A QUESTION YES THANK YOU
CENTER. AND I'M JUST USING MY
RECALL HERE OR THE LAST TIME WE
HAVE THIS BEING DISCUSSED I WAS
OPPOSED TO IT BECAUSE IF I
REMEMBER CORRECT AND I. FIND
THE TO BE CORRECTED PLEASE
CORRECT ME. THAT IT WAS HV FEES
AT WERE ORIGINALLY CHOIR DID
USE TO BUY THIS PROPERTY. IF
THAT IS THE CASE AND IF NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IS IN FACT THE
SELLING PRICE OF THE PROPERTY
WITH THE NINE MILLION DOLLARS
BE RETURNED TO THE A TREE FUN.
SO WE CAN MITIGATE THE LOSS OF
ALWAYS SHE LAND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR YOUR QUESTION. AND YES THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL IS
THAT IF THE PROPERTY WAS SOLD
AGAIN THAT'S AN OPTION THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE. NOT A
REQUIREMENT OF THIS BILL. THAT
THE FUNDS TO BE RETURNED TO THE
O. H. BE FINE TO BE USED FOR
ONLY HD PURPOSES. AND SO THOSE
WHO ARE ENTHUSIASTS OF THE
SPORT IN THIS BILL IS IN NO WAY
AS- AN ATTEMPT TO A TAKE AWAY
THAT RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITY.
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD GET
RESOURCES THAT ARE LOCKED DOWN
NOW GOING FOR NOTHING. AND HE'D
BE ABLE TO GET THOSE RESOURCES
BACK AND HOPEFULLY FIND OTHER
APPROPRIATE PLACES TO SUPPORT
THAT ACTIVITY IN THAT WOULD BE
AND THAT. AND THAT'S THE BILL
PROVIDES FOR THAT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR I APPRECIATE YOU
ANSWERING THE QUESTION. I THINK
IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE THAT
SINCE EACH THE FUNDS TO PAY FOR
THIS PROPERTY IF IT'S TO BE
SOLD AT THE OCEAN GO BACK INTO
THE HV FUN TO MAYBE FIND MORE
APPROPRIATE TO A PIECE OF LAND
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
KNOW OVER TWENTY YEARS SAID.
THINGS HAPPEN THINGS BECOME
EITHER MORE URBANITES ARE
THINGS GOING TO HABITAT AS
WE'VE SEEN IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WHERE WE HAVE PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST PROGRESSIVE HABITT
CONSERVATION PLANS IN THE
COUNTRY WITH A HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND ACRES SLATED TO
BE PUT INTO CONSERVATION BUT AS
A FORMER EACH Vì USER AND MANY
THAT USE EACH PIECE OF MY
DISTRICT. I'M PLEASED TO HEAR
THAT THE NINE MILLION DOLLARS
WILL GO BACK INTO THE WHICH THE
FUND I HOPE THAT IF THERE IS A
CAPITAL GAIN ON THIS PROPERTY
THAT THE GOOD SENATOR WILL
MAINTAIN ITS COMMITMENT WHICH I
BELIEVE THAT HE WILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE HD FUND HOPEFULLY
WILL BE WE MADE WHOLE WITH THAT
APPRECIATION AND WITH THAT I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF. THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR WHITE CULTURE. I RISE
AS A- PROUD. RESIDENT OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY MISTER PRESIDENT
RISE SINCE. OUR IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE I THINK THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE CHEN THE
UNDERSTAND THAT. ALAMEDA COUNTY
HAS PASSED MEASURE D. WHICH
LIMITS THE DEVELOPMENT ON ANY
COUNTY OPEN SPACE. THE ONE
HOUSING UNITS PER HUNDRED SO
WHILE THIS PARTICULAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. DOESN'T HAVE
REVISIONARY LANGUAGE IN IT
THERE ARE THERE ARE IN PLACE
PROTECTION SAID THAT THIS.
PROPERTY WILL REMAIN
ESSENTIALLY OPEN SPACE AGAIN I
THINK THE FLOOR MANAGER. AND
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR HAS. HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE ECOLOGICAL
UNIQUENESS OF THIS PROPERTY
WHICH IS THE- BEING PROTECTED
UNDER OUR CURRENT RULES THE SG
HAS THE ABILITY TO GIVE A
DISCOUNT FOR OPEN SPACE LAND
AND I THINK THAT THE DISCUSSION
THIS VOCAL ONE WITH THE SG
SHOULD MEASURE PASSED THIS
HOUSE SINGLE WANTING TO GAIN
THE GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE IS
STILL BE A DISCUSSION ON THE
VALUE THAT OPEN SPACE ALSO MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
LEGISLATION IS WRITTEN RIGHT
NOW ALL THE MONEY WILL GO TO
THE OFF ROAD VEHICLE FUND SO IF
THERE'S ANY SURPLUS THAT'S- NOT
SURPLUS BY THE NEGOTIATED.
AMOUNT AND THIS IS WILL BE FAIR
BY IN ONE OF THE ARMS IS STATE
GOVERNMENT SO I PLUG THE AUTHOR
AND THE FLOOR MANAGER FOR THE
HARD WORK TO PERSISTENT WORK ON
THIS ISSUE AND I WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORS HARD WORK ON THIS
HE'S BEEN VERY CONSISTENT ON
THAT. ALMOST TO A FAULT I THINK
AND I JUST KNOW I WANT TO TALK
TO THE PROCESS HERE. THIS
BILL'S BEEN HEARD A COUPLE OF
TIMES THIS YEAR. IT WAS HELD IN
THE ASSEMBLY THE SENATE BILL
WAS HERE. EARLIER VERSION OF
THIS AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
THIS WEEK WE HAVE A JAIL BREAK
ON A. B. TEN EIGHTY SIX. SO IS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROCESS ON
THIS AND- THE. THE JUST A
PROCESS AND I WOULD URGE NO
VOTE THANK YOU. TRADITIONS THAT
SORT OF LOOKING FOR TRADITIONS
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM HE NINE SENATOR GLAZER
WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT LET ME CLOSE
AND TALKING ABOUT THE PROCESS
SO. THIS BILL IN IT AT THE
CONSTANCE'S THIS BILL WERE
HEARD HERE IN THE SENATE A
COUPLE TIMES TO DIFFERENT
HEARINGS AND WAS HER ON THE
FLOOR AND PASSED OUT EARLIER
THIS YEAR. AND THIS PARTICULAR
BILLS HAD THREE HEARINGS IN THE
SENATE PRIOR TO THE FLOOR
DISCUSSION TODAY. AND FOR THOSE
WHO ARE VETERANS ALL KNOW THAT
A SIMILAR BILL ALMOST IDENTICAL
WAS INTRODUCED IN HEARD AND
PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE A YEAR
AGO. SO THERE'S BEEN QUITE A
LOT OF DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL
AND IT'S ALMOST EXACTLY THE
SAME FORM WE HAVE IT TODAY AND
SO I WOULD ARE MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT. THIS IS THAT A
PLOT PLENTY OF THAT VETTING AND
I THINK IT'S GOOD IT'S. IT'S
FOR PREFERS TAKE ACTION ON THIS
TODAY AND FINALLY ALL THAT
HEARING PROCESS I KNOW WE HAVE
A LOT OF OFF ROAD ENTHUSIASTS
IN THE SENATE. I MYSELF.
HAVEN'T REALLY GOTTEN ON ONE OF
THOSE BIKES YET BUT I'M VERY
OPEN TO THE IDEA JUST SO YOU
KNOW. YEAH AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A WORRY THAT SOMEHOW
THIS IS GONNA. I TAKE AWAY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE WHO
ENJOY THAT SPORT. AND MANY OF
THOSE FOLKS LIVE IN MY DISTRICT
IN THE ME JUST ASSURE YOU THAT.
WE HAVE AN OFF ROAD. VEHICLE
PARKED RIGHT NEXT DOOR. AND
IT'S A GREAT OUTLET ONE OF
EIGHT IN THE STATE. THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE THAT AND ANYWAY.
AND THAT. RESOLVING THIS ISSUE
AND I HOPE THE PARKS DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS CAN DO THAT QUICKLY.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BRING A
LOT MORE RESOURCES BACK INTO
THE HD FINE. SO THAT THAT THAT
ACTIVITY CAN BE PROMOTED. WHERE
IT'S APPROPRIATE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER. THANK YOU ALL
DEBATE INSCRIPTION HAVEN'T
SEIZED MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL BY BRIDGES NO BRADFORD AYE
CAMBIADO I CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
BY DATO. JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
HI MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MERRELL NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE
BY. NUMBER OUR CASKEY BY WIENER
AYE WILK. GLAZER MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING BACK
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE
SENATOR DAUGHTER YOU PREPARE TO
TAKE UP THIS ITEM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT RELATING
TO AIR AMBULANCE SERVICES YOUR
DAUGHTER FOR GEORGE THIS
RESIDENT MEMBERS AS A CO AUTHOR
I'M HAPPY PERCENT AB SIX FIVE
ONE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TIM GRAYSON. EMERGENCY
AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE STATEWIDE
EMS SYSTEM THEY HAVE ALSO
PROVIDED CRITICAL LIFE SAVING
SUPPORT IN RECENT FIRES AND
EARTHQUAKES CURRENTLY AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE FUNDED
THROUGH EMERGENCY MEDICAL AIR
TRANSPORTATION ACT THAT'S E.
MADA THAT FUND IS SET TO EXPIRE
ON. DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. BUT AB SIX
FIFTY ONE WILL EXTEND THE
EXISTING EMERGENCY MEDICAL AIR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING UNTIL
THE NEXT BUDGET CYCLE WHILE THE
AUTHORED TENDS TO FIND A LONG
TERM. FUNDING SOLUTION IN THE
COMING YEAR THIS BILL PROVIDES
AREA NOTES WITH THE SERVICES
THE FUNDING THEY NEED TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THIS
LIFESAVING SERVICES IN THE
INTERIM. THE BILL ALSO
PROHIBITS THE BALLOT BALANCE
BILLING PRACTICES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IBM. ANY DESCRIPTION DEBATE
SENATOR DALLY. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. WHEN YOU
VISIT TO THE FIRST ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT IT'S VERY RULE OPEN AS
MANY YOU'VE BEEN OUT THERE AND.
LET'S IS REALLY YOUR LIFELINE
IF YOU GET INJURED OUT THERE
AND SO WE'VE WORKED ON THIS
GOOD SENATOR FROM NAPA AND I
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
HAVE WORKED ON THIS AND THIS IS
A SHORT TERM FIX IT JUST KEEPS
ON GOING. BUT WE REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT A LONG TERM SOLUTION TO
AREA MOSES IN CALIFORNIA SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. JEANNIE HEARING
NINE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ON THIS SENATOR DODD. DRIVERS
MISS SECTOR WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN. BY. ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS BY BRADFORD I COME A
EURO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD
I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROW BY
HERTZBERG AYE HILL. AYE HUESO.
HI TACO. JACKSON JONES BY LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL HI
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I'M REAL.
I NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG. IRA CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK HI. SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TADO JACKSON I.
PORTANTINO. CENTER MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP CENTER DOT FILE ITEM
FORTY ONE. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACT REALLY IN HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER DOT. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT SENATORS AB
SEVEN FORTY FOUR STRENGTHENS
STRENGTHENS NON DISCRIMINATION
STATUTES IN EXISTING TELEHEALTH
LAW TO ENSURE THAT THE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER IS REIMBURSE FOR
THE SERVICES DELIVERED TO AN
ENROLLEE THREE TELEHEALTH IF
THOSE SAME SERVICES. ARE
COVERED IN PERSON. ALL
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE REGARDLESS OF
THEIR LOCATION AND PROVIDERS
SHOULD BE INCENTIVIZE TO EXPAND
THEIR REACH THIS BILL DOES NOT
EXPAND SERVICES THAT ARE
COVERED IT ONLY ADDRESSES THE
MODALITY USED TO PROVIDE THOSE
COVERED SERVICES. WHETHER
PROVIDERS HE'S A PATIENT IN
PERSON OR THROUGH A VIDEO
CONFERENCE THEY SHOULD BE PAID
FOR THAT WORK. AB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR WERE PARTICULARLY HELP
CALIFORNIANS IN WORLD
COMMUNITIES MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN DISPLACED BY NATURAL
DISASTERS. I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THIS IS NOT JUST OUR WORLD
ISSUE WE ALL HAVE POCKETS IN
OUR DISTRICT WERE ACCESS TO
ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE IS
LIMITED. WE SHOULD BE DOING
WHATEVER WE CAN TO LEVERAGE
INNOVATION AND HEALTH CARE TO
SERVE THOSE POPULATIONS. I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLARS. THE MEASURE
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO RISE
IF YOU HAPPEN TO GET IN THAT
HELICOPTER AND THEN LAND AT ONE
OF OUR HOSPITALS YOU MAY NEED
TELL HEALTH IN THE RULE AREA TO.
GET YOUR SERVICES SO THIS IS
VERY CRITICAL TO RULE AREAS I
KNOW THE GOOD SENATOR FROM THE
NORTH COAST AND I. HAVE A LOT
OF THE PLACES WHERE WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THE TECH THE DOCKS
THERE AND THIS THIS WILL ALLOW
THEM TO BE ABLE TO SERVICE
THOSE CONSTITUENTS OUT THERE
TO. TELEMEDICINE SO I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. IN ADDITION
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR DODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. OKAY WAS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL. BY BURGESS HI BRADFORD
AYE AYE CABALLERO AYE TING AYE
DALY AYE DODD AYE DORADO I
GALGIANI. HI GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO HI
JACKSON. ITUNES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LOCK. RAIL NO
NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH BY RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN BY STONE BY NUMBER FIVE A
CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK BY.
THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. GROWTH
MORE LOCKED. NIELSEN. NIELSEN
AYE PORTANTINO HI. ICE THIRTY
SIX KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES. OKAY. MEMBERS WERE
MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. CENTERS JACKSON
ARE YOU PREPARED. THE PRESIDENT
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN SB ONE EIGHTY TWO TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER ACTION.
DOES WILL KNOW. ANY ADDITIONAL
ITEMS UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. HEARING TO NONE
WERE MOVING BACK TO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENCE WERE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THREE CENTER WINNER ARE
YOU PREPARED. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE YOU BREED DYED SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
WINNER AND ACTUALLY NEW
ELECTIONS WINNER. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT HOW
COLLEAGUES SB TO SIXTY EIGHT IS
A BILL TO ENSURE THAT WHEN
PARCEL TAXES IN BONDS FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES GO TO
THE VOTERS THAT THE VOTERS HAVE
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT THOSE BALLOT
MEASURES UNDER LEGISLATION
PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO. THE
REQUIREMENT IS THAT IN THE
SEVENTY FIVE WORD BALLOT
QUESTION BY GOVERNMENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO PUT QUORUM COURT
HOW MUCH PEOPLE WILL PAY THE
PROBLEM IS THAT FOUR TIERED
PARCEL TAXES IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
FIT THAT INFORMATION WITHIN
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS AND FOR
BONDS IT'S COMPLETELY
SPECULATIVE BECAUSE YOU DO NOT
KNOW HOW MUCH PEOPLE WILL PAY
UNTIL YOU ACTUALLY SELL THE
BOND AT A PARTICULAR INTEREST
RATE WHICH IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
PREDICT AT THE TIME THE VOTERS
ARE VOTING. ON THE MEASURE. HI
SIR SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT WILL
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. BY MOVING
THAT INFORMATION A REQUIRE EVEN
MORE INFORMATION THAN CURRENTLY
REQUIRED AND VOTER GUIDE. AND
BY REQUIRING A PARENTHETICAL
WITHIN THE SEVENTY FIVE WORD
BALLOT QUESTION THAT WILL STATE
QUOTE SEE VOTER GUIDE FOR TAX
RATE INFORMATION THE VOTERS
WILL BE REFERRED TO THE VOTER
GUIDE IT WILL BE CLEAR THAT
IT'S A TAX. BY AND THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO GET ALL THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED AND WE WILL BE ABLE
TO HAVE COMPREHENSIBLE SEVENTY
FIVE WORD BALLOT QUESTIONS AND
CITIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COUNTIES WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE. PROGRESSIVE
TIERED PARCEL TAXES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FOR THE
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THIS ITEM.
MISS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. NOBEL I
PORGES HI BRADFORD. I CAMBIADO
I TING. NO DALY NO DODD. I
DORADO JOHNNY NO GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO HI TITLE.
JACKSON JONES. NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MOORLACH NUMBER
RAIL. NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER HI MY COUNTY WINNER HI
WILK. NO THIS IS MISS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GLAZER TADO. JACKSON BY ROTH.
GORGEOUS I DON'T KNOW. PRICE
TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TWELVE THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE
CONCURRED AND NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO A FILE ITEM FOR CENTER ON
BURKE I SEE HE'S READY MISTER
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL SIX NINETY SIX WITH
SENATOR UMBERG ENACT REALLY
INTO ELECTIONS AND DECLARED
THROUGHOUT THE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY ON BURKE. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES OF
THE- MOST RAPIDLY GROWING
SEGMENT OF THE VOTER POPULATION
TERMS OF REGISTRATION IS NO
PARTY PREFERENCEUNFORTUNATELY
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
CONFUSION IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE THE ONLY STATE THAT THAT
ACTUALLY PERMITS THIS ON THE
CONFUSION EXISTS BECAUSE ONE OF
THE PARTIES THAT ONE CAN
REGISTER FOR IS CALLED THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY. A
GREAT NUMBER OF FOLKS AS WAS
ILLUSTRATED IN VARIOUS POLLS
WHO REGISTER AS AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY MEMBERS
ACTUALLY THINK THE REGISTERING
AS INDEPENDENCE OR WHAT IS NOW
TERMED AS NO PARTY PREFERENCE
THAT IS NOT THE CASE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF REGISTERING IS
AN AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
MEMBER WHEN YOU THINK YOU'RE
REGISTERING AS AN ACTUAL
INDEPENDENT. ONE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES YOU CAN'T VOTE SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
FOR PRESIDENT WITH THIS BILL
DOES IS SIMPLY SAYS THAT YOU
CAN'T HAVE A PARTY THAT HAS THE
WORD INDEPENDENT OR DECLINE TO
STATE OR NO PARTY PREFERENCE OR
VARIATION OF THOSE WORDS IN THE
DESIGNATION. IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO
REGISTER AS INDEPENDENCE THAT
THEY REGISTER AS EIGHT AND ARE
NO PARTY PREFERENCE PERSON YOU
CAN'T CREATE MISLEADING TITLES
THAT. ARE FOR EXAMPLE CONNECTED
THE DEMOCRATIC OR REPUBLICAN
PARTY YOU COULDN'T SAY YOU'RE
AN AMERICAN DEMOCRATIC PARTY
MEMBER OR A REPUBLICAN AMERICAN
PARTY MEMBER BECAUSE THAT WOULD
<c.green>E CONFUSING HELLO THIS BILL</c>
DOES IS IT SIMPLY SAYS THAT YOU
MAY NOT USE THE WORD
INDEPENDENT DECLINE TO STATE OR
NO PARTY PREFERENCE IN THE
TITLE. OF A- LOCAL PARTY
TONIGHT. SURGERY PREPARE ON THE
YEAH YEAH VERY MUCH SHOULD JUST
pBEFORE US SENATE ROMBERG IT YOU
KNOW IN IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES TO THE
STUDY. THE STORY WHERE THEY
FOUND THAT. 73% OF THE PEOPLE
WHO SIGNED UP FOR THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY ON MISTAKENLY
THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE BEING ON
AFFILIATED GOES TO THE POINT.
THAT WAS MADE IN THE
PRESENTATION ABOUT THE
CONFUSION AND THE ONLY POINT I
WANT TO ADD IS. YOU DON'T. FISH
RIGHT TO VOTE. ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING AROUND
VOTING. TO ENHANCE IT TO MAKE
IT EASIER TO GIVE PEOPLE
OPTIONS TO PARTICIPATE IN
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO. NOTHING
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN MAKING
SURE THERE'S NO CONFUSION IN
THE PROCESS AND WHEN YOU HAVE
73% OF THE PEOPLE. WHO ACTUALLY
THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE A PART
PART OF A NOTE NO PARTY
PREFERENCE WHEN IN FACT THIS
PARTY IS THE PARTY THAT NOMINEE
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WAS
GEORGE WALLACE. I DON'T MAKE
THAT FOR A STATEMENT ABOUT
WHETHER ON ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER I JUST MAKE IT FOR A
STATEMENT THAT I SUSPECTED
PEOPLE KNEW THAT. AND KNEW WHAT
THE POLITICAL PHILOSOPHY OF
THAT PARTY WAS THAT USED THE
WORD INDEPENDENT. THAT THERE
WAS CLEAR CONFUSION I WAS
SUPPORTED BY THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES LAST YEAR I VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL SIX
NINE SIX AND. I WROTE IT THIS
MORNING BEFORE FASHION STARTED.
BUT I SEE SB SIX NINE SIX AS A
BLATANTLY OPPRESSIVE AND
TYRANNICAL MANEUVER. BUT WHAT'S
NEW. ABOUT STRONG ARMING IN
THIS CHAMBER CALL EXIST
LEGISLATURE HAS GONE AFTER ONE
POSITIONS WHO ARE TRYING TO
PROTECT INFANTS AGAINST
VACCINES THEY MAY BE SEVERELY
ALLERGIC TO THOSE WHO HUNT
BOBCATS THREE SPIRITUAL
COUNSELORS WHO ARE PERCEIVED TO
BE ADDRESSING THE TOPIC OF
CONVERSION THERAPY FOR THE FOR
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA FIVE THE
GIG ECONOMY I'LL STOP THERE. IT
ONLY MAKES SENSE TO GO AFTER.
AN ENTIRE POLITICAL PARTY NOW I
NOT WE'RE HAVING SUCH A GOOD
ROLE THIS YEAR. THIS
LEGISLATURE IS BOLD IN ITS
BULLYING GO BOULDER GLOBAL GO
HOME I GUESS BUT THIS BUT THIS
IS CENTER MARK WE'RE GONNA
SHOES SPEAK TO THE MERITS OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT DO A GREAT JOB. THE
DEFINITION OF BALI IS TO SEEK
TO HARM INTIMIDATE OR COERCE
SOMEONE PERCEIVED AS VULNERABLE.
CAN DECIMATE THE A. I. P.'S
NAME BECAUSE CAN BUT THE OPTICS
MAC THE POLITICAL BULLYING. AND
WE MAKE LAWS TO STOP BULLYING.
HOW IRONIC. INSTEAD OF
ENCOURAGING CITIZENS TO DO A
LITTLE RESEARCH TAKE A CIVICS
TUTORIAL ANYTHING TO PREVENT
THEM FROM EMBARRASSING
THEMSELVES SACRAMENTO TAKES
AWAY THE POTENTIAL BECAUSE OF
SOMEONE'S LOOKING INEPT. THE
ART OF WHICH WE'RE ASKING TO
SPEAK TO THE MERITS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT ONE
OF OUR MISTER PRESIDENT. BY
WORKPLACE SOONER JONES. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MAKE YOUR
POINT ANOTHER POINT IS I
UNDERSTOOD THAT THERE WAS A
POINT OF ORDER ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE CHAMBERS I'M NOT
SURE THAT THE POINT OF ORDER
WAS RECOGNIZED. AND IF THE
PERSON MAKING THE POINT OF
ORDER WOULD LIKE TO RISE AND
GIVE THEIR POINT OF ORDER I
THINK THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
FOR THE CHAMBER. CENTER JACQUI
SMITH BELOW IS A POINT OF ORDER
THIS IS NOT YOUR MAIN TO THE
ESSENCE OF THE BILL WE HAD A
DISCUSSION EARLIER THIS MORNING
ABOUT FLAME THROWING
RESPECTFULLY FROM THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE MINORITY
LEADER WELLS WELL TAKEN AND IT
HAS TO BE APPLIED BY BOTH SIDES
I AM OBJECTING IS A POINT OF
ORDER THAT THE DISCUSSION NOW
IS FLAME THROWING AGAINST THE
PARTY IN POWER IT IS NOT ABOUT
THE ISSUE IN THE BILL ENTRY.
BEFORE US TODAY AND IT'S THAT
BASIS UPON WHICH I AM
PROJECTION
. THANK YOU. THE
POINT OF ORDER IS WELL TAKEN
AND WE'RE STILL GONNA SHOULD
REMAIN TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
BILL. PRESIDENT I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE. DISTURBANCE THAT I'VE
CAUSED I DID NOT MEAN TO DO
THAT I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
POINT OF CONCLUDE BY SAYING
THAT THE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT
PARTY. HAS BEEN AROUND LONGER
THAN MANY OF US HAVE BEEN ALIVE.
I THINK IT'S A STRANGE TACTIC
MISTER PRESIDENT I THINK IT'S A
SHAME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM YES. YES. CONSIDER BORDERS
I CONCEDE SO YOU MIGHT THINK IT
WAS PRESIDENT. I HAVE TO ADMIT.
WHEN I LOOK AT PARTY
DESIGNATIONS I GET CONFUSED.
WHEN I SEE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT
ARE THE INDEPENDENT IS IT SOME
OTHER ORGANIZATION THE LOT OF
THESE THINGS ARE MISLEADING AND
WE HAD AN ISSUE NOT THAT LONG
AGO ON. HOW DO WE PROTECT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS WELL
STILL PRESERVING OUR- OUR OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS OR OR THE
INTEGRITY OF THE VOTING
PROCESS. IT SEEMS LIKE WE TRIED
TO NEARLY TAILOR OUR SOLUTIONS.
BUT THIS ONE SEEMS TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
MISSED. WOULD IT NOT HAVE BEEN.
MORE HELPFUL TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR PROCESS BY
REQUESTING OR EVEN MANDATING
FOR THAT MATTER I DISCLOSURE ON
ANY FORMS THAT SAYS THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY IS.
A PARTY THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY IDENTIFY ITSELF AS
INDEPENDENT OR SOME VARIATION
THEREOF THAT INFORMS THE PUBLIC
THAT THE TITLE THE READING MAY
NOT BE IS AS ACCURATE AS THE
LABEL THAT THEY'RE INTERPRETING.
SO WHAT I'M WHAT I'M GETTING AT
WITH ALL OF THIS IS THAT THERE
IS A SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM
BUT THE BILL HERE. I DON'T
THINK IT IS IT IS SATISFACTORY
SO I GUESS I'M ALL ALLEN HERE
THAT THIS IS IT THIS COULD BE
THE RIGHT STEP FORWARD BUT IT'S
NOT DRAFTED. APPROPRIATELY MY
OPINION. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL SCRIPT SENATOR BATES.
LOW MILEAGE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. SENATOR BOB HERTZBERG
WOULD YOU TAKE THE QUESTION I'M
CERTAIN WILL BE THE HIGH POINT
OF MY DAY YES. SURVEYS AND
MESSY BECAUSE A GOOD SENATOR
FROM LAGUNA MIGUEL IS ASKING IT
RIGHT. ANYWAY I AM I'M CURIOUS
AS TO WHETHER THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY AS A
DESIGNATION OF A PARTY EXIST
ACROSS THE NATION OR JUST IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
JUST IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
JUST FROM THE THANK YOU THAT
WAS MY QUESTION. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITION DISCUSSIONS DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. NINETEEN NINE CENTER
ON BURKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISS PRESENT
AND TO FURTHER RESPOND TO MY
GOOD FRIEND THE SENATOR FROM
LAGUNA MIGUEL. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY TERMS OF A
PARTY DESIGNATION THIS THIS
BILL IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY IN FACT
I THINK IS 20% THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS ACTUALLY VOTED FOR IT.
IT IS ENDORSED AND SUPPORTED BY
THE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
IN IT GOES TO OUR INTERESTS OUR
COLLECTIVE INTERESTS AND IN
ENSURING THAT THAT VOTERS
AREN'T MISLED. WHEN YOU GO TO
THE DMV AND YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE A PARTY
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
STARTS IS THE FIRST PARTY. OF
USING YOUR INDEPENDENT. CAN YOU
CHECK AMERICAN INDEPENDENT
PARTY AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE SEEN
AT LEAST I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
SEE IN. ITS GROWTH BEING SO
DRAMATIC IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
IF THE PARTY WHICH IS TO BE THE
AMERICAN PARTY THEY MAY DO SO.
IF THEY WISH TO BE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PARTY WHICH IS
SORT OF THEIR DERIVATION OTHER
STATES THEY MAY DO SO BUT WHAT
THEY CAN'T DO IS THEY CAN'T
CONFUSE VOTERS. BY CHOOSING A
NAME THAT MANY PEOPLE ASSOCIATE
WITH BEING INDEPENDENT WHEN IN
FACT THEY ARE NOT. HERE TONIGHT
VOTE. THANK YOU AUGUST BAIT
INSCRIPTION HAVING SEASON
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA BY ATKINS AYE
BATES. NOBEL HI BURGESS NO
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO. I CHIANG
NO DALY NO DODD I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO I JACKSON AYE JONES NO
LEYVA. I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL.
HI MONNING. I'M MORE LUCK
NUMBER RAIL NO NIELSEN NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NO BURKE CASKEY BY
WIENER AYE WILK. NO SOONER
UMBERG MOVES A CALL NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM FIVE CENTER LEYVA ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM SHE
IS MISTER SECRETARY YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL TWO TEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT RELATING
TO BE COOLER AIR POLLUTION
CENTER LEYVA THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS SB TWO TENNIS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOVE THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AMONG
OTHERS SPECIFICALLY AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN TO. REMOVE DUPLICATE
DUPLICATIVE TESTING REGULATIONS.
CAP THE PROGRAM BE AT THIRTY
SORRY A LITTLE COLD. ENSURE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TOOLS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
PROVIDE REASONABLE PATHWAYS FOR
INDUSTRY COMPLIANCE WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH CTA THE AG
COMMUNITY AIR QUALITY OF THE
KIDS TO HELP INSURE COMPLIANCE
WHILE IMPROVING THE STATE'S AIR
QUALITY. I WANT TO THANK BOTH
HOUSES FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD
WORK OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS
TO MAKE SB TWO TEN A BALANCED
MAJOR THAN IMPROVES PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PROVIDES CLEAN AIR
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SOONER DALLY.
THE MEASURE PRESENT MEMBERS I
HAVE TO RISE IN OPPOSITION AND
I DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE THE
HEARING YESTERDAY ON THIS BILL
AND AS YOU KNOW I AM IN THE
TRUCKING BUSINESS AND WANTED
JUST SHARE I KNOW THIS BILL'S
GOING TO GET OUT BUT I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU WHAT IT'S GOING
TO HOW IT'S GOING TO IMPACT.
THE SMALL OWNER OPERATOR IN
INTO IN YUP THE LITTLE GUY AND
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN REALLY
AFFECTED BY AB FIVE IN IN
RECENT LEGISLATION AS WELL. THE
REASON THAT THE CDA IS OFF IS
BECAUSE- THE BILL STATES THAT
IF YOU HAVE A BRAND NEW VEHICLE
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE. YOUR
SMOG CHECK EVERY TWO YEARS YOU
GET A FOR YOUR PASS. MOST YOUR
LARGE TRUCKING COMPANIES. BIG
BUSINESS. LEAST TRUCKS ANY
LEESON FOR FOUR YEARS BUT-
THREE OR FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
MILES ON THEM AND THEN THEY
TURN AT LEAST IN. AND THEY THEN
ARE SOLD TYPICALLY DO GUYS LIKE
ME WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY A
NEW ONE. EVEN A USED TRUCK CAN
BE ROUND WITH THE LAST ONE I
PURCHASED WAS ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY IF YOUR CHECK
ENGINE LIGHT COMES ON. YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GO GET THAT THAT
YOU HAVE SEVENTY FIVE DAYS FOR
ACT TO GO GET IT CHECKED BUT I
WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
THERE ARE LIKE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SENSORS. ON THESE TRUCKS.
NOW ON THE MOST RECENT TRUCK
THAT I. HAVE PURCHASED. I'VE
HAD IT TO THE SHOP SEVERAL
TIMES BECAUSE I'VE HAD A CHECK
ENGINE LIGHT ON. IN THE TRUCK
SEEM TO BE PERFORMING WELL. BUT
IT'S THE SENSOR ITSELF THAT
GOES OUT. FROM SIX HUNDRED TO A
THOUSAND DOLLARS IS THE BILL
EVERY TIME I HAVE TO GO IN AND
HAVE THAT CHECKED OUT. NOW THE
TRUCK I USED TO OWN THE OLDER
TRUCKS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
WORK ON OURSELVES AND RUN FOR
YEARS WITHOUT TAKING THEM TO
THE DEALERS. DID NOT HAVE AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS WE HAVE TODAY
OBVIOUSLY. BUT THE TECHNOLOGY
NOW IT'S CHANGED. BECAUSE THAT
TECHNOLOGIES CHANGED WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
WORK ON OUR- VEHICLES AS YOU
DON'T YOUR OWN CARS. AND SO THE
DEALERS ARE ALL FOR THIS
BECAUSE WHAT DOES IT DO IT IT
REQUIRES YOU TO GO IN AND MANY
OF YOU PROBABLY HAVE NOTICED
THAT. IF YOU HAVE A CAR THAT
HOUSE THE SENSORS THAT TELL YOU
HOW MUCH AIR IS IN THE IN THE
TIRES IT COMES ON YOUR- DASH
AND YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT INTO
THE TIRE SHOP. AND MANY TIMES
IT MAY BE JUST A COLD MORNING
BECAUSE IT CAN DEBTS ARE A HOT
DAY WHERE YOU'RE TRAVELING OR
THE SENSOR GOES OUT. THEY'RE
REQUIRED BY LAW TO NOT LEAVE
THAT THAT VEHICLE LEAVE WITHOUT
THOSE CHECK ENGINE LIGHTS ALL.
WHICH DRIVES ACOSTA FOR
EVERYBODY EVEN THOUGH IT'S JUST
SIMPLY A SENSOR THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG SAFETY WISE YOU CAN TAKE
A GAUGE AND CHECK YOUR TIRE AND
MANY TIMES ON THE TRUCKS. THE
SENSOR IS THE PROBLEM ITSELF
IT'S NOT THE PROBLEM WITH THE
TRUCK SO THIS IS GOING TO
IMPACT. SMALL OPERATORS MORE
THAN IT IS THE BIG OPERATORS
AND IT'S KIND OF OBVIOUS THE-
PROMOTE MORE CELLS OF TRUCKS
AND THAT'S WHY THE DEALERS AND
THOSE GUYS ARE HAPPY ABOUT IT
BUT THEY IT'S GOING TO DRIVE
THE COST UP OF TRANSPORTATION
COSTS IN CALIFORNIA. UP IN
THERE IS IN A MINUTE IN THE
BILL TO THE WHICH I THINK IS A
GOOD PART OF THE BILL WHICH I
WILL SAY IS THAT IT REQUIRES
pWITH CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH WILL
HELP US BE A LITTLE MORE
COMPARED BUT THE END OF THE
DAY. THE SMALL GUYS GOING TO
GET HURT AND IT'S GOING TO
DRIVE THE COST UP OF LIVING IN
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
OF THIS PIECE ELECTION SO I
URGE. NO VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY S.
SENATOR GIRL. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT A QUESTION THE AUTHOR
YES TURNER WHICH TO QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY I REALIZE THAT THERE
IS AN EXEMPTION IN THE BILL ARE
AT THERE IS A AN INCLUSION IN
THE BILL FOR OUT OF STATE
TRUCKERS AN OUT OF STATE
VEHICLES THAT COME FROM ACROSS
STATE LINES IS THERE A ALSO AN
INCLUSION FOR OUT OF COUNTRY
VEHICLES. DO YOU HAVE TO HAVE
AN OPERATION YOU HAVE TO HELP
GO THROUGH A SMOG CHECK. IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE AN OPERATING
PERMIT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT WOULD PLAY
APPLY TO ANY TRUCK FROM
ANYWHERE BEING DRIVEN IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA SO IF YOU CAN'T
YOUR FOR TRUCK. WHETHER FROM
OUT OF COUNTRY WHETHER IT'S
FROM OUT OF STATE. CANNOT PASS
A SMOG CHECK YOU WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO REGISTER IN CALIFORNIA
AND OBTAIN AN- OPERATOR'S
PERMIT. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT ON MY OWN TIME. WE PASS
LEGISLATION IN THIS BUILDING
OVER THE FAST PAST TEN YEARS
AND IT IT DEALS WITH THEM YOU
KNOW PEOPLE'S FREEDOM LIKE THE
PEOPLE IN THE BALCONY AND ALSO
PEOPLE'S FREEDOM TO OPERATE A
BUSINESS ENTERING AND DO WHEN
YOU. WHEN YOU OPERATE A
BUSINESS AND YOU HAVE
LEGISLATION THAT COMES THROUGH
JUST LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA SAID
FROM BEAVER. WE GO FROM
CULTURAL LOW CARBON FUELS WE GO
FROM LOW CARBON FEELS ULTRA LOW
COVERED FEELS TO ALTER ALTER TO
NON EXISTENT TO NOW EMISSIONS
AND THE TURNOVER RATES FOR
THESE THESE THE EXPENSE AND THE
TURNOVER RATES FOR THESE PIECES
OF EQUIPMENT FOR BUSINESS TO
OPERATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMING. AND SO HAVING
THAT IN MIND AND THAT'S THE WAY
THAT BUSINESSES ARE NOW
STRUGGLING WITH MAKING SURE
THAT THEY COMPLY WITH THE
CURRENT RULES UNDER THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IN THE
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY'VE ALREADY
BOUGHT IT IS NOT YET OUT OF
COMPLIANCE. I WOULD URGE A NO
VOTE. CENTER HER TITLE. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT YOU KNOW I
WANT TO START OFF BY. SPEAKING
A LITTLE BIT OF TRUTH AND I
KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CHINO KNOWS THIS VERY WALL THAT
I'VE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
RELUCTANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL. BECAUSE THE DISTRICT
HAS YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE JUST
THEY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL. REGULATION AND ONE
NOT RIGHT BUT- I ULTIMATELY
DECIDED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO. AND IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO FOR MY DISTRICT MOBILE
SOURCE POLLUTION IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST CONTRIBUTORS TO AIR. IN
THE SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND IT'S A TOUGH VOTE FOR ME
BUT IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
I AM PLEASED TO SEE THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT WORD THAT
ADDRESS MANY OF THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS. AND THIS
BILL I THINK STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE AND RECOGNIZES THE
CENTRAL ROLE THAT HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS PLAY IN MY DISTRICT
WHILE ALSO REDUCING EMISSIONS.
OF HARMFUL POLLUTANTS FROM
MOBILE SOURCES. AND WITHOUT
COLLEAGUES I URGE YOU TO VOTE
I. ON SB TWO SIXTY. Q. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. CENA MORE
MICROPHONES SENATOR LABOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND THANK YOU
TO THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAYING
I APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS IT
MAY BE A TOUGH BLOW FOR HER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BUT WHAT
I'D LIKE TO SAY MEMBERS IF THIS
IS OUR THIRD YEAR WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS WITH EVERYONE
INVOLVED WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT A GOOD NEGOTIATION IS
A GOOD NEGOTIATIONS WHEN
EVERYBODY WALKS AWAY A LITTLE
BIT HAPPY A LITTLE BIT UNHAPPY
AND THAT'S THE BALANCE THAT WE
HAVE ACHIEVED HERE. ALL THESE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT SO WAS
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AND THAT'S
WHY WE TOOK EVERY SINGLE
AMENDMENT THAT AG ASKED US TO
TAKE. EXCEPT FOR ONE AND THAT
WILL GO TO THE H. Q. EMPTY FOR
MOBILE SOURCING TO MAKE SURE
AND THEY HAVE COMMITTED THE RB
HAS COME A QB HAS COMMITTED. TO
DOING MBILE SOURCE TESTING SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DRIVE A
HUNDRED OR TWO HUNDRED MILES.
TO GET YOUR VEHICLETESTED. I
THINK THIS IS A BILL THAT DOES
WHAT WE ALL WANT TO DO HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT WHAT
WE ALL WANT TO DO HERE ON THIS
FLOOR. THAT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT
BUSINESSES CAN STILL OPERATE.
AND BE PROFITABLE BUT WE ALSO
STILL HAVE CLEAN AIR TO BREATHE
YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK ABOUT WHEN
I WAS A LITTLE GIRL. IN THE
SEVENTIES AND YOU COULDN'T SEE
THE MOUNTAINS. AND THINGS HAVE
GOTTEN BETTER THE SKIES ARE
BLUE OR BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE PARTICULATES ARE SMALLER.
AND WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO WE
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE THIS BILL OVER TEN YEARS
WILL BE THE EQUIVALENT OF
TAKING THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND. IG
DIESEL TRUCKS THE WORKS
POLLUTERS. OFF OF THE STREET. I
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEES MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
NOBEL I PURCHASE NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD. I DORADO. I GALGIANI.
GLAZER I GONZALEZ HI GROW NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
TADO I JACKSON AYE JONES. LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL BY
MONEY. I'M MORE LARK NO MERRELL.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH BY RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE NO
BURKE OUR CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK NO LEYVA MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM SIX MY SENATOR HILL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE.
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY BY
SENATOR HILL AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC UTILITIES THROUGH HILL
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SB
FIVE FIFTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
IN THE ASSEMBLY ADD A FINANCIAL
THRESHOLD TO CPUC
CONSIDERATIONS OF SAFETY
STANDARDS AND INCORPORATE THE
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS
REGARDING CPUC REVIEW.
NEGOTIATED AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR EARLIER THIS
YEAR THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT TO
THE ASSEMBLY OF MEN. ANY
FURTHER DESCRIPTION OF IT ON
THE SIDE OF. THE NON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES HI BILL HI PORGES. HI
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO. CHIANG BY
DAILY. DODD ON SIDE ALSO. I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
HI GROW. HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE
HUESO AYE TADO AYE JACKSON AYE
JONES BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK I'M REAL NO. NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. BY SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE. HI AMBERG. POWER CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK HI. THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL YOUR UP TO
MEMBERS ALLEN. CABALLERO. HI
DOLLY I GROWTH HI. CEDAR HILL
MOVES THE CALL. NEXT UP MEMBERS
IS FILE ITEM SEVEN SENATOR
GLAZERS ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT ITEM HE IS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX ON I'M A SENATOR
GLAZER AND AQUINNAH PROFESSIONS
AND VOCATIONS DINNER DOLLARS
ARE THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS THE SUNSET
HILL FOR THE BUREAU OF SECURITY
AND INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY DID A VARIETY OF
THINGS WANTED INCREASES THE
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR FEES IN
ACCORDANCE WITH AN EXTERNAL
AUDIT AND AT THE REQUEST THE
BUREAU WITHOUT THE PROPOSED FEE
INCREASE THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATIVE ACCOUNT IS
PROJECTED TO BECOME INSOLVENT.
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR. DISPLAY
THE MEASURE MERGES THE. TO FIND
AND THE PRIVATE SECURITY
SERVICES FUND. IT ALIGNS THE
BUREAU STATUTES WITH THE PENAL
CODE. AND EXPERIENCE OTHER
CHANGES STEMMING FROM THE
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
CONDUCTED BY. OUR ART. OUR
AGENCY THERE'S NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER. ANY FOR THE
DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THIS ITEM.
THREE NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL I FIVE LARGEST BRADFORD I
CABALLERO BY CHIANG I DALY DODD
HI DORADO HI GALGIANI HI GLAZER
I GONZALEZ BY GROW BY HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO
AYE JACKSON AYE JONES I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MOORLACH AYE
MORRELL AYE NIELSEN. AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE. I AM BURKE OUR CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK HI. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN BATES HI. GORGEOUS DALY.
CENTER GLAZER MOVES A CALL NEXT
REMOVING TO THREE BUDGET ITEM
SENATOR MATURE YOU'RE PREPARED
WE HAVE ITEMS EIGHT. NINE AND
TEN. FIRST UP AUTOMATE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL ONE ON NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
BUDGET MAKING PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUT YOUR BILL
SOONER BUT AS CINEMA DRUM SIR
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB ONE OR NOT AS THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AND CONTAINS
TECHNICAL AND SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS TO THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT. THE BILL
DOES THE FOLLOWING IT INCLUDES
MULTIPLE ITEMS THAT WERE PART
OF THE JUNE BUDGET AGREEMENT
INCLUDING APPROPRIATING TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A GRANT TO
THE COUNTY OF STANISLAUS
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS
EQUIPMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
APPROPRIATING TEN MILLION TO
THE CITY OF PALM SPRINGS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS RELATED
NEEDS ADELINE FUNDING FOR CHILD
CARE PROGRAM SO PROPERLY
REFLECT ALLOWABLE FEDERAL FUND
USES IN ADDITION THIS BILL
INCLUDES ITEMS THAT WERE
INADVERTENTLY LEFT OUT OF THE
GYM BUDGET OR THAT ADDRESS
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAVE ARISEN
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE JUNE
BUDGET. SUCH AS APPROPRIATING
TEN MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CENTER GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDING TO ENGINE SIX POINT
ONE MILLION FOR THE SALTON SEA
SPECIES CONSERVATION HABITAT
PROJECT APPROPRIATE FOURTEEN
POINT NINE MILLION FOR OVERTIME
COSTS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE. PROTECTION.
THE BILL MAKES THIS TECHNICAL
NON SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS TO
THE TWENTY NINETY BUDGET ACT.
ANY DESCRIPTION OF EIGHT ON
THIS ITEM HEARING AND SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS AYE BATES NO BILL I
BRIDGES NO BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO I CHIANG. NO DALY NO
DA. HI DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROW. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TADO I JACKSON BY JONES
NO LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
HI MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER. HI IRA CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK MR OTHER PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN LEYVA.
HI STONE. YES SIR MR MOVES CALL
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM NINE.
MISTER TERRY PLEASE ROUTE.
SENATE BILL ONE TWELVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUT IN FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACTING STATE
GOVERNMENT AND MAKING PROGRESS
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED BUT.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
THIS IS. THE LAST BILL WE JUST
IT WAS A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR WE
ARE NOW MOVING INTO. SOME OF
THE FINAL TRAILER BILL FOR THIS
YEAR THIS IS SENATE BILL ONE
TWELVE WHICH IS THE GENERAL
GOVERNMENT CLEAN UP TRAILER
BILL. IT RESTORES THE TO
GENERAL'S AUTHORITY TO INITIATE
AN AUDIT OR REVIEW POLICIES
PRACTICES AND PROCEDURES OF THE
APARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. AND PROVIDES
AUTHORITY TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO PROVIDE.
CONTEMPORANEA OVERSIGHT TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S REVISED PROCESS
FOR HANLEY IN MAKE COMPLAINTS
PRISON EMPLOYEE MISCONDUCT. IT
APPROPRIATE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION ON GOING TO THE OFFICE
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. IT
CLARIFIES EXISTING STATE LAW
WITH RESPECT TO THE EMPLOYMENT
VERIFICATION PROCESS
ADMINISTERED BY EMPLOYEES
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL LAW. IT
UPDATES THE NOISE TESTING
STANDARDS FOR VEHICLE EXHAUST
SYSTEMS AND MODIFIES EXISTING
LAW TO ALLOW AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS ARRESTED OR CITED FOR A
VIOLATION OF THOSE STANDARDS.
THE FIX THE VIOLATION AND
PROVIDE PROOF OF CORRECTION
INSTEAD OF FACING OTHER
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS MAKES A
VARIETY OF OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THE
SITE ON HIM TO NONE THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. NO BILL HI BURGESS NO
BRADFORD I CALVET HERO HI JANE%
NO DALY NO DODD HI DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW NO HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TADO HI
JACKSON. I JONES NO LEYVA. I AM
A CHOIR HI MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
HI. ROTH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER.
OUR CASKEY I WINNER BY WILK NO.
OUR EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES FINAL
BUDGET ITEM IS FILE ITEM TEN.
SOONER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AND ECHOING HOUSING AND
MAKE IN PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED BUDGET SENATE MITCHELL
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTEEN IS THE
HOUSING TRAILER BILL AND
CONTAINS STATUTORY CHANGES
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT. IT
STAYS THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO
ESTABLISH A TRUST THE MANAGE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
MILLION IN STATE FUNDS THAT ARE
COURT ORDER TO PROVIDE BORROWER
RELIEF AND LEGAL AID TO
HOMEOWNERS OR RENTERS AND
PROVIDES FOR THE TRANSFER OF
THE REQUIRED FUNDS IT CLARIFIES
THE APPLICATION OF CERTAIN
JUDICIAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
REMEDIES FOR NON COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE HOUSING ELEMENT. IT
ALLOWS THE COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENT THAT RECEIVE
PLANNING FUNDS PROVIDED THE
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT TO SPEND UP
225% OF THEIR PHONES PREPARE
FOR PLANNING ACTIVITIES
REQUIRED IN THE UPCOMING SIX
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT CYCLE AND MAKES A
VARIETY OF TECHNICAL AND
CONFORMING CHANGES. WE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
GROW ON THE SIDE OF. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR MAJORITY TO QUESTION
OF COURSE. THANK YOU HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE FOR FUNDING FROM
THE STRESS TO ACTUALLY GET IN
THE HANDS OF HOMEOWNERS TO HELP
THEM. WELL I DON'T KNOW
OFFHAND. IF YOU NEEDED BEFORE
WE TAKE A VOTE I'D BE HAPPY TO
CHECK WITH STAFF AND FIND OUT.
THAT BE GREAT. MY UNDERSTANDING
IT'S GOING TO GO INTO A TRUST
IS GOING TO BE GOVERNED BY
THERE'D BE INTO THE STOCK
MARKET OF THE STOCK MARKET
CRASHES. AND SOMETHING HAPPENS
TO THIS FUNDING STREAM WE ARE
WE GET PREPARED TO HAVE THE
GENERAL FUND REPLACES THREE IN
A THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS ORIGINALLY STOLEN. FROM THE
TAXPAYERS. CENTER CENTER METERS
CHECKING ON YOUR FIRST QUESTION
SO SHE'S LIKE FRANKIE MISTER
PRESIDENT. WE HAVE
. FIND
EVERYONE ABOUT THE CIRCUMSTANCE
OF MY COLLEAGUE REFERENCED TO
TAXPAYER DOLLARS BEING STOLEN
THERE WAS A COURT ORDER THAT
DECLARED THE LEGISLATURE NEEDED
TO SET UP THE TRUST THAT'S WHAT
THE TRAILER BILL DOES TO
ESTABLISH THE TRUST IN JANUARY
HOPEFULLY THROUGH ANOTHER
BUDGET ACTION SO WOULD TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY ANOTHER
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WOULD HAVE
TO BE INTRODUCED ON THAT THEN
WOULD ALLOW THE DISBURSEMENT OF
THE OF THE FUNDS SO THIS
TRAILER BILL. ESTABLISHES THE.
PRESS FUN ANOTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED. TO ACTUALLY
DISPERSE THE FUNDS. AT SO I
CAN'T ANSWER YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTION ABOUT HOW LONG IT
WOULD TAKE BUT THAT'S THE TIME
FRAME THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
THANK YOU ON MY OWN TIME. I
THINK THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
PRESENTED IS INCORRECT THE
ORDER DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ESTABLISH A
TRUST THE ORDER REQUIRES THE
THREE NINE THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO BE RETURNED TO THE
HOMEOWNERS. AND SENATE
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR THIS RETURN OF
THESE FUNDS WERE STRUCK FOR
STRUGGLING HOMEOWNERS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN WE'VE
HEARD STORIES OF HOMEOWNERS
THAT ARE STILL WAITING
DESPERATELY FOR THESE FUNDS
THAT WERE PROMISED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
BUDGETS MONEY WAS TAKEN FROM
THESE HOLDOVERS AND PUT IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE BUDGET
BUT THE MAJORITY PARTY. THIS
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS THEN WENT
TO OUR THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
FILE A LAWSUIT THIS IS
BACKGROUND ON THIS AND SHE
REFUSED TO FOLLOW LAWSUIT OR
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
RETURN THESE THREE OR THIRTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. SO WE
STOOD BESIDE WE AS REPUBLICANS
THE NATIONAL ASIAN COALITION
AMERICAN COALITION AND THE
NATIONAL DIVERSITY COALITION IN
THEIR ADMIRABLE FIGHT TO GET
THESE FRIENDS RETURNED THE
RECENTLY MORE GOT A COURT
JUDGMENT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT THIS IS THIS
THREE NINE THIRTY WIN ONE
MILLION DOLLARS WAS TENDED ONLY
TO HELP HOMEOWNERS HOMEOWNERS
AND SHOULD BE RETURNED. FOR
PEOPLE THAT WERE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF DURING MORTGAGE
AND FORECLOSURE CRISIS THIS
BILL RIGHT HERE THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY WILL INVEST
THESE FUNDS AN UNKNOWN WAYS AND
NOT RETURN THIS MONEY TO THE
HOMEOWNERS. THIS GOVERNMENT DID
NOT EVEN TAKE UP THE FIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE IN ORDER
TO RETURN THIS THREE NINE
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE PEOPLE OR THE HOMEOWNERS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO NON
PROFITS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
NONPROFIT INDONESIAN NONPROFIT
LED BY A VERY STRONG WOMAN
ADVOCATED AND FILED A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THIS. STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO GET THIS MONEY
BACK AND THEY HAVE WRITTEN
OPPOSE LETTER TO THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TODAY BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT RETURN THE MONEY TO
THE HOMEOWNERS IT PUTS THE PLAN
IN A TRUST AND ESTABLISHES
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT.
BUREAUCRATIC AGENCY. I DIDN'T.
MOTOR FANS AD THIS VOTE RIGHT
HERE TODAY IS JUST ANOTHER
DELAY FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
THE HOMEOWNERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT TO RECEIVE THIS
MONEY AND I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE ONE THREE
AS WE KNOW THE STATE'S REAM
COURT RULED THAT THE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE SETTLEMENT
WITH THE NATION'S LARGEST
MORTGAGE BANKS TO HOW
CALIFORNIA'S HOMEOWNERS
VICTIMIZED BY ILLEGAL LENDING
PRACTICES DURING THE MORTGAGE
MORTGAGE CRISIS WAS UNLAWFULLY
TAKEN BY GOVERNOR BROWN AND HIS
FINANCIAL OFFICERS AND DIVERTED
TO THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND.
THIS THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS WAS
INTENDED TO ONLY HELP
HOMEOWNERS WHO WERE ABUSED BY
LENDERS DURING THE MORTGAGE AND
FORECLOSURE CRISIS AND NOW WE
ARE BEING ASKED TO USE IT FOR A
MYRIAD OF OTHER PURPOSES AS SET
FORTH IN THE LEGISLATION BETTER
AGAIN QUESTIONABLE GIVEN THE
EXPLICIT RULINGS BY THE COURTS
THIS MANY SHOULD BE DIRECTED TO
A PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY VALUABLE CALLED KEEP
YOUR HOME CALIFORNIA. THE FREE
MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
THAT HAS HELPED MORE THAN
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOMEOWNERS
WHO FACE FINANCIAL HARDSHIP IN
WORRIED ABOUT LOSING THEIR HOME
THE GOVERNOR SENIOR HOUSING
ADVISER WHEN SHE WAS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY STATED
AND I QUOTE. KEEP YOUR HOME
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A VERY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM HELPING
HOMEOWNERS DEAL WITH THEIR
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES AND AVOID.
FORECLOSURE AS THEY GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET. END QUOTE. SKEWS ME
THIS STATE MANAGE PROGRAM
ALLOWS HOMEOWNERS TO AVOID
FORECLOSURE BY PROVIDING AS
MUCH AS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ASSISTANCE KEEP YOUR
HOME CALIFORNIA PROVIDES A
SECOND CHANCE TO STRUGGLING
HOMEOWNERS. THE KEEP YOUR HOME
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM IS PRESENTLY
CLOSED BECAUSE ALL OF THE FUNDS
THAT WERE PROVIDED TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO PREVENT
FORECLOSURES THAT WAS OVER
ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS. HAVE
ALREADY BEEN PROVIDED TO
APPROVED HOMEOWNERS ARE
COMMITTED TO QUALIFY TO
HOMEOWNERS THIS TYPE OF EFFORT
THAT THE MARGIN MORTGAGE
SETTLEMENT WAS SUPPOSED TO
FUND. IT ALREADY EXISTS EVERY
PENNY OF THIS SETTLEMENT MONEY
SHOULD GO TO REINSTATE THE KEEP
YOUR HOME CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
AB ONE THIRTEEN DOES NOT HELP
THIS WERE THE PROGRAM IN MOST
OF THOSE AFFECTED BY IN THE
SHORT TERM BY THE MORTGAGE
CRISIS I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER CRADDICK
SOONER VERY TO SB ONE THIRTEEN.
SB ONE THIRTEEN OZ SENATOR Y.
KASKI. PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SB ONE THIRTEEN
LET'S BE CLEAR IF WE VOTE NO ON
SB ONE THIRTEEN NOBODY GETS ANY
MONEY. THE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
NOTHING HAPPENS IT'S FINE TO
CRITICIZE THE SLOW MOTION OF
STATE GOVERNMENT. THAT'S THAT'S
FINE BUT THIS IS GOING TO
TRANSFER THE MONEY INTO THE
NATIONAL. MORTGAGE SPECIAL
DEPOSIT FINE AND WILL PROCEED
IN A TIMELY MANNER AS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF JANUARY TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY PENNY OF THIS
MONEY GOES TO THE PEOPLE A
WRIST. WHO ARE ENTITLED TO A
REGION I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN. MR LEADING
CHEN THE SENATE I WOULD. URGE A
NO VOTE AGAIN. TO ME IS THIS IS
A TRIFLING WITH OUR PROCESS A
COMPLICATED NEW SYSTEM. THAT IS
AND WILL BE RISKY. AND GOING TO
BE DIRECTED FUNDS IF. THAT
WOULD PASSED INPUT INTO LAW
SOME OF THESE FUNDS WILL BE
DIRECTED TO AREAS THAT MIGHT
FACILITATE A CERTAIN SECTOR.
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOULD CURSE OF HOUSING BUT IT
IS NOT WHAT WE'VE LOOKED AT
HISTORICALLY AS PROVIDING
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. IT UNTIL
I THINK AND I ARGUE THAT IT'S
OF CORRUPTION OF THE PROCESS
AND MANIPULATION OF THE
PROCESS. AND THEREFORE WE
SHOULD VOTE NO. THANKS CENTER
NIELSEN CENTER JONES. I THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I HAVE A
LETTER THAT THE MINORITY LEADER
RECEIVED RECENTLY MANY OF THE
POINTS OF ALL OF THE POINTS IN
THE LETTER ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
DEBATED THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND THE HEARING PROCESS
I DID WANT TO QUOTE JUST A
SHORT PART OF IT IF I COULD
MISTER PRESENT HAVE PERMISSION
TO READ. ARE YOU ARE YOU ASKING
FOR PERJURY. YES SIR PRODUCT
THANK YOU. AND I DID GET A
COMMITMENT. FROM THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER THAT SHE WILL DISPERSE
THIS LETTER TO THE OTHER
MEMBERS IF THE SUIT WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE IT. BUT IT'S FROM THE
NATIONAL ASIAN AMERICAN
COALITION. THERE SEE IS A FAITH
BUT PRESIDENCY IS FAITH PARTIES
TO. AND THE OPENING PARAGRAPH
THE NATIONAL ASIAN AMERICAN
COALITION AND THE NATIONAL
DIVERSITY COALITION. REITERATE
ITS FERVENT CALL FOR THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO DO THE RIGHT
THING IN REGARDS OF THE RETURN
OF THE THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. TO THE
NATIONAL MORTGAGE SPECIAL
DEPOSIT FUND IN M. S. D. F.
THAT IS TO UTILIZE AND DISPERSE
THE FUN IN A MANNER THAT WILL
NOT DELAY THE ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF DELIVERING AID AND
ASSISTANCE TO HOMEOWNERS IN
DISTRESS. THERE'S A- FIVE
THERE'S SIX POINTS THAT THEY
MAKE THAT UP THAT ALL BEEN
BROUGHT UP. BUT I'LL CLOSE WITH
JUST BY READING THE LAST POINT
NUMBER SIX. HOMEOWNERS HAVE
ALREADY WAITED TOO LONG FOR
THESE SETTLEMENT FUNDS TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE ASSISTANCE.
THIS I NEEDED INVESTMENT SCHEME
APPEARS TO DELAY IMMEDIATE
ACTION AND RESULTS. INSTEAD OF
THIS BILL THE STATE SHOULD
SIMPLY USE THE FUNDS TO
DIRECTLY ASSIST HOMEOWNERS THIS
YEAR. MISTER PRESIDENT I ASK
FOR A NO VOTE ON SB ONE
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU CENTER
STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THIS IS A CLASSIC
GOVERNMENTAL BAIT AND SWITCH
THE STATE SHOULD NOT TAKE MONEY
THAT WAS LEGALLY OBTAINED FOR
ONE PURPOSE AND THEN USING IT
FOR ANOTHER PURPOSE. YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE A TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IT WAS AN ORDER
THE SAID THAT THIS THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
USED TO HELP THOSE THAT WERE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF DURING THE
MORTGAGE CRISIS WOULD GET THAT
MONEY AND BE ABLE TO. HOPEFULLY
REBOUND TO GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET. LOOK AT OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LOOK AT OUR POVERTY
OVER EIGHTEEN PERCENT. WE
SHOULD BE FAST TRACKING THIS
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AND NOT PUTTING
IT INTO A SPECIAL TRUST.
BECAUSE BASICALLY BY PUTTING IN
THIS TRUST YOU'RE LOOKING AT
CREATING AN ENDOWMENT THAT'S
NOT WHAT THE SUPPLEMENT SAID
WE'RE NOT CREATING AN
ENDOWMENT. TO USE INTEREST ON
MONEY TO HELP A FINITE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE AND I WILL SAY A
SMALL FINITE OF PEOPLE. RATHER
THAN A MUCH LARGER GROUP OF
PEOPLE THE NEED TO HELP TODAY
NOT TEN YEARS FROM NOW ARE
CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAVE WAITED SEVEN
YEARS. TO GET REIMBURSED FOR
THE ABUSES THAT THEY SUFFERED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
IF THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT ARE HOLDING
THIS MONEY UP. FOR THAT REASON
LET'S STAND FOR THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THOSE
THEY'RE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
DURING THE MORTGAGE CRISIS.
LET'S GET TO THE MONEY TO THE
RIFLE PEOPLE SO THEY CAN MAYBE
BUY A HOME OR RENT A HOME AND
GET THEIR CELLS OFF THE
STREETS. I STAND UP FOR THE
CITIZENS OF THE STATE
CALIFORNIA WERE HEARD IN THE
MORTGAGE CRISIS. I HOPE YOU
WILL TOO BY SUPPORTING US BE
ONE ONE THREE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION FOR BAIT ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING
ON SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY
CLOSE I TO ASK FOR SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL ONE ONE THREE THANK
YOU MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHIE
LET AT AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. NO
BILL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD I
KELLY GHETTO I CHIANG NO DALLY
NO DOT. HI DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY
GROVE NO HERTZBERG AYE AYE AYE
HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO. HI
JACKSON BY JONES NO LEYVA. I'M
ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL AYE MONNING
BY MORE LOCK NO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN NO PAN BY PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER I
STERN BY STONE NOVEMBER OUR
CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK. NO.
SIX THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. RUBIO RUBIO AYE.
AUGUST TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TUCKER IN OUR
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN A
SINNER DRAWS OR YOU PREPARED
FOR THIS ITEM YES MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR
JR ALSO AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR ALSO THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX AMENDED IN
THE ASSEMBLY ADDRESSES A LABOR
CODE ISSUE REGARDING THE
INTERPRETATION OF SECTION TWO A
ONE THE DISCHARGE STATUTE AND
IN WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES IT SHOULD
APPLY IN THE CONTEXT OF WORKERS
AT BASEBALL PARKS IN THE STATE
I WORKED WITH THE MANAGEMENT OF
THE TEAMS THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION SCA YOU TEAMSTERS
UNITED HERE. CALIFORNIA
APPOINTMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS AND
OTHERS. TO ENSURE THE
CLARIFICATION OF THIS LABOR
CODE THIS IS A WELL ESTABLISHED
AND WELL ACCEPTED PRACTICE
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU AND ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE IN CONCURRENCE
WITH ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NONE OF MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BELL I WILL PURCHASE.
BRADFORD HI I HAVE A HERO I
CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO
I JACKSON AYE JONES. I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MOORLACH AYE
MORRELL. AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER OUR CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK BY. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PORGES. HI ROVE. STONE. ICE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO SIMPLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS SHOULD BE PREPARED
WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO CALL ON OUR
THIRTEEN OUTSTANDING ITEMS
.
PART MEMBERS IF YOU'RE PREPARED
WE'RE GONNA START LOOKING ITEMS
ARE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO THE AUTHOR THIS
ASSEMBLYMAN BLOOM AT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. BY BURGESS. CABALLERO I
CHIANG. GALGIANI OUR GROWTH.
HUESO. I JACKSON. MERRELL RUBIO.
WILK LOOK NO. MORRELL NO.
SECURE CALL BY UP TO MEMBERS
BURGESS. CHIANG GROWTH. JACKSON
GROW BY JACKSON. RUBIO. ICE
THIRTY NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES NEXUS FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE. THE SECRETARY WHEN
YOU'RE READY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. HI ATKINS BY BATES
NO PURCHASE. CHIANG DODD HI
GROWTH. NO HER TADO BY JACKSON
BOARDS NO. JACKSON. LEYVA I
MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO
PORTANTINO. MS RUBIO AREA NO.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS WANT
MORE TIME CHIANG. JACKSON MORE
LOCK PORTANTINO. I IS TWENTY
SIX KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PROCESS NEXUS FALL ITEM THIRTY
FOUR A. B. ELEVEN SIXTEEN THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HI ATKINS I DODD. I
GROWTH HI. HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE. AB SEVEN
THIRTY THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I BATES. DODD
BY DORADO. HER TADO HI MORE
LOCK. WHAT COUNTY. ICE TWENTY
NINE NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY TWO A. B. NINE TWENTY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. HI DODD. HI HER
TADO. I AM BURKE BY. ALL EYES
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES NEXT UP FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE AB TEN EIGHTY SIX MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES NO. TADO HI WILK NO. ALL
EYES THIRTY KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP FILE
ITEM THIRTY FIVE A. B. SIX FIVE
ONE. RESEARCHER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. TADO HI PORTANTINO. HI
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. EXCEPT AS FILE ITEM FOR
SB SIX NINE SIX. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
ALLEN HI. OUR EYES THIRTY NINE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS A LEVIN ON
THE URGENCY EYES TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ELEVEN ON THE ITEM ON THE
MEASURE IS IT ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM FIVE. S. B. TWO TEN.
ALLEN A RHETORICAL ROLE ALLEN.
BY GALGIANI. JONES NO. I STE
TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN ON THE
CONCURRENT. AS IT IS CERTAINLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM SIX SB FIVE
FIFTY. IN THIS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN BY.
ICE THIRTY EIGHT NIELSEN
NIELSEN NOTIFY. OUR EYES THIRTY
NINE A NOSE ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM SEVEN SB SIX OH
NINE MISS SECTOR PLEASE CALL
AFTER MEMBERS. ALLEN HI
GORGEOUS. HI OUR EYES FORTY.
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE SOMEONE
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN. LAST
BUT NOT LEAST WE HAVE FILE ITEM
EIGHT SB ONE OWN NINE MISTER
TERRY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN HI STONE. I WAS
TWENTY NINE AND KNOWS TEN THAT
THE SOME LIMITS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THAT COMPLETES OUR- ON CALL
ITEMS GIVES A MINUTE. MEMBERS
WERE MOVIE BACK TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. FILE ITEM
NINETEEN
. ALL RIGHT. BY
CHANGING PLANS RIGHT NOW
MEMBERS IT WAS A MINUTE
. OUR
MEMBERS REMOVING A TO FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING SHERRI HILL ARE YOU
PREPARED. THIS SECTOR PLEASE
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
AN ACT RELATING TO REGIONAL
NOTIFICATION CENTERS. WHEN
YOU'RE READY SENATOR HILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. IS A CO AUTHOR
I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT AB SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. THIS
MEASURE ALLOWS EIGHT ONE ONE
CENTERS TO RECEIVE THE MOST
CURRENT G. I. S. MAPPING DATA
THIS WILL ENABLE THESE CENTERS
TO FULFILL THEIR STATUTORILY
MANDATED DUTY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE. BY
NOTIFYING UNDERGROUND FACILITY
OWNERS ABOUT NEARBY EXCAVATION
FURTHERMORE. EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR WILL REQUIRE APPLICATIONS
FOR SOLAR ENERGY PERMITS TO
REFERENCE THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS TO NOTIFY A
REGIONAL REGIONAL NOTIFICATION
CENTER OF THAT PERSON'S INTENT
TO EXCAVATE BEFORE ACTIVATING.
THE BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESOURCES TO ADD A REFERENCE TO
WHICH CALIFORNIA SOLAR
PERMITTING GUIDE BOOK REGARDING
THIS REQUIREMENT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THIS ITEM.
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ON ITEM
FORTY FOUR. HEARING YOU SEE
NINE. EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE
.
OUR MEMBERS RUMORED TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN. SENATOR IN
DOLLARS ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THIS ITEM. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND ACT REALLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT. SOONER GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
ONE SEVEN ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ AB ONE SEVENTY
ONE PROTECTS VICTIMS OF
WORKPLACE SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULTS BY CREATING
RETALIATION PROTECTIONS UNDER
THE LABOR CODE. ESTABLISHING A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION OF
UNLAWFUL RETALIATION IF AN
EMPLOYER TAKES AN ADVERSE
ACTION AGAINST EMPLOYEE WITHIN
NINETY DAYS OF THE EMPLOYERS
KNOWLEDGE OF THE EMPLOYEES
STATUS AS A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT FOR
STOCKING. A LET'S BE CLEAR
THOUGH VULNERABLE EMPLOYEES
MOSTLY LOW WAGE WORKING WOMEN
ARE OFTEN LEFT BEHIND IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS APPROXIMATELY 50%
OF WORKERS WHO EXPERIENCE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE HAVE NOT REPORTED IT
BECAUSE OF FEAR OF RETALIATION
THREATS OF. OUR TO PAY
REDUCTION AS WELL AS JOB LOSS
THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND RECOVERY
PLEASE PROTECTIONS VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DESCRIPTION
OF THE PAGE ON THE SITE ON.
HEARING SEEN NONE RECEPTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. BY
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
WELL I BRIDGES NO BRADFORD I
CAN BE ERA. I CHIANG DELHI.
DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
BUYER TACO. JACKSON BY JONES NO
LEYVA TIME ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL
HI MONEY. I'M MORE LOCK. NUMBER
RAIL. NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. NO
BURKE OUR CASKEY BY WINNER. BY
WILK NO. WE WILL NOT HAVE ANY
DISRUPTION IN THE CHAMBER.
SERGEANTS
. ROCKETS. I CAUCUS
PLEASE. BRIDGE IS GOING TO BE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN A MATTER
ALLOWS WILL BE IN RECESS DURING
CAUCUS. BERNIE SUSPEND ROLL
CALL FOR DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR GROWTH THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE MATTER MANY LACK
OUR SKIS ME THE **** LOUNGE
THERE WILL BE A REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE **** Là
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA YOUR ATKINS
BATES BILL AGES EFFORT. ZERO
JANE. KELLY DODD TERRAZZO
GALGIANI. LASER GONZALEZ GROVE
YOUR HERTZBERG HILL HUESO TADO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL. MORNING AIR MORLOCK
MERRELL NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE
NUMBER BY CASSIE WIENER WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESSED
PRESIDENT WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
AND WE'RE RECOGNIZING OUR
PROTEOME AT THIS TIME. MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
COLLEAGUES ARE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE REPUBLICAN LEADER
AND I HE HERE WANTED TO MAKE A
STATEMENT OR TWO BEFORE WE
CONTINUE TO CONDUCT OUR
BUSINESS. A CRIME WAS COMMITTED
TODAY. BUT THE SENATE WILL NOT
BE DETERRED FROM CONDUCTING THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS. I WANT TO
SAY HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATE OUR
SERGEANT AT ARMS JERRY BARNETT.
HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATE OUR
SECRETARY ERICA CONTRAIRE US.
THE ENTIRE DESK TEAM AND BERNIE
MCNULTY AND HER INCREDIBLE
STAFF FOR HAVING THE ABILITY TO
ADJUST SHIFT GEARS AND DO WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THE WORK. WE HAVE SOME
LEGISLATION LEFT TO DO OUR I
WANT TO THANK SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON HI HE HAS BEEN MOST
GRACIOUS TO OFFER THEIR
SERVICES IN ANY WAY POSSIBLE TO
HELP US CONTINUE TO DO THE
WORK. MOST IMPORTANT I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES AND
YOUR INCREDIBLE STAFFS ARE
STAFF. FIVE. THIS IS UNUSUAL
OBVIOUSLY BUT I HAVE TO SAY HOW
PROUD I AM AS THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM OF THE SENATE. THAT WE CAN
COME TOGETHER AND FOCUS ON THE
JOB AND THE WORK AT HAND AND
CONTINUE TO DO WHAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS SENT US HERE. TO
DO. THANK YOU. I THINK YOU SAID
IT PRO TEM IT IS WITH A HEAVY
HEART THAT I CAN BEFORE YOU
GUYS AND TELL YOU THAT FIRST OF
ALL I'M DEEPLY SORRY FOR WHAT
HAPPENED ON THE SENATE FLOOR I
ALSO WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
VIOLENCE OF ANY TYPE WILL NOT
BE CONDONED. OR. OR TOLERATED
IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM BY ANY
OF ES REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT IT
DOESN'T MATTER. AND THE PERSON
THAT IS SAM IN QUESTION SHOULD
BE. PROSECUTED TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT OF THE LAW. AND I
SUPPORT THE YOU KNOW THE CHP
OFFICERS THAT HAVE ARE IN
CUSTODY RIGHT NOW I DO WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE SENATE
PRO TEM INTEL AND THE ENTIRE
STAFF ESPECIALLY JODY IN THE IN
THIS OUR CHIEF AND- JUST
KIMBERLY AND EVERYBODY THAT WAS
NAMED INDIVIDUALLY BY THE
SENATE PRO TEM AND ALL OF YOU
AS OUR COLLEAGUES. THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER EVEN THE
DISAGREEMENTS DISAPPEARS THEY
WERE ON THE FLOOR TODAY EARLIER
BETWEEN EACH OF US WE CAN STILL
COME TOGETHER ADAPTING DO WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO FINISH THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET ME NOT
FORGET TO ADD OUR APPRECIATION
AND THANKS TO. THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. AND ALL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT'S BUSY DOING THE
WORK THEY NEED TO DO TO
COMPLETE THIS INVESTIGATION.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL GET BACK
TO WORK MISTER PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
AND WITH. MINORITY LEADER BOB
WE'RE GOING TO GO OVER SOME
HOUSE RULES TO OUR SEARCH
PERSONAL CIRCUMSTANCES TONIGHT
FOR THOSE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENTING BILLS WILL PRESENT
FROM THE PODIUM APPEAR ON THE
RISER THOSE MEMBERS WHO CHOOSE
TO SPEAK ON A PARTICULAR MATTER
WE HAVE MICROPHONES ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE HOUSE SO CHOOSE
TO. LINE UP IF YOU CHOOSE OR
STAND UP AND BE RECOGNIZED AT
THE MICROPHONE IF YOU CHOOSE TO
SPEAK ON A PARTICULAR MATTER
AND WE'RE GONNA RETURN BACK TO
THE DAILY FILE AND WE'RE MOVING
BACK TO FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN. US
SENATOR GONZALEZ ARE YOU
PREPARED. THAT'S RIGHT WILL BUT
WE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE TAKING A
ROLL CALL MEMBERS WERE DOING
ROLL CALL AN ITEM SEVENTEEN A.
B. SEVEN I MEAN ONE SEVEN ONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA. HI
ATKINS BY. EIGHT NO BELL BY
BURGESS. YEAH FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI BY WORDS NO BORDERS
NO. NO HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
AYE AYE HUESO AYE. TADO BY
JACKSON. I JONES NO LEYVA HI I
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI HI
MONNING I'M MORE LARK NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI.
PORTANTINO HI ROSS BY RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE NO
NUMBER IOWA COUNTY HI AYE
WIENER AYE WILK NO. MISTER
PRESIDENT WILL CALL. OUR
MEMBERS WERE MOVING NOW TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY. SIR GLAZER YOU'RE
PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM. ONE
HALLMARK WERE TAKE TIME OUT BE
FREE TIME OUT
. SOME OF. OUR
MEMBERS WERE MAKE AN EXCEPTION
WE'RE GONNA ANNOUNCED A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON ITEM SEVENTEEN
IT'S TWENTY SEVEN EYES NOSE CAN
AT THIS MOMENT THE MORE THE
ITEM WILL BE PLACED BACK ON THE
CALL. SENATOR GLAZER WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ITEM
FIFTY. ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL ANAK REALLY TO
EDUCATION FINANCE. GLAZER THIS
PRESIDENTE AND MEMBERS AT FIRST
AS A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE TO ME THANK EVERYONE
FOR GETTING US ORGANIZED AGAIN
TO COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS TODAY
AND- ANSWER THE BECAUSE OF THE
BILL THAT I'M GOING TO PRESENT
TO YOU. PRESENT TO YOU NOW.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY EIGHT
PLACES A FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
K. THROUGH TWELVE THROUGH
HIGHER EDUCATION BOND. ON THE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY DOLLARS.
THE BOND INCLUDES NINE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR PRESCHOOL THROUGH
GRADE TWELVE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TWO BILLION
STATE UNIVERSITY IN TWO BILLION
DOLLARS TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL REFLECT CHANGES
REQUESTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIP.
THE BILL MAKES CHANGES TO THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM INCLUDING THE
FOLLOWING. INCREASING THE STATE
MATCH FOR LOW WELL DISTRICTS
AND DISTRICTS WITH HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF LOW INCOME FOSTER
CARE. AN E. L. STUDENTS. BY
PRIORITIZING THE REVIEW OF
CERTAIN APPLICATIONS INCLUDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY. APPLICATIONS
THAT REMEDIATE LEAD IN DRINKING
WATER THAT PROVIDE. A PRIORITY
FOR LOWER WELL DISTRICTS AND
FOR OVERCROWDED SCHOOLS. BY
ALLOWING STATE BOND FUNDS TO BE
USED FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
PRESCHOOL CLASSROOMS KITCHENS
IN SPACE FOR COUNSELORS AND
NURSES. BY ADJUSTING THE CAP ON
LOCAL BONDING TO AUGMENT SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
ABILITY TO RAISE LOCAL FUNDS.
AND ALSO UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THE BILL WAY
SCHOOL IMPACT FEES FOR MULTI
HOUSING PROJECTS LOCATED WITHIN
ONE A HALF A MILE OF A TRANSIT
STOP. AND REDUCES SCHOOL IMPACT
FEES BY 20% FOR OTHER MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROJECTS. AND
FINALLY HERE THE BILL ALSO
SPENDS LEVEL THREE FEES UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. NOW AB FORTY EIGHT ALSO
PROVIDES FUNDS FOR THE
FOLLOWING PROGRAMSSMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT ASSISTANCE TESTING
REMEDIATION OF LETTING WATER.
DISASTER ASSISTANCE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS. ON THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SIDE THE BILL
PRIORITIZES FUNDING FOR UC AND
CSU PROJECTS. THAT ADDRESS FIRE
AND LIFE SAFETY SEISMIC AND
CRITICAL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ISSUES. AND REQUIRES UC AND CSU
TO ADOPT FIVE YEAR AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING PLANS. MEMBERS
THE NEED IS GREAT. IN FACT MUCH
GREATER THAN WHAT IS PROVIDED
IN THIS BILL. BUT THIS BOND IS
IN IS AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD
FOR ALL OF OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND THERE'S AN AYE
VOTE. ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT ON
THE ITEM SENATOR MORLOCK. RISK
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FORTY EIGHT
COLLEAGUES I HAVE SOME GOOD
NEWS AND I HAVE SOME BAD NEWS.
SO START WITH THE BAD NEWS.
CALIFORNIA'S UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT GREW BY FORTY THREE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE LAST YEAR. THE
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT FOR
JUNE THIRTY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WAS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
POINT FIVE BILLION. FOR THE
YEAR ENDED JUNE THIRTY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT'S NOW TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. THE MAJOR
REASON FOR THE INCREASE
COLLEAGUES WAS BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTING STANDARDS
BOARD THAT REQUIRES FINALLY
THAT UNFUNDED ACTUARIAL ACCRUED
LIABILITIES FOR RETIREE MEDICAL
PLANS BE INCLUDED ON THE
BALANCE SHEET. SO IN THIS LAST
YEAR CALIFORNIA'S BALANCE SHEET
IS MORE MISERABLE BY ANOTHER
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT THERE WERE THREE
STATES THAT THERE ON RESTRICTED
THAT DEFICITS GROUP MUCH MORE
THAN OURS. ILLINOIS GREW BY
FORTY EIGHT POINT SEVEN
BILLION. NEW JERSEY BY SIXTY
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION. AND
TAXES BY SEVENTY NINE POINT
FIVE BILLION. TRADITIONALLY
EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIA'S HAD THE
LARGEST UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT ALWAYS PLACING AND
FIFTY OF PLACE BUT THIS YEAR
THERE'S SOME GOOD NEWS. BECAUSE
NEW JERSEY HAD SUCH A LARGE
INCREASE IT IS NOW AT TWO
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IT JUST EDGED
OUT CALIFORNIA WITH THE LARGEST
ON FUNDED. ARE SHOULD BE
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT BE
THIS OUT BY KNOWS THE WORD IN
FORTY NINTH PLACE WHICH IS
PROBABLY WHERE WE SHOULD BE
BEING A FORTY NINER FROM LONG
BEACH STATE KINDA COOL BUT
TEXAS A GROUP TO A HUNDRED AND
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION. SO IF
YOU COMBINE THOSE FOUR STATES
THEIR UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICITS
TOTAL OF THREE QUARTERS OF A
TRILLION DOLLARS. COLLEAGUES
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T NEED MORE
DEBT. AND IF IT IS PAID OUT OF
THE GENERAL FUND AS OPPOSED TO
PROP NINETY EIGHT THE INTEREST
AND PRINCIPAL PAYMENTS WILL
CROWD OUT OTHER CRITICAL
PROGRAM FUNDING LOOKING AT
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS YOU'RE
PROBABLY LOOKING AT ANOTHER
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. IN INTEREST AND PRINCIPAL
PAYMENTS COLLEAGUES WE'VE ALSO
SEEN THE AN INVERTED YIELD
CURVE ARRIVE AGAIN I'VE DEALT
WITH THIS IN TIMES PAST THAN IT
DID PORTENDS A RECESSION IS ON
THE HORIZON HORIZON ADDING IT
SO ADDING MORE BOND PAYMENTS
WHICH ARE FIXED COSTS TO OUR
BUDGET WILL BE VERY IMPRUDENT
AT THIS TIME. CONSEQUENTLY
REGARDLESS OF HOW GOOD THE
CAUSES FOR BORROWING WITH TOO
MUCH DEBT OF ALL POLL TAX
SYSTEM GROWING PENSION
CONTRIBUTION COSTS AND A
POTENTIAL RECESSIONON THE
HORIZON I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE
IN ADVICE AT THIS LEGISLATURE
FOCUS ON PAYING CASH FOR
IMPROVEMENTS AND SETTING FUNDS
ASIDE NOW FOR ITS FUTURE
MAINTENANCE JUST LIKE WE
REQUIRE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
TO DO. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND I URGE A NO VOTE
ON A. B. FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR BORDERS. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING AS
NIMBLE AS YOU YOU HAVE BEEN IN
MAKING THIS THIS NEW VENUE WORK
OUT FOR ALL OF US. A I HAVE
GREAT RESPECT FOR MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY. NOW
HOWEVER THERE ARE CERTAIN NEEDS
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL IN OUR STATE.
THAT AT THIS POINT CANNOT BE
SATISFIED BY A GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE. WE HAVE IN UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL WE HAVE TWO
BILLION THEY'LL BE GOING TO
COMMUNICATE ALL AGES TWO
BILLION TO UC'S IN TWO BILLION
TO SEE ISSUES ON TOP OF THE
NINE THAT WOULD BE GOING TO THE
K. THROUGH TWELVE. I HAVE SOME
SERIOUS RESERVATIONS ABOUT SOME
OF THE POISON PILLS. BETTER
THAT ARE IN THIS. AND THE
QUESTION THAT I'VE HAD TO ASK
MYSELF IS THE NEEDS SO GREAT
THAT WE MUST. MOVE THIS FORWARD
AND MOVING THIS FORWARD IS NOT
A LEGISLATIVE ACT IN TERMINUS
IT IS GIVING THE VOTERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A DECISION
ON THIS ISSUE. AND I BELIEVE IT
IS MY RESPONSIBILITY HAS
REPRESENT OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ONE OF OTHERS ONE OF MANY
OTHERS IS TO GIVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THE VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M A BIG CHAMPION
OF UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA C.
ISSUES IN OUR COMMUNICATORS
OCCASION SYSTEMS. AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE. ARE MUCH GREATER THAN OUR
GENERAL FUND COULD EVER MUSTER
IN ANY GIVEN YEAR OR EVEN THREE
OR FOUR FIVE YEARS SO OUT OF
NECESSITY THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
THERE IS JUST SIMPLY NO OTHER
ALTERNATIVE. I AM GOING TO BE
CASTING AN AYE VOTE I ENCOURAGE
MY COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME.
MAYBE NOT BECAUSE THEY AGREE
WITH ALL OF THE PROVISIONS IN
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION. BUT
GIVING CALIFORNIANS THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE TO VOTE ON
THIS AND THE DETERMINATION TO
REACH THEIR OWN CONCLUSION I
THINK IS ESSENTIAL AND THAT IS
WHILE BE CASTING AN AYE VOTE IN
FAVOR ARE OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU. CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU OF. MISTER PRESIDENT.
IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS. WE
HAVE AUTHORIZED FORTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN FACILITIES
BONDS FOR K. THROUGH FOURTEEN
U. K. THROUGH TWELVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE ISSUES AND THE UC
SYSTEM MAKE IT SIXTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OF FACILITIES.
INDEED THERE WILL BE SOME DEBT
BURDEN AND I THINK WHAT WAS
INDICATED BY TO HEAR MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IS PROBABLY
PRETTY ACCURATE. AND WE NOW
HAVE EIGHTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN STATE AND LOCAL FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS. BUT IS EVERY MEMBER IN
THIS SENATE. AND I THINK MOST
MEMBERS A CALIFORNIA UNDERSTAND
THAT EDUCATION IS THE CORE OF
UPWARD MOBILITY. TO THE MATTER
IS THAT ARE YOU PEOPLE FOOT
SPENDING IN K. TO TWELVE IS WAY
BELOW WHAT IT SHOULD BE. THE
NOTION OF MODERNIZING
FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN IS SOMETHING THAT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND THEN
IF YOU'RE GONNA PUT A SMALL
BURDEN OF DEBT WHAT BETTER
PLACE TO DO THAT THEN FOR
EDUCATION FOR UPWARD MOBILITY
FOR PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES
WHEN YOU LOOK AT EVERY
ECONOMIST LEFT TO RIGHT
WHEREVER HEY ARE ON THIS
POLITICAL SPECTRUM IT IS ALL
ABOUT EDUCATION IS THE CORE WE
TALK ABOUT IT. IN THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY WITH
MODERNIZING THESE FACILITIES
WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
THINGS THAT WE NEVER DREAMED OF
BEFORE. IS JUST EXTRAORDINARY
SO THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS AND I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS AUTHORS IN BOTH HOUSES FOR
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU SIR
NIELSEN. DOWN ON THE SENATE
THIS UNFORTUNATE DAY. FOR THE
STATE SENATE A HISTORIC DAY IT
IS ALSO IN THIS RESPECT WITH
THIS BILL A FORTUNATE DAY. THE
FORTUNATE DAY WHERE WE CAN
STAND UP FOR THE A PRIORITY I
THINK THAT GENERALLY ALL
CALIFORNIANS HOLD. FOR THE
PUBLIC DOLLARS IN THE STATE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND EDUCATION. I
BELIEVE IS TO REMAIN AT THE
VERY TOP. I SPENT MANY MANY
YEARS SERVING ON THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD I GOT TO LEARN
VERY UP FRONT AND VERY
PERSONALLY THE PLIGHT OF SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE REHABILITATION.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THROUGH
TRYING TIMES THEN. AND EVEN NOW.
MANY OF THOSE FACILITIES HAVE.
DECLINED EVEN MORE NOT HAVING
BEEN ABLE TO BE. REHABILITATED.
OR HAVE MAINTENANCE BEING
DEFERRED THAT'S A HISTORIC
PROBLEM. AND THOUGH WE HAVE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT IN SOME
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA THOSE ARE
GENERALLY SCHOOLS THAT ALL HAVE
HUGE. DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
CHALLENGE AND WE WILL HAVE A
GROWING ENROLLMENT. THROUGHOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION. HISTORICALLY
THEIR CAPITAL OUTLAY ISSUES
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ETCETERA
HAVE BEEN FUNDED THROUGH THE
STATE WIDE BONDS. LOCAL
DISTRICTS A REGION'S DO NOT
HAVE THE CAPABILITY. TO COME UP
WITH THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
IS REQUIRED. FOR K. TWELVE
EDUCATION. THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND THE PREVIOUS
BOND THAT HAD BEEN PASSED.
BECAUSE OF THE FINANCIAL PLIGHT
OF THE STATE. PRIOR
ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE TIGHT. AND GETTING MONEY
OUT. THAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH A
LONG TROUGH. WITHOUT HAVING
ANOTHER BONTA FOR US. AND
WITHOUT HAVING SUFFICIENT MONEY
TO KEEP UP. ALLOCATED BY THAT
BOARD. NOW IS MORE TIME IN A
TIMELY THAN EVER. BECAUSE THE
NEED IS GREATER. WE ALL ARE
SENSITIVE TO THE BONDED
INDEBTEDNESS OF CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT IS NOT A PRODUCT I ARGUE
UP K. TWELVE EDUCATION OR
HIGHER EDUCATION CONSTRUCTION
ETCETERA BONDS. IT IS A
PLETHORA OF BONDS THAT WE HAVE
LACKED FOR MANY MANY OTHER
PURPOSES. FAR LESS IMPORTANT IN
EDUCATION. THEN I SAY IN THESE
TIMES WE HAVE GOT TO HARKEN. TO
THE HIGHEST OF PRIORITIES. AND
THIS MOST ASSUREDLY SHOULD
REMAIN OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY. WE
CANNOT SACRIFICE THOSE
INSTITUTIONAL FACILITIES NEEDS
FOR OTHER OTHER FIVE OR TEN
YEARS WHICH IS WHAT WE WILL
INDOOR IF WE DO NOT. PASS THIS
MEASURE. AND THEN ENCOURAGE OUR
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA TO
SUPPORT THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
OF OUR YOUTH. OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND EVEN OUR ADULTS. ONE LAST
THING I AM PLEASED THAT IN THE
LAST SEVERAL DAYS. THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE BEEN
PUT BACK TO THE PERRY PURSUE
STATUS THEY WERE A BEHIND. CSU
AND YOU SEE. THEY NEEDED A
LITTLE BIT MORE RESOURCES THERE
VITAL PART AND THE MASTER PLAN
THAT WE REVIEWED IN THE
EIGHTIES SET THEM EQUAL THE CSU
AND YOU SEE FULL PARTNERS IN
THE TRIPARTITE SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA FULL
PARTNERS THAT BEING THE CASE
I'M GLAD NOW THEY ARE FULL
PARTNERS IN SHARING SOME OF THE
PROCEEDS FROM THE BOND. I
REGION I VOTE. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN ON SENATOR GLAZER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS FOR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO THE SENATORS WHO
SPOKE APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS. PARTICULAR APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT FROM THE US SENATOR
FROM FRESNO THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND TO HANNAH. AND IT
GIVES YOU A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF THE COMPROMISE AND CONSENSUS
BUILDING THAT WENT INTO THIS
MEASURE IT ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND THAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE OF THE GREAT LEADERSHIP
OF OUR GOVERNOR OF OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEM SPEAKER THE
ASSEMBLY AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WERE INVOLVED
IN THESE DISCUSSIONS TO BRING
THIS MEASURE BEFORE YOU. AND
CERTAINLY I'D BE REMISS WITHOUT
ACKNOWLEDGING THE GOOD WORK OF
THE EDUCATION CHAIR IN THE
ASSEMBLY THE JOINT AUTHORED
WITH ME ASSEMBLY MEMBER DONALD.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WITH THIS
MEASURE THE VOTERS ARE GOING TO
MAKE THE FINAL DECISION. BUT WE
ALL KNOW AS IT HAS SO
ARTICULATELY BEEN EXPRESSED
TONIGHT THE EDUCATION OF OUR
YOUTH IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT WE DO IT IS A
PRIORITY. I HOPE THAT YOU AGREE
I HELP THE VOTERS AGREE THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER IN
AB FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU.
MISTER SENATOR GLAZER MISMAS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RIGHT. GEN. ALLEN HI HI
ARCHULETA HI HI ATKINS AYE
BATES HI BILL ALL RIGHT I JUST.
I BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CHIANG BY DAILY. DODD ALL RIGHT
BYE DORADO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ BY GROWTH I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO I. JACKSON BY JONES NO
LEYVA HI I'M MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY MORE
LUCK NO MORRELL. NO NIELSEN AYE
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
AYE STONE NO NUMBER I'VE BY BY
COUNTY. WIENER AYE WILK POT HI.
THE SOONER GLAZER MOVES A CALL.
OR ICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FOR.
NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX. SENATOR GALGIANI ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THAT. I DON'T.
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AN
ACT RELATING TO THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY. WHEN YOU'RE READY
CENTER TO GALGIANI THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWELVE
NINETY SIX WOULD ESTABLISH THE
TAX RECOVERY IN THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY TRUE CRIME ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
COMBAT IN THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY. THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY TAKES A TOLL. ON SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
IN OUR SOCIETY WORKERS ARE
OFTEN SUBJECT TO LOW WAGES AND
CONSUMERS ARE EXPOSED TO
DANGEROUS PRODUCTS THAT ARE
UNREGULATED AND MAY BE HARMFUL
TO THE HEALTH OF AN INDIVIDUAL.
AB TWELVE NINETY SIX WOULD
CODIFY THE TRUE PROGRAM WHICH
WILL MAINTAIN MULTI AGENCY
INVESTIGATIVE TEAMS AND
SACRAMENTO AND LOS ANGELES AND
MEMBERS THIS BODY HAS VOTED FOR
SIMILAR LEGISLATION THE SENATE
HAS. HERETOFORE BEEN CALLED THE
TRACE PROGRAM AND IT WAS
SUPPORTED I BELIEVE UNANIMOUSLY
AND THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
PAST. AB TWELVE NINETY SIX
ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SCENE NINE MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA ART BY ATKINS. BY
BATES HI BILL ALL RIGHT HI
GORGEOUS I BRADFORD AYE
CAMBIADO I CHAIN I DALY. HI
DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE TADO HI JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
MORNING HI HI MORE LUCK HI
MORRELL. AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN HI.
NO HI ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE BY
NUMBER IOWA CASKEY. WIENER HI
BY WILK HI HI. CENTER GALGIANI
MOVES THE CALL. THE COUNT IS
THIRTY EIGHT EYES ZERONOS.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FORTY TWO SENATOR ALSO ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS MEASURE.
MISTER SECRETARY WILL YOU
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SENATOR
DORADO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT UP MEMBERS AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN. WHAT
BETTER PREVENT MISUSE OF
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
DATABASES SPECIFICALLY THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
HELICAL TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM CLASS CLASS IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK AVAILABLE TO ALL PUBLIC
AGENCIES OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITHIN THE STATE IT PROVIDES
ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCIES WITH
THE CAPABILITY OF OBTAINING
INFORMATION DIRECTLY FROM STATE
AND FEDERAL OF FEDERAL AND
STATE COMPUTERIZED INFORMATION
FILES. RECENT REPORTS OF
UNCOVERED THAT SOME FEDERAL
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN ACCESSING
STATE RUN DATABASES CONCERNING
INFORMATION ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
WITH LICENSES THAT WERE MADE
AVAILABLE UNDER AB SIXTY THIS
IS A BREACH OF PUBLIC TRUST AND
WE MUST IMPLEMENT GUIDELINES TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
THIS BILL REQUIRES
JUSTIFICATION FOR INQUIRIES
SEEKING INFORMATION OTHER THAN
CRIMINAL HISTORY INFORMATION.
AVAILABLE THROUGH CLOUDS THIS
BILL ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO CONDUCT
AUDITS INVESTIGATIONS TO
MONITOR SUBSCRIBER COMPLIANCE
OF CLOUDS THIS BILL IS NEEDED
TO PREVENT STATE RESOURCES FROM
BEING USED FOR FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT PROPER MEASURES
ARE IN PLACE TO JUSTIFY
INQUIRIES IN CLUBS AND ALLOW
FOR AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS
TO TAKE PLACE THAT WOULD
IDENTIFY MISUSE. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FIRST OF
ALL THANK YOU FOR DOING SUCH A
GREAT JOB IN YOUR ADAPTATION
TODAY IN OUR STAFF THANK YOU. I
RISE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN WILL
PROHIBIT CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM
SHARING DATABASES WITH FORMER
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB FIFTY FOUR THE PLACE
GUIDELINES ON THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION TO ALLOW. LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
CONTINUE SHARING INFORMATION
REGARDING CRITICAL PUBLIC
SAFETY THREATS AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WILL ALSO
LIMITING THE USE OF INFORMATION
SOLELY FOR IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES SB FIFTY
FOUR WAS HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL
AND TOOK MANY MONTHS OF
NEGOTIATIONS TO GET VARIOUS
PEACE OFFICER ORGANIZATIONS TO
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION. HERE
HERE WE ARE TWO YEARS LATER AND
THIS SAME LEGISLATURE IS NOW
PROPOSING A MEASURE THAT HAS A
STRIKINGLY SIMILAR LANGUAGE TO
WHAT WAS ONCE NEGOTIATED AND
REMOVED IN SB FIFTY FOUR AGAIN
PROMISES MADE PROMISES NOT
KEPT. IT IS THE DUTY OF OUR
PEACE OFFICERS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS PEACE OFFICERS MUST
COLLABORATE WITH FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO AVERT
VERY REAL THREATS POSED BY
FOREIGN TRANS TRANSNATIONAL
CRIMINAL CARTELS. TERRACE AND
OTHER STATEWIDE AND NATIONAL
THREATS SHARING INFORMATION
HELPS TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS SUCCESS IN OPERATIONS
SHARING INFORMATION KEEPS
CALIFORNIA SAFE. THIS BAIT AND
SWITCH IS UNCONSCIOUS COUPLE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I URGE A
NO VOTE ON AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
IF YOU WERE GONNA ASK THAT YOU
CAN TO KEEP. THE VOICES DOWN WE
CAN READ A REALLY CARES IS HARD
HERE CENTER BORDERS OR- ON THE
SIDE OF. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT IN A- IN DARK IRONY
I'M LOOKING AT THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION AS- INDIVIDUALS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE WE NOW
WEARING HANDCUFFS. THAT'S WHAT
THIS LEGISLATION DOES IT HAND
CUFFS LAW ENFORCEMENT TO THE
IDEA THAT WE ARE TAKING. A YEAR
BURDEN OF PROOF NORMALLY
RESERVED FOR THE COURT ROOM HEY
NOW INCORPORATING IT INTO THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROCESS TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS. THIS IS.
THIS IS AN ASSAULT ON. LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. AND HI WE
SEE A LOT OF BILLS. SOME OF THE
MORE CONTROVERSIAL BUT A WHAT
I'M SEEING REPEATEDLY IS THIS
IDEA THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
GUILTY BEFORE PRESUMED INNOCENT.
WHEN WE SHOULD BE RESERVING
THAT TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ACCUSED SO I
WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO TAKE
A CLOSE LOOK AT THIS. THIS IS
HANDCUFFING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
EXCHANGING INFORMATION THAT'S
NOT WHAT OUR SYSTEM IS ABOUT I
WOULD ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO VOTE NO ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THERE WILL BE
OTHERS NO DOUBT THAT WILL COME
IN THIS CYCLE OR IN THE NEXT
CYCLE BUT THIS I THINK CROSSES
THE LINE AND I ASK YOU TO
RESPECT LAW ENFORCEMENT'S LINE.
I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENIOR
NINE SENATOR ALSO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU THIS
BILL REQUIRES JUSTIFICATION FOR
INCREASED SEEKING INFORMATION
OTHER THAN CRIMINAL HISTORY
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO
THROUGH CLASS I WOULD ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT AND ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
KERR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI HI ARCHULETA AYE AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. NO BELL HI
BURGESS NO BRADFORD ART I CAN
BE YELLOW. CHIANG NO DALLY NO
DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE FURTADO. JACKSON BY JONES
NO LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
AYE AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE NO
NUMBER IRAQ IRA CASKEY. WIENER.
I WILK I DON'T KNOW. THIRD
AROUSAL MOVES A CALL. TWENTY
SIX ALL EYES ELEVEN KNOWS THE
MEASURES ON CALL. NEXT UP
MEMBERS IS ITEM NINETEEN FILE
ITEM NINETEEN CENTER WINNER YOU
PREPARED. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL AN ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE ASSESSMENT.
THE WINNER WHEN YOU'RE READY. I
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES TO RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL WAS SO EXPAND THE
PATHWAY TO COLLEGE BY GIVING
ELEVENTH GRADE STUDENTS ACCESS.
TO REQUIREDENTRANCE EXAM FOR
COLLEGE CURRENTLY STUDENTS IN
GRADES THREE THROUGH EIGHT AN
ELEVENTH GRADER REQUIRED TO
TAKE THE SMARTER BALANCED
ASSESSMENT THIS BILL ALLOWS BUT
DOES NOT REQUIRE A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADMINISTER A
COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAMS SUCH AS
THE SAT OR ACT STE THE CITY
INSTEAD OF THE STATE REQUIRED
ASSESSMENT FOR ELEVENTH GRADE
STUDENTS AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE
REQUIRES ASSESSMENT TO MEET OUR
STATE ACADEMIC STANDARDS. AND
TO ENSURE THAT ACCOMMODATIONS
OVER BE PROVIDED TO ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AS REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE
NEED TO GET APPROVAL FROM THE
US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
BEFORE ADMINISTERING THE
COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAM AND PROVE
THAT THIS ASSESSMENT WOULD MEET
ALL STATE AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE
WOULD REDUCE THE- NUMBER OF
TESTS THE STUDENTS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO TAKING GIVE
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS MORE TIME
FOR INSTRUCTION. ELEVENTH GRADE
IS A BUSY YEAR STUDENTS ARE NOT
ONLY TAKING THE STATE REQUIRED
TESTS BUT ALSO A P. TESTS AND
COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAMS OVER
FORTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED. A SIMILAR
POLICY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IN NINETEEN NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. HI BILL
ALL RIGHT I PORGES I BRADFORD
HI CAMBIADO HI JANE I DALY. I
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG BY AYE HILL AYE HUESO
I HER TADO. I JACKSON HI I
JONES HI LEYVA I AM A CHOIR. HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK I AM A REAL HI NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE HI NUMBER. IOWA KELSEY
DOWN NO WINNER HI I WILK HI
PLEASE. CALL ME AT SEVENTEEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GLAZER NO. I THIRTY EIGHT
MEMBERS TO. ICE THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS TO THE MEASURE PASSES
NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR WHY WELL ONE MINUTE
I'M SURE
. MEMBERS WERE GONNA
LET THE CALL ON FILE FILE ITEM
FIFTY A. B. FORTY EIGHT. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY. WHAT
COUNTY HI I. THE. I THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES
. OUR MEMBERS
NEXT ITEM UP IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR SENATOR MITCHELL ARE YOU
PREPARED SHE IS MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT. YOUR
<c.magenta>ITCHELL WHEN YOU'RE READY</c>
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ A BILL
THAT GIVES BOTH LARGE AND SMALL
NEWSPAPERS AN ADDITIONAL ONE
YEAR TO COMPLY WITH THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DYNAMIX RULING. AS WE
ALL KNOW OUR COMMUNITY
NEWSPAPERS ARE HURTING AND IN
SERIOUS JEOPARDY BOTH LARGE AND
SMALL PUBLICATIONS ARE FACING
CHALLENGES WITH THE ADVERTISERS
MOVING TO THE INTERNET AND
ONLINE AGGREGATORS OF NEWS
CUTTING THE LOCAL NEWSPAPERS
OUT. RECENTLY DECIED DYNAMIX
DECISION BY THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT ADDS TO THESE
CHALLENGES BY CONVERTING
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS FROM INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS TO EMPLOYEES. IT'S
THE SMALL COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS
THAT WE ALL HAVE IN OUR OWN
AREAS NEWSPAPERS THAT SERVE
RULE CALIFORNIA MONOLINGUAL
COMMUNITIES IT'S THE ETHNIC
PAPERS THAT SELLS WEEKLIES THAT
SO MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
RELY ON TO ACCESS CRITICAL NEWS
EVERY DAY. THE JEWISH JOURNAL
CULVER CITY NEWS BEVERLY PRESS
THE KOREAN TIMES OUR WEEKLY THE
LA SET NO THOSE ARE JUST A
HANDFUL IN MY VERY OWN DISTRICT
WHO I KNOW WILL BE IMPACTED IF
WE DON'T TAKE ACTION AND GIVE
THEM TIME TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO COMPLY WITH THE NEW. SUPREME
COURT RULING HAND STATE LAW.
THIS TIME WILL ENSURE THAT THE
NEWSPAPERS CAN ADJUST THEIR
DELIVERY METHODS TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW. WITHOUT FACING
DISASTROUS LIABILITY WHILE ALSO
ENSURING THAT THE NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY EVENTUALLY COMPLIES
WITH DYNAMICS AND ENSURE THAT
THE NEWSPAPER CARRIERS ARE
FAIRLY PAID AND PROTECTED BY
CALIFORNIA LABOR LAW. I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY.
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
BATES I HAVE A AN AMENDMENT TO
AT THE DESK. MR SECTOR PLEASE
READ THE AMENDMENT AMENDMENTS
BY SENATOR BATES FOR THAT ONE
BUT YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ARE THIS AMENDMENT IS
QUITE SIMPLE IT WOULD PROVIDE
AN EXEMPTION FOR UP FOR MAYBE
FIVE FOR NEWSPAPER CARRIERS OR
NEWSPAPER DISTRIBUTORS THESE
ARE LOCAL NEWSPAPER DELIVERY
PEOPLE FOR MOST THIS IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL SOURCE OF INCOME
MANY DELIVER MULTIPLE
NEWSPAPERS ON THEIR ROUTES
WHICH IS SLOW CERTAINLY ON MY
HOME. FROM THE MERCURY NEWS
GROUP EDITORIAL LET ME READ MAY
I READ. QUOTE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS SHOULD NOT IN
DANGER NEWSPAPERS LAWMAKERS
DEBATING THE FUTURE OF THE GIG
ECONOMY ARE THREATENING THE FOR
STAYING ABILITY OF LEGACY
INDUSTRIES THE SACRAMENTO BEE
EDITORIAL STATED BY REQUIRING
NEWSPAPERS TO EXTEND EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS AND PROTECTIONS. TO
ALL AND NEWSPAPER CARRIERS AB
FIVE WOULD MAKE NEWSPAPER
DELIVERY ECONOMICALLY
ECONOMICALLY IMPOSSIBLE THE
LOSS OF PRINCE REVENUE FROM
SCRAPPING THE PRINT EDITION OF
THE PAPER WITH THEN DEAL A
SEVERE BLOW TO BOTH THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRIES VIABILITY
AND THEIR MISSION. A ONE YEAR
DELAY IS NOT SUFFICIENT WE CAN
FIX THIS SPECIFIC PROBLEM WITH
AB FIVE TODAY WE CAN ADOPT THIS
AMENDMENT IT IS SIMPLE IT IS
REASONABLE IN S. URGENTLY
NEEDED I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS AMENDMENT. MR MAJORITY
LEADER. BUT YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I MOVE TO LAY THE
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE. MISS MISS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA HI BY ATKINS BY
BATES NO BELL ALL RIGHT BYE
FORGES. BRADFORD HI KELLY HERO
BY CHIANG. DALY NO DODD I
DORADO I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO I
JACKSON I JONES KNOWS LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LOCK. NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I'M AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN. STONE NO
I WILK NO NO. GROW NO. CHIANG
NO IT IS NO
. I JUST TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN THE MINOTAUR
LAID ON THE TABLE. CENTER MORE
LOCKED. MISTER PRESIDENT LIKE
TO SUBMIT A SET TO FOR
AMENDMENTS THIS SECTOR PLEASE
READ AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
MORLOCK SET TO. OR LOG THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SEVENTY ASSIST OUR
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY AND THAT'S A
POSSIBLE. BUT IT DEMONSTRATES A
FLAW OF AB FIVE SELECTING
INDUSTRIES ARE NOT CLEAR
FACTORS. THAT'S A GREATLY. AS I
DID EARLIER THIS WEEK I REQUEST
A SUSPENSION OF DYNAMAX
OPERATIONS WEST INC VERSUS
SUPERIOR COURT UNTIL JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT IS A
REASONABLE REQUEST AND I
REQUEST A NO VOTE ON THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S MOTION TO LAY
SET TO ON THE TABLE. HERTZBERG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANTICIPATION OF THAT BUT A
VACATION I INDEED MOVED TO LAY
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA AYE AYE ATKINS.
HI BATES. BELL. BATES NOBEL ALL
RIGHT BY BURGESS NO BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD. HI DORADO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROW FUR
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE AYE
AYE HUESO HI TADO HI JACKSON BY
JONES. NO LEYVA HI I'M MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL HI HI MONNING BY
MORE LOCK NO MERRELL. NO
NIELSEN NO PAN HI BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH IRA AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN. STONE. NO
I'M BURKE ACT IA CATHY HI I
WIENER AYE WILK NO. ICE TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN THE MOMENT
ARE LAID ON THE TABLE. WE'RE
NOW ON THE BILL IN CHIEF IS
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OF THE BILL IN CHIEF. CENTER
MORE MARK ARE YOU. YES CENTER
MORLOCK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES SO
WEDNESDAY EVENING I PROFFERED
AN AMENDMENT TO THE FOR ONE
YEAR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
FIVE FOR THE GIG ECONOMY. I
LAMENTED THAT AB FIVE PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS. AB ONE
SEVENTY PROVES MY POINT THANK
YOU. THE OWNERS OF DYNAMICS
HAVE DONE THE STATE A HUGE
DISSERVICE. THEY MADE A BIG
MISTAKE. BUT GOVERNMENT MAKES
MISTAKES TO. WHEN A SALESMAN
COMES IN AND CONVENTION TO DO
SOMETHING THAT SEEMS ATTRACTIVE
BUT IS NOT APPROPRIATE CAN WE
ALL SAY RTA ABUSE. BUT A HODGE
PODGE STRATEGY MAKES THE
LEGISLATURE. A LITTLE
DYSFUNCTIONAL AND MAYBE NOT
HAVE A GOOD GRASP ON INCOME TAX
AND PERSONAL OFF PERSONNEL LAW
AND THEREFORE I SUGGEST AND
STRONGLY RECOMMEND A NOBODY NO
VOTE ON AB ONE SEVENTY THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. YOU
CENTER DALLAS. NAME IS RESIDENT
MEMBERS I ALSO. COME UP TO RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I
SPOKE IN VERY HIGH DETAIL ABOUT
THE DYNAMICS CASE AND- PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS IN. THE
STATE ASSEMBLY SENATE YOU KNOW
MARK TWAIN QUOTED DID NEVER
PICK A FIGHT WITH PEOPLE WHO
BUY INK BY THE BARREL. AND I'M
NOT TRYING TO PICK A FIGHT WITH
MY LOCAL PAPERS BY ANY MEANS.
BUT THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT I
HAVE A HOSPITAL THAT CANNOT
HIGHER NOW AN ANESTHESIOLOGIST
PART TIME TO COME AND DO
SURGERY IN MY RULE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T EXEMPTS THEM.
LONG WITH THERE'S A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST ALONG WITH INFINITE
TRUCKERS. THERE ARE REALLY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO NEED
THIS EXEMPTION AND THIS
LEGISLATURE'S PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS PERFECT EXAMPLE THIS
BILL RIGHT HERE. WE NEED TO DO
A VISIT A BUSINESS EXEMPTION.
YES WAS DYNAMAX WRONG
ABSOLUTELY THEY WERE EMPLOYEES.
THEN THEY TEN NINETY NINE THEM
AND MADE THEM. CONTRACTORS
THERE ARE SEVERAL PEOPLE OUT
THERE ARE IN BUSINESS THAT TEN
NINETY NINE EACH OTHER EVERY
DAY SUCH AS MYSELF I DO THE
SAME THINGS WITH BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS. WE NEED TO TAKE THIS
SERIOUS AND WE NEED TO EXEMPT
THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING THE RIGHT THING IN
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS. FIRED A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING THIS. ALL YEAR
NEXT YEAR IF WE'RE GONNA PICK
ONE AT A TIME. LET'S FIX IT
RIGHT TAKE CARE OF ALL THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WERE DOING BUSINESS
TO BUSINESS. AND GO OUT TO
THOSE BAD ACTORS LIKE DYNAMAX.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPLOITING WORKERS ABSOLUTELY.
BUT THIS IS NOT GOING TO WORK
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING THIS. ALL
NEXT YEAR GENOVA. THANK YOU
CENTER STONE. MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES A. B. ONE SEVENTY AS
WE KNOW IS A SISTER BILL TO AB
FIVE EXEMPTS NEWSPAPER
DISTRIBUTORS FOR ONE YEAR. FROM
THE DYNAMICS APPLICATION AND I
SHARE THE SAME. VIEWPOINTS IS
MY SPEAKER RIGHT BEFORE OUR
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AT
THAT. WE DON'T CONDONE WITH
DYNAMICS DID. AND TO BROAD
BRUSH CAN THROW THE BABY OUT
WITH THE BATHWATER AS WERE
DOING IS GOING TO HURT THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD ALTHOUGH THIS BILL DOES
MARGINAL AND TEMPORARY RELIEF
TO ONE OF THE MANY INDUSTRIES
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
DYNAMICS DECISION THE FACT
REMAINS. THAT THIS BILL
REPRESENTS YET AGAIN ANOTHER
CAR ABOUT FOR A FAVORITE
INDUSTRY AB ONE SEVENTY AS ONE
MORE EXAMPLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S PICKING WINNERS
AND PICKING LOSERS THIS MEASURE
SISTER BILL AB FIVE PROVIDED
EXEMPTIONS FOR MANY
PROFESSIONS. THAT HAVE THE
MONEY TO GET LOBBYIST UP HERE
AND SPEND MONEY AND GET THE
DESIRED OUTCOME BUT IT BARELY
SCRATCHES THE SURFACE OF ALL OF
THE AFFECTED INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE GONNA BE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED. BY THIS BILL.
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES NEED A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO THE
PROBLEMS CREATED BY THE
DYNAMICS DECISION. WE NEED A
METHOD APPLIES TO ALL
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA NOT
JUST THOSE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
GET THEMSELVES ADDED TO THE AB
FIVE CAR ABOUT TRADE. THE FACT
THAT THERE'S EVEN A CAR ABOUT
TRAIN PERFECTLY DEMONSTRATES
THAT THE DYNAMAX DECISION IS
WRONG IN OTHER WORDS. OF THE
AUTHOR OF AB TAT AB ONE
SEVENTIES TWENTY NINE TEN
HEARING I'M QUOTING HER THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'D EVER CARRIED
A BILL THAT I AM DEFINITELY
OPPOSED TO I WOULD BE LYING IF
I SAID THIS WASN'T
HEARTBREAKING FOR ME. THIS MAY
BE ONE OF THE FEW TIMES I AGREE
WITH THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR AB ONE
SEVENTY. BREAKS MY HEART AS
WELL JUST LIKE THE ALL POWERFUL
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I'M
OPPOSED TO THE POLICY. BEHIND
THE BILL HOWEVER. BECAUSE I AM
IN SUPPORT OF LEGISLATION THAT
HELPS BUSINESSES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON AB ONE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO. THIS IS
VERY. VERY CONFUSING TESTIMONY
SOMETIMES. I RISE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BUT I ALSO RISE TO
RAISE CONCERNS I AGREE HOME
PORT IN THE FREE PRESS IS AN WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE AS THOSE
BUSINESSES THRIVE AT THE
WORKERS TO DELIVER THOSE
NEWSPAPERS ARE GIVEN THE PROPER
WORKER PROTECTIONS AND WORKING
CONDITIONS. HIS NEWSPAPER
DELIVERY CARRIERS OF THE ONES
WHO WAKE UP AT TWO O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING TO MAKE SURE THE
PAPERS ARE DELIVERED BY FOUR
AM. THEY DID NOT GET DAYS OFF
THE CARS GET DAMAGED THEY MUST
COVER MANY MILES AND GAS ALL AT
THEIR OWN EXPENSE. SO
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO SUPPORT
BECAUSE THIS BILL WAS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE A ONE YEAR DELAY.
FROM THE DYNAMICS REQUIREMENTS
FOR NEWSPAPER CARRIERS. BECAUSE
OF THE ONE YEAR I SURPRISED TO
SUPPORT AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
RAZA SENATOR GIRL. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT WE'RE SO GLAD
THAT THE AUTHOR IS LISTEN TO
THE SENATE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN
ISSUE DISTILLATE FOR THOSE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRIES WHOSE
LIVELIHOODS WILL BE THREATENED
BY AB FIVE BUT THOSE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
ALONE. THE THEIR INDIVIDUALS
AND OTHER INDUSTRIES OUT THERE
STILL SEEKING A CARVE OUT OF AB
FIVE THESE INCLUDED TRUCKING
INDUSTRY INCLUDING SINGLE TRUCK
OWNER OPERATORS BROKERS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONS LOW PROFESSIONALS
LAB TECHS NURSE
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS. OPTOMETRISTS
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS RESPIRATORY
THERAPIST MASSAGE THERAPIST
SOCIAL WORKERS OCCUPATIONAL SEX
THERAPIST SPEECH THERAPIST
BEHAVIORAL SERRA BUT THERAPIST
TRUCK DRIVERS REPAIR PERSON
CATERS TAXI CAB DRIVERS
REGISTER PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS
LICENSE TIMBER OPERATORS
INTERPRETER INTERPRETERS
MUSICIANS RABBIS FRANCHISEES.
IN FRANCHISE OR IT'S JUST TO
NAME A FEW. THAT'S WHY WE
BROUGHT FORTH TODAY'S
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE ASSN INSTEAD OF PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS FOR THIS
BODY IN THIS LEGISLATURE TO
CREATE A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
FOR ALL INDUSTRIES ACROSS THE
BOARD SO THAT THIS BILL CAN BE
WORKED OUT PROPRLY. BUT A VOTE
FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE IT DOES
TO A ONE YEAR DEAL IT DOES
PROVIDE A ONE YEAR DELAY FOR
OUR NEWSPAPERS THAT DESPERATELY
NEED IT. BUT I WANT TO
CHALLENGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE INTENDED
TARGET OF THIS BILL THE GIG
ECONOMY BIRD LEFT DOOR DASH.
LET'S SEE DOOR DASH UBER EATS
POSTMASTERS X. SETTER AT. THOSE
PEOPLE ARE NOT EVEN GONNA BE
COVERED UNDER THIS BILL BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A LEGITIMATE ARGUMENT
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL GO TO COURT
AND WIN ABOUT BEING A PLATFORM
AND NOT AN EMPLOYER YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ACCESS AID.
BEAUTIFULLY CREATED PLATFORM
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO GET ONLINE
AND FIGURE OUT WHERE PEOPLE ARE
REQUESTING SERVICES AND THEN
GAIN RESOURCES BY PROVIDING
SERVICES THE PEOPLE THAT USE
THE SAME PLATFORM SO THEY'RE
NOT EVEN DRIVERS THESE PEOPLE
DON'T EVEN WORK FOR YOU BRING
LEFT AND SOMEONE FORTUNATELY
THEY'RE PROBABLY A MANY A LOT
OF PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT ARE
GOING TO BE HURT BY THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BUT I DO APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR
THE ONE YEAR XTENSION FOR THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY BECAUSE IT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED AND I WOULD
ASK OF FOR IT A AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS TO SUPPORTER NEWSPAPER
FRIENDS. BUT THESE CAR ABOUT
SPERM ARE AND THE ONES THAT ARE
NOT THE ONES THAT ARE BEING
LEFT OUT FROM THIS CAR ABOUT
TRAINING LEFT AT THE STATION.
ARE UNACCEPTABLE. THANK YOU IN
ADDITION A- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HERE
NINETY NINE CENTER MITCH WHICH
OUGHT TO CLOSE I WILL MISTER UP
PRESIDENT JUST SAY WITH THE
LATENESS OF THE HOUR AND THE
UNIQUE CONDITIONS IN WHICH WERE
ALL WORKING I WILL BRIEFLY SAY
THAT. THE POINT OF AB ONE
SEVENTY IS NOT TO RENEGOTIATE
AB FIVE. AB ONE SEVENTY IS A
ONE YEAR CARVE OUT FOR THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY. THEY ARE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED TO STEP UP
AND DO THEIR WORK WITH ALL DUE
DILIGENCE WITHIN THE ONE YEAR
THEY ARE GIVEN BECAUSE IT IS
NOT THE AUTHOR'S DESIRE NOR
MINE AS THE FLOOR JACQUI TO SEE
A NOTHER YEAR WHERE NEWSPAPER
CARRIERS ARE ABUSED AND
MISTREATED BY THE PEOPLE WHO
THEY HAVE CONTRACTS WITH AGAIN
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ON THE
BILL BASS STATED AB ONE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU ALL DISCUSSION DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MISS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI BY ATKINS. BATES
HI HI BILL I PORGES. I BRADFORD
I CAL YELLOW I CHAIN I DALY NO
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TADO I JACKSON. I JONES I AYE
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK.
MORRELL HI NIELSEN ALL RIGHT I
PAN HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE AYE NUMBER IOWA
CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK HI.
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS. MORE LOCK. ICE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
GONNA LET THE CALL ON A FEW
ITEMS. IT WAS JUST ONE SECOND
HERE
. WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO CALL
AN ITEM SEVENTEEN AB ONE SEVEN
ONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHEN. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB ONE SEVEN ONE.
ALLEN HI. CHAIN. GLAZER GLAZER
I. HI IT'S TWENTY NINE KNOWS
TEN MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS
WERE LOOKING THE CALL ON ITEM
FORTY TWO AB. SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO TADO. WHAT CASKEY FOR
HEALTHCARE. ICE TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
YOU'RE NOW LOOKING CALL ON FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX AB TWELVE NINETY
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
APRS. TWELVE NINETY SIX I'M
SORRY TWELVE NINETY SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MITCHELL. WHY CASKEY HI WHAT
ELSE THE AYE MITCHELL AYE. THE
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. ONE MOMENT MEMBERS AS
WE GET OUR FALL IN ORDER
.
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE THIS EVERYONE
HAVE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER
ONE. WILL BE CONCURRENT
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. EVERYONE
HAS THE DOCUMENT. FIRST ITEM UP
LAST FALL ITEM FIFTY FIVE BY
CENTER MOBILE ARE YOU PREPARED
TO MAKE PRESENTATION WHICH
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE. SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR REQUIRE
AN ACT REALLY IN YOUR PREPAID
MOBILE TELEPHONY SERVICES.
MCGUIRE TO MY CHECK GOOD
EVENING MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB
THREE FOUR FOUR PROVIDE A ONE
YEAR SUNSET EXTENSION TO ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COLLECT ON
LOCAL UTILITY USER TAXES FOR
RETAIL SALES A PREPAID WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATION PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES THEY'RE CURRENTLY
HUNDRED ONE CITIES IN THREE
COUNTIES TO COLLECT THESE.
LOCAL UTILITY TAXES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THAT'S WHEN
THE PROGRAM WAS ENACTED TWENTY
FOUR MILLIONS BEEN COLLECTED SB
THREE FOUR FOUR ONE SURE THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE KEPT
WHOLE WHILE LARGER CLEANUP
LANGUAGE IS WORKED OUT TO LINE
STATE AND LOCAL FEES. NEXT YEAR
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. MEANING
HEARING NINE MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF
A BLIND THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
THE FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE.
EIGHTY NINE OZ THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX
SENATOR WIENER. MR KERRY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY
SIX BY SENATOR WINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO SENTENCING. SURE
WINNER THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AS TO ONE THIRTY SIX
WHICH PASSES CHAMBER EARLIER.
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL REPEAL THEIR
ONE YEAR SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT
APPLIED OVERWHELMINGLY TO LOW
LEVEL. FELONIES FOR A SECOND OR
SUBSEQUENT FELONY CONVICTION
THIS IS THE MOST COMMON SENSE
ENHANCEMENT AND REPEALING IT
WILL HELP US. TO HEAL OUR STATE
FROM THE MASS INCARCERATION
THAT HAS A INFLICTED SO MUCH
DAMAGE ON OUR COMMUNITIES AND
ON OUR BUDGET I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. XENON IS JUST I'M SORRY
SENATOR GROW. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL YOU KNOW SPEAKING
TO OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
KERN COUNTY SHE'S VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SOME ISSUES THAT
THAT TAKE OUR THAT WILL NOT
ALLOW JUST RETURNEES TO PURSUE
AN AD EIGHT A SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND THAT THIS CHAMBER
CONTINUALLY SAYS THAT THEY WANT
TO PROTECT WOMEN IN THESE
INCIDENTS ENCAMPMENTS
ENHANCEMENTS. BEING TAKEN AWAY
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PIECE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ARE NOT
HELPFUL FOR OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS WHO CONTINUALLY TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO ADD SINCE
ENCAMPMENTS TO ENHANCEMENTS TO
REPEAT OFFENDERS ESPECIALLY ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUES I.
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING SEEING
NONE SIR WINNER TO LIKE TO
CLOSE I THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE AND I WE'VE BEEN
HEARING THIS ALIVE FROM THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S AND NOT THE
SENATOR FROM. THE MINORITY
LEADER TO IT'S REPEATED AT
WHICH IS COMPLETELY INACCURATE
THERE IS A SEPARATE SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT THAT IS ONLY FOR
REPEAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFFENDERS REPEAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OFFENDERS RECEIVE A
SENTENCE ON TOP A NEW HAS BEEN
ON TOP OF THEIR SENTENCE THAT
IS TYPICALLY ONE TWO OR THREE
YEARS LONGER. AND IN ADDITION
IF THERE IS GREAT BODILY INJURY
AS A RESULT OF THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
HARSH ENHANCEMENT ON TOP OF
THAT SO I WANTED TO EXPRESS MY
DISAPPOINTMENT AT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S CONTINUE TO SPREAD
THIS MISINFORMATION THAT THE
METHOD THAT REPEALING THIS WILL
MEAN NO ONE HAS BEEN FOR
REPEAT. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFFENDERS THERE IS A SEPARATE
HARSHER ENHANCEMENT ONLY FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE AT REPEAT
CONVICTIONS FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE SAME IS TRUE OF
CHILD ABUSE BECAUSE THEY'VE ALL
ALSO SPREAD THAT SAME
MISINFORMATION THIS. IS A GOOD
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HELLO NO
ATKINS. BATES. NO BELL HI
GORGEOUS. NO BRADFORD HI COME A
GYRO I CHAIN NO DALLY NO DODD.
DORADO HI HI GALGIANI NO GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE AYE HUESO TADO NO.
JACKSON BY JONES. NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. I
MONNING. HI MORE LOCK. NO
MERRELL NO NIELSEN. NO PAN HI
PORTANTINO. ROTH HI I RUBIO.
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. NO
NUMBER. NO BY CASKEY I WINNER.
I WILK NO. SELECT SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS.
DODD NO GLAZER. WES SO I RUBIO.
PORTANTINO. ONE MORE TIME. AND
MRS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. ATKINS GLAZER
PORTANTINO RUBIO RIGHT. THE
CALL TWENTY HIGHS NO SIXTEEN.
EXCEPT MEMBERS THIS FALL ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN BY CENTER WHITE
COLLAR SKI MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN MESSENGER Y. CASKEY AN
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE BY
COUNTY THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THROUGH THE DILIGENT
WORK OF THE SENATE PRO TENSE
OFFICE RECENT AMENDMENTS
ELIMINATE CHAPTER IN COMPLEX
WITH EIGHTY YOU BILLS AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TING IN
BLOOM I'D LIKE TO THANK THE PRO
TEM FOR HER WORK ON. MAKING
SURE THAT SB THIRTEEN WAS
APPROVED THIS YEAR AND I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE WORLD. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS. BATES HI
HI BILL HI PORGES. BRADFORD HI
I CABALLERO I CHANGED I DALY HI
DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ OUR GROWTH.
I BY HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE AYE
HUESO HI HI TADO HI JACKSON.
JONES I'VE HI LEYVA AYE AYE AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK. I'M A REAL HI BY
NELSON ALL RIGHT HI PAN HI BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER HI STERN NO STONE I
AMBERG AYE AYE WORK OWSKI HI I
WIENER AYE WILK NO. THIRTY
THREE THREE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. GORGEOUS
HI JACKSON. RUBIO RUBIO NO.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR DOES. ICE
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FOR THE
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THE OTHER MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO HE IS PREPARED
MISTER SECRETARY WHEN YOU'RE
READY PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL
SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
ANAK REALLY IN A FIRE ARMS. DO
YOU KNOW FLOOR GEORGE THANK YOU
MISS PRESIDENT MEMBERS 5% SB
SIXTY ONE WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE MEMBERS TAKEN
IN THE ASSEMBLY. MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES AN ADDRESS CHAPTER OUT
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTES THE MEMBERS
PROHIBIT THE SALE OF SEMI
AUTOMATIC CENTERFIRE RIFLE TO
ANY PERSON UNDER TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE. AND PROHIBITED
PERSON FOR MAKING AN
APPLICATION TO PURCHASE MORE
THAN ONE SEMI AUTOMATIC
CENTERFIRE RIFLE IN ANY THIRTY
DAY PERIOD AS YOU KNOW THESE
ARE THE WEAPONS OF CHOICE. OF
SOME OF THOSE HEINOUS VIOLENT
ACTS THA ARE JUST KILLING OUR
KIDS SO LET'S PROHIBIT THE
CENTERFIRE RIFLES AND LIMIT THE
PURCHASED TO ONE A MONTH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS I DON'T.
SENATOR NELSON PRESENT LATER
DOWN THE SENATE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS MAKE A BAD BILL
WORSE. ARGENEAU VOTE. THERE'S
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING ON
CENTER PORTANTINO TO A CLOSE I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE WERE ALSO
CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE ON THOSE
WHO ARE TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD
PROHIBITING PEOPLE YOUNGER THAN
TWENTY ONE FROM PURCHASING
THESE CENTERFIRE VIOLENT
WEAPONS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OUR. MISS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE WORLD. ALLEN I
AM I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES.
BATES NO NO BELL HI PORGES. NO
BRADFORD ALRIGHT HI COVER GYRO
I CHIANG NOPE DALLY NO DOT HI I
DORADO. HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. I AYE HILL AYE HUESO
HI TADO HI JACKSON HI JONES NO
LEYVA TIME ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL
HI MONNING HI MORE LOCK NO
MORRELL. NO NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO.
IT IS A NUMBER. WELL NIELSEN NO.
PAN HI HI. PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE AYE STERN
AYE STONE NOVEMBER BY Y. CASKEY
HI WINNER I WILK NO. ONE CAN I
CAN GO. THE SECULAR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS ROTH.
ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS A LOVE
IN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE
CONCURRED IN NEXT UP IS FALL I
OWN ITEM FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
LEYVA MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR LEYVA AND NECK
RULING TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
LEVEL THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. GOOD EVENING MEMBERS
JUST LIKE A REALLY BIG
COMMITTEE MEETING EXCEPT
BETTER. SO MEMBERS I BACK 2%
SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR WHICH
IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY WERE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING. IT IS CLEAR BY
RECENT EFFORTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT ACCESS TO ABORTION
WOMEN'S RIGHTS IN GENERAL ARE
UNDER ATTACK. SB TWENTY FOUR
COLLEGE STUDENT RIGHT TO ACCESS
ACT WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA AND FORWARD BY
REAFFIRMING THE RIGHT OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO ACCESS TO
ABORTION CARE WITHOUT DELAY.
ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
COLLEGE STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THE FULL RANGE AND
CHOICES OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE SO THEY CAN PLAN THEIR
FUTURES AND ACHIEVE THEIR
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
GOALS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY.
BATES OUR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEN NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI I ATKINS.
BATES. NOBEL HI GORGEOUS. NO
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI CHAIN.
NO DALY NO DODD HI DORADO. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
BY GROWTH NO HERTZBERG AYE AYE
HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA. AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK NO MERRELL. NO
NELSON OF NO PAN I PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO BY SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE NO NUMBER
IOWA CASKEY HI AYE WIENER AYE
WILK. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. WILK
WILK NO. MY EYES TWENTY EIGHT
NOS ELEVEN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEANT AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN AND MR. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL ON SB TWENTY FOURTH
THIS LETTER HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
BOTH SIDES. ARE THERE ANY
OBJECTIONS TO THE LOWER. ALMOST
ALL ONE. WE'RE CALING A ROLE
ON THE SUBMISSIONS A LETTER OF
THE JOURNAL MISS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WE'RE ASKING FOR
THE MIDDLE OF THE. EARLIER IS
ASKING FOR AYE VOTE SENATOR
GROVES ASKING FOR NO VOTE.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA AYE AYE ATKINS
BATES. NO FELL HI PORGES. NO
BRADFORD HI KELLY HERO. CHIANG
NO DALLY NO DODD. I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI. HI GLAZER I GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH. GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY TADO.
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA AYE
AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. BY
MORNING BY MORE LOCK NO MERRELL
NOPE NIELSEN NO PAN HI BY
PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. NO
NUMBER I LIKE OWSKI HI I WIENER
AYE WILK NO. PORTANTINO AYE FOR
TITLE II. COPYRIGHT BY. THE SIX
THIRD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN HI HI ATKINS.
YEAH HE JUST STEPPED IN THE
DOOR. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT NOS
ELEVEN THE MOTION CARRIES.
MEMBERS NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY WE'RE GOING TO WAIT FOR A
MINUTE BUT I'M GETTING SENATOR
DR
. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS. WE HAVE
FOUGHT FOR FILE ITEM SIXTY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE A
SENATOR DODD ENACT RULING
HOUSING DOT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION SP TWO THIRTY FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THIS IS. MEMBERS MEMBERS THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
THIRTY NINE ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES
. MEMBERS WERE MOVING
BACK TO MOTIONS RATHER
RESOLUTIONS IS THERE ANY
MEMBERS SENATOR HERTZBERG HOW
SIR SIR I'M SORRY CENTER TODDLE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE PLEASE MOVE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THAT NAME
TO BE AN ACTIVE FILE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE NINETY NINE. TO BE
AN ACTIVE FILE PLEASE. WHAT
FILE ITEM FORTY NINE. JUST ONE
NOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SYNERGY BURKE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR UP PRESIDENT I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL INVOLVING
AB TWENTY FIVE BOTH SIDES OF
ALREADY SEEN IT AND I'M TOLD
HAVE APPROVED THIS AND THANK
YOU THE BEST ON THE- AND WILL
FOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION. ANY
ADDITIONAL MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS YES SERVICE CENTER
HUESO I REQUEST CONSENT TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
REGARDING SB THREE ONE THREE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
. MEMBERS ARE
IN OUR MOVIE TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE CENTER LIVE ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM. SHE
IS READY SHE'S COMING MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AN
ACCOLADE UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION AND MAKING A
PREPARATION THERE FOR. WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING
TODAY THAT WE DON'T ALWAYS HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO WE MANY
TIMES TIP THE SCALES IN THE
FAVOR OF LARGE CORPORATIONS AND
LARGE COMPANIES RARELY DO WE
EVER GET TO TIP THE SCALES IN
THE FAVOR OF WORKERS TODAY WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
I RISE 2% AB TEN SIXTY SIX
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FOR
STRIKING AND LOCKED OUT
WORKERS. WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT
WHY SHOULD WE TIP THE SCALES IN
FAVOR OF WORKING PEOPLE BECAUSE
WE DO SO MUCH FOR CORPORATIONS
WE WANT CORPORATIONS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL ABSOLUTELY BUT WE
ALSO WANT THEM TO SHARE THEIR
MONEY AND THEIR PROFITS WITH
THE PEOPLE. THAT PUSH THE MONEY
UP TO THEM. WE KNOW THAT
EARLIER THIS YEAR ACTIONS LAST
YEAR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES. GRANTED A TAX
CUTS TO CORPORATIONS. AND WE
WERE ALL TOLD THAT THAT TAX CUT
WOULD TRICKLE DOWN TO WORKERS
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED WE
KNOW THAT THESE CORPORATIONS
TOOK THAT MONEY AND PLOWED BACK
INTO THEIR SHAREHOLDERS AND THE
BOARD MEMBERS. I JUST WANT TO
GIVE YOU A COUPLE EXAMPLES OF
WHAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED WITH
THAT MONEY CVS COULD HAVE GIVEN
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEIR
WORKERS AND EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR RAISE BUT THEY DIDN'T
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WHEN
YOU MAKE MINIMUM WAGE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IS LIFE
CHANGING THAT CAN KEEP SOMEONE
OUT OF LOSING APARTMENT. THAT
CAN MOVE A FAMILY OUT OF A ONE
BEDROOM HOME APARTMENT INTO A
THREE BEDROOM APARTMENT. HOME
DEPOT COULD HAVE ALSO GIVEN
EACH ONE OF THEIR EMPLOYEES AND
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLAR RACE
BUT THEY DIDN'T MCDONALD'S
COULD HAVE GIVEN EVERYONE OF
THEIR WORKERS WORLDWIDE A FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLAR REYES AND THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE THE MONEY
NEVER TRICKLES DOWN TO THE
WORKERS THE MONEY STAYS WITH
THE CORPORATIONS AND STAYS WITH
THE SHAREHOLDERS AND THE BOARD
MEMBERS. YOUR PRICE AND OKAY
CONNIE LABEL WHAT IS THIS HAVE
TO DO WITH LOCKED OUT WORKERS
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT IT HAS TO
DO WITH LOCKED OUT WORKERS THIS
IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME BECAUSE
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW I WAS A
LABOR UNION BOSS FOR MANY YEARS
AND I LOVE THAT JOB BECAUSE I
LOVE REPRESENTING WORKERS
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE A JOB THAT CAN PAY THE
BILLS. HELP ALL THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE ALL LIVE WORK AND HELP
THE CONSTITUENTS THAT WE
REPRESENT IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
IT WAS A LONG TIME AGO. WE KNEW
THAT BARGAINING WAS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT WITH THE GROCERY
STORES ARE WE REPRESENTED THE
THREE BIG CORPORATIONS
ALBERTSONS RALPHS VONS. SO WHAT
WE DID AS THEY WERE UNION
BOSSES IS WE WENT OUT AND SPOKE
TO ALL OF OUR MEMBERS AND WE
SAID HE SENT THESE ARE GOING TO
BE. TOUGH NEGOTIATIONS. WHAT
YOU BE READY. RIGHT NOW YOU PAY
NOTHING YOUR HEALTHCARE YOU'RE
PROBABLY GONNA HAVE TO START
PAYING A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
COPAY. AND YOU DON'T REMEMBER
SAID THEY SAID WE GET IT WE
KNOW THIS WAS BEFORE OBAMACARE
THIS IS BEFORE WE SAW INCREASES
OR DECREASES IN HEALTH CARE.
THIS IS WHEN WE WERE AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE AND WE WERE
SEEING. DOUBLE DIGIT INCREASES
IN HEALTH CARE. THE WORKERS
UNDERSTOOD AND THEY SAID WE'RE
READY WE'LL DO WHAT WE NEED TO
DO WERE HAPPY TO PAY A LITTLE
BIT MORE. WHAT WE COULDN'T KNOW
AS A NION AT THAT TIME. WAS AT
THESE THREE CORPORATIONS WERE
PLANNING A STRIKE. THEY WERE
PLAYING TO PUT SOMETHING ON THE
TABLE THAT WOULD BE SO
DETRIMENTAL TO THESE WORKERS.
THAT WOULD LEAVE THEM NO CHOICE
BUT TO GO ON STRIKE. BUT WE MET
WITH THIRTY NINE BARGAINING
SESSIONS WITH THESE EMPLOYERS.
AND AFTER THIRTY NINE
BARGAINING SESSIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE CALLED A
STRIKE AND THE MEMBERS AT ALL
VOTED ON THIS. AND WHAT PEOPLE
WHO DON'T WORK IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT DON'T KNOW. IS THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE A MULTI
BARGAINING. UNIT YOU HAVE EACH
UNIT VOTE TO GO ON STRIKE BUT
THAT UNIT DOESN'T KNOW WHICH
ONE OF THEM THE STRIKE MIGHT BE
CALLED AGAINST. AND WE MAKE
THAT DECISION AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE AND IT'S USUALLY THE
EMPLOYER THAT'S THE WORST AT
THE TABLE IN THIS CASE IT WAS
VAUGHN'S UP HERE IT'S SAFE WAY.
AND THE REASON THEY WERE THE
WORST IS BECAUSE WHEN WE WERE
AT THE TABLE. SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THEY MADE WERE
COMMENTS LIKE THIS I'LL NEVER
FORGET THIS WOMAN SU ROAD
CHECK. AND SHE SAID. IT'S NOT
THAT WE DON'T WANT THAT WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO GIVE PAY RAISES
WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE PAY
RAISES BECAUSE A MONKEY COULD
DO THE JOB OF ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES. YOU IMAGINE THAT
TELLING YOU THINKING OF YOUR
EMPLOYEES AS MONKEYS. SO WE
CALLED THE STRIKE AGAINST
BONDS. ON OCTOBER SIXTH THIRD
OF OCTOBER ELEVENTH OF TWO
THOUSAND THREE. I WITHIN TWELVE
HOURS ALBERTSONS AND RALPH HAD
LOCKED OUT ALL OF THE WORKERS
THEY RETALIATED AGAINST THEIR
WORKERS. AND WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
PICKET LINES HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WOULD
ULTIMATELY BE THE LONGEST AND
MOST CUT COSTLY STRIKE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE THREE CEOS BIRD DILLON AND
JOHNSTON PUT OUT LETTERS TO ALL
OF THEIR WORKERS AND THEY SAID
WE DON'T CARE STRIKE AS LONG AS
YOU WANT. THE OFFER WILL NEVER
GET BETTER. BUT WE KEPT HOPE
ALIVE THE OFFER WOULD GET
BETTER AND AS THE DAYS AND THE
WEEKS AND THE MONTHS WORE ON.
IT GOT HARDER AND HARDER PEOPLE
LOST THEIR CARS PEOPLE LOST
THEIR HOMES. IN THE THIRD MONTH
OF THE STRIKE MEMBERS RAN OUT
OF THEIR BENEFITS SO FOR ALL OF
US WHO ARE HEALTHY THAT WAS
OKAY. BUT FOR THE WORKERS WERE
BATTLING CANCER CANCER I WILL
NEVER FORGET THE I'LL W. YOU
THE LONGSHOREMEN'S UNION
STEPPED UP. THEY FOUND OUT
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER WHO HAD
CANCER AND THEY PAID THEIR
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY WOULDN'T LOSE
THEIR MEDICAL BENEFITS WHILE
THEY WERE BATTLING CANCER. BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT DISTRICT IT
BLINDED COME DOWN THE PICKET
LINES DID COME DOWN BECAUSE THE
OFER DID GET BETTER. ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVENTH OF TWO
THOUSAND FOUR AFTER FOUR AND A
HALF MONTHS THIS PICK THE
PICKET LINES CAME DOWN. IT'S
STILL SOMETIMES HARD FOR ME TO
TALK ABOUT IT'S VERY EMOTIONAL
BECAUSE NO ONE GOES ON STRIKE
UNLESS THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING ELSE TO DO.
OUR THERE'S NO OTHER WAY OUT
PEOPLE DON'T GIVE UP THEIR
WAGES BECAUSE THEY DON'T THINK
THAT THEY JUST KNOW THERE'S NO
OTHER WAY OUT THEIR BACKS ARE
TO THE WALL. I LOOK AT THE
SEVENTY THOUSAND WORKERS. FIFTY
THOUSAND OF THEM WHO WERE
LOCKED OUT OF SOME OF THE
BRAVEST PEOPLE I WILL EVER
KNOW. AND AFTER THE STRIKE WAS
OVER WHAT THE COMPANY SAID TO
US WAS. WE PLAN TO TAKE A HIT
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO BREAK THE
UNION. AND WHAT I NEVER
UNDERSTOOD ABOUT THAT STATEMENT
IS WHEN YOU BREAK THE UNION ME
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNION
YOU'RE NOT BREAKING ME. YOU'RE
TRYING TO BREAK ALL THE WORKERS
EVERY DAY AND MAKE MONEY IF
THOSE WORKERS DON'T SHOW UP TO
WORK THESE CORPORATIONS DON'T
MAKE ANY MONEY. SO WHEN YOU
WANT TO BREAK THE UNION YOU'RE
NOT HARMING ME YOU'RE HARMING
THE WORKERS THAT ARE DOING THE
JOB FOR YOU. THOSE COMPANIES
WERE WILLING TO LOSE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS AN ATTEMPT TO
BREAK THE UNION ATTEMPTED TO
RETALIATE. AGAINST THE WORKERS.
AB TEN SIXTY SIX WOULD DO. WHAT
TIPPED THE SCALES. JUST A
LITTLE BIT TO HELP WORKERS. SO
THAT IF YOU WERE LOCKED OUT YOU
CAN RECEIVE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
ARE ONLY 26% OF YOUR ACTUAL
WAGES. IF YOU'RE ON STRIKE
AFTER FOUR WEEKS YOU WOULD BE
ENTITLED TO RECEIVE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. SO
MEMBERS. I JUST ASK YOU TODAY.
WE'RE ALWAYS SO WILLING TO TIP
THE SCALES IN THE FAVOR OF
CORPORATIONS. WHO NEVER HELP
THEIR WORKERS. TODAY COULD WE
TIP THE SCALES IN THE FAVOR OF
WORKERS THE PEOPLE THAT WE ALL
REPRESENT THEY'RE TRYING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEMS
CENTER STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES AND I.
I SIT HERE IN AMAZEMENT WHEN I
HEAR MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO
SAY THAT CAN WE ONCE TIPPED THE
SCALES IN THE FAVOR OF UNIONS
AND UNION WORKERS. AND NOT IN
FAVOR OF CORPORATIONS. MY
FRIENDS THIS IS JUST ANOTHER.
ANOTHER BILL IN THE SEQUENCE OF
UNION. BILLS THEY WERE SAYING
PART OF THE UNION CAUCUS
PRIORITIES AND IT'S JUST KIND
OF DISCONCERTING TO. HEAR THE
VILIFICATION OF CORPORATE
COMPANIES THAT DO BUSINESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO US HAVE BEEN THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. AND YOU KNOW IT YOU TALK
ABOUT THE GREED OF CORPORATIONS
WELL WHAT DO THEY DO WITH THEIR
PROFITS. MOST OF THEM ARE
PUBLICLY HELD CORPORATIONS AND
MANY OF OUR SENIOR CITIZENS
ACTUALLY GET DIVIDENDS WHEN
THOSE COMPANIES DO WELL. THEY
DO WELL. AND WITH THE STRESSES
THAT ARE SENIOR CITIZENS HAVE
TODAY WITH SOCIAL SECURITY
WHICH BARELY PAYS A- LIVING
WAGE AND MEDICARE SUPPLEMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR THEY
NEED THIS INCOME SO THAT THEY
DON'T BECOME HOMELESS. IN THEIR
GOLDEN YEARS. HERO. I'LL BET
YOU THERE'S NOT ONE PERSON IN
HERE EXCEPT ME IT IS ACTUALLY
OWNED A BUSINESS THAT MADE IT
UNION HAD UNANIMOUS LOYALTIES
AND SERVED IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. HAVING TWENTY THOUSAND.
UNION MEMBERS. AND WHILE I WAS
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
THE CITY OF TEMECULA. NEVER HAD
ONE STRIKE. BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
CONTRARY TO MY RHETORIC IN
COMMENTS AND MARKING THE UNION
CAUCUS THIS PAST WEEK I'VE HAD
A VERY GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
LABOR AND MY TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
OF BEING AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
AND IN MY YEARS OF OWNING MY
UNION PHARMACIES AND HAVING
EMPLOYEES WITH VERY LITTLE TURN
AROUND. BECAUSE THERE WILL
TAKING CARE OF. BUT MY FRIENDS
I MUST RESPECTFULLY RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. MY
WORRY IS THAT PROVIDING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS TO
EXISTING WORKERS WHO CHOOSE TO
GO ON STRIKE. WE WOULD BE
REMOVING AN INCENTIVE FOR THE
EMPLOYEES TO COME TO THE
BARGAINING TABLE AND NEGOTIATE
IN GOOD FAITH FOR THE MORE.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IS NOT
FOR WORKERS THAT HAVE
VOLUNTARILY LEFT A JOB. AB TEN
SIXTY SIX GOES BEYOND THAT. AND
PROVIDES THESE BENEFITS TO
WORKERS THAT ARE STILL EMPLOYED.
UNIONS ALREADY PLANNED FOR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
STRIKING MEMBERS WITH STRIKING
ACCOUNTS FUNDED BY UNION DUES
WHICH ALWAYS GETTING MORE
EXPENSIVE AND NEVER COMING
DOWN. AND SPECIAL ASSESSMENTS.
WELL I WILL ADMIT THAT THIS IS
A CREATIVE WAY FOR UNIONS TO
ELIMINATE THE NEED TO CREATE A
RESERVE FOR THE STRIKING
MEMBERS. THEREBY FREEING UP
MUCH OF THEIR NEEDED FUNDS I
JUST DON'T BELIEVE. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED TO BOOST THE
COFFERS OF UNIONS. THIS IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD. AS MANY AS OF THE
OTHER PIECES OF UNION
LEGISLATION THAT WE SEEN THIS
PAST WEEK. IS IN RESPONSE TO
THE JANICE DECISION AND I KNOW
THE UNIONS ARE UPSET ABOUT THE
CHANCE DECISION. AND THIS IS A
WAY. FOR THEM TO TRY TO
OVERCOME. THEIR DISDAIN. FOR
THAT SUPREME COURT DECISION.
AGAIN LET'S RESERVE OUR
EMPLOYMENT FUNDS FOR THOSE THAT
ARE TRULY UNEMPLOYED. HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS OR BEEN TERMINATED.
FOR THOSE REASONS I ASK A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WANTED TO
ADD ONE. I WANTED TO ADD ONE
PIECES OF INFORMATION TO THIS
DEBATE TO THE EXTENT IT'S
HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND. THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT. A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL WAS NEGOTIATED LAST
NIGHT. THAT IS CURRENTLY
PENDING AT THE ASSEMBLY DESK
SHOULD THE BILL WILL PASS AND
BE HEARD ON CONCURRENCE AND
I'LL JUST READ PERMISSION TO
READ FROM THIS LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL. PERMISSION GRANTED
OKAY A TO ENSURE SUCCESSFUL IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
LEGISLATION IT IS MY INTENT TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND EDT. TO REVIEW DATA ON THE
IMPACTS OF THIS POLICY CHANGE
ON THE U. I. PROGRAMS.
INCLUDING THE INTERPLAY WITH
ANY LABOR DISPUTE RELATED
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS. AND
WHETHER THIS POLICY CHANGE
WOULD IMPACT FUND'S SOLVENCY IN
ANY WAY AS WELL AS OTHER
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS. SHOULD
THE POLICY CHANGE UNDER AB TEN
SIXTY SIX RESULT IN ANYTHING
MORE THAN A NEGLIGIBLE IMPACT
ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FUND IT IS MY INTENT THAT
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE OR
REGULATORY ACTION BE PURSUED TO
LIMIT. ANY ADVERSE FISCAL
IMPACTS ON THE FUND. I KNOW
THAT THIS WAS A CENTRAL ISSUE
OF CONCERNED IN TERMS OF THE
SOLVENCY OF THE FUND AND THERE
ARE THERE COMPETING SETS OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THIS LEGISLATION BUT I THOUGHT
THAT CLARIFYING THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT SHOULD IT PASS AND
ARRIVE AT THE ASSEMBLY WOULD BE
HELPFUL IN MAKING YOUR
DECISION. THANK YOU MEMBERS. DO
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATES YES CENTER MOREAU THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS ABOUT. BUT THE
PRESENTATION OF THIS BILL AS
WELL AS SOME OTHER BILLS.
LINCOLN SAID THAT A HOUSE
DIVIDED WILL FALL AND IT'S
INTERESTING WHEN PEOPLE MAKE
THEIR- ARGUMENTS ON THIS FLOOR.
THE PIT A NEIGHBOR AGAINST
NEIGHBOR FRIEND AGAINST FRIEND
BUSINESS AGAINST. OTHER
BUSINESSES AND INDUSTRIES JUST
LIKE AB FIVE IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF THAT WINNERS VERSES
LOSERS AND NOW WE PIT EMPLOYEES
AGAINST EMPLOYERS JUST TO BE
ABLE TO GET A BILL THROUGH. AND
AGAIN THE UNIONS ARE DOING
DAMAGE TO OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
STATE I'M CONVINCED THAT AND
THIS IS BECOMING A UNION ST AND
WE WILL LOSE MORE JOBS AND
COUNTER THAT THIS BILL AS WELL
AS AB FIVE. AND AGAIN I THINK
THE POINT THAT I JUST WANNA SAY
IS I JUST THINK THE WAY THE
BILL IS PRESENTED IT THIS BODY
TENDS TO. PET. PEOPLE AGAINST
PEOPLE SO I SPOKE MY PIECE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF IT
ON THE SIDE OF. XENON SURLY
WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT OF I'VE I FEEL
BADLY THAT TWO OF THE SPEAKERS
TO NOT LISTEN TO ANYTHING THAT
I SAID. THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
GENESIS ASIAN I WAS TALKING
ABOUT AN EXPERIENCE THAT
HAPPENED SIXTEEN YOU YEARS AGO
WELL BEFORE THE JANICE DECISION
EVER CAME INTO BEING. AND I WAS
NOT SPEAKING ABOUT AB FIVE AND
YOU KNOW I'M NOT HITTING ANYONE
AGAINST EACH OTHER I'M TYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT WORKING PEOPLE
ARE LIVING AROUND US EVERY DAY
THAT WOULD WORKING PEOPLE DON'T
SUCCEED NONE OF US SUCCEED. AND
PEOPLE YOU KNOW I WAS IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT FOR THIRTY YEARS
FROM THE TIME I WAS A SENIOR IN
HIGH SCHOOL UNTIL I TOOK THIS
JOB AND IN THIRTY YEARS THERE
WAS ONE STRIKE. IS A MASSIVE
STRIKE BUT THERE WAS ONE STRIKE
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T TAKE IT
LIGHTLY MEMBERS DO NOT CHOOSE
TO GIVE UP EVERYTHING BECAUSE-
THEY THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
EASY. AND IN A WIN WIN. THE
CALL OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TEMECULA TALKS ABOUT A UNION
FUND WHAT'S CALLED A STRIKE
FUND AND YES WE DO YOU JUNIOR
INDUCED TO PUT THAT AWAY. BUT
IN MY LOCAL UNION WHICH WAS
SOLVENT AND WE WERE VERY FRUGAL
WITH OUR MONEY WE HAD TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TREAT
COMPETE WITH THE CORPORATION
WHO SET ASIDE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. TO LOSE TWO MILLION
VERSUS TWO BILLION. SO AGAIN
I'M JUST GOING TO ASK ALL OF
YOU THINK ABOUT TIPPING THE
SCALES TOWARDS WORKERS TODAY WE
DON'T MIND PRACTICING CORPORATE
WELFARE WHEN WE HAVE
CORPORATIONS. THEY TEACH THEIR
EMPLOYEES HOW TO GO ON WELFARE
AND HOW TO GO ON FOOD STAMPS WE
DON'T SEEM TO HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT. LET'S DO SOMETHING
FOR WORKERS TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZE INSPECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
NO ATKINS. BATES. NO BELL I
PORGES. NO BRADFORD ARC I
CABALLERO. CHAIN NO DALLY NO
DODD. NO DORADO. HI GALGIANI.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. HILL NO WAY SO. HI
DATO. JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA
I AM MCGUIRE I MITCHELL HI
MONNING. HI MORE LOCK NO
MERRELL NO NIELSEN NO PAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. SKINNER
AYE STERN. I STONE NO NUMBER. I
WORK OUT SEE I WINNER AYE WILK
NO. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS ALLEN.
ATKINS. ZERO GALGIANI GLAZER.
HERTZBERG TADO. PAN PORTANTINO.
ROTH RUBIO. I'M SORRY I FIFTEEN
THOSE FOURTEEN WITH CENTER
LEYVA MOST CALL
. THANK YOU NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE
SENATOR JACKSON'S PREPAREDNESS
SECTOR PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE A TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO AN ACCOLADE
TO PRIVACY. JACKSON THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
THIS IS A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
THAT AFFECTS EVERY CONSUMER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS THE BUYING AND SELLING. OF
OUR PERSONAL INFORMATION LAST
YEAR WE ENACTED THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT AND IN
DOING SO THIS LEGISLATURE GAVE
CALIFORNIANS MANY OF THE
NECESSARY. THANK YOU GAVE ME A
ARE LAST YEAR WE BY ENACTING
THIS LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT THE
LEGISLATURE GAVE CALIFORNIANS
MANY OF THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
TAKE CHARGE OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. STRTING JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE ABLE TO EXERCISE OUR
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS TO MONITOR
AND CONTROL HOW ARE DATA IS
USED SOLD. OR OTHERWISE
EXCHANGE BUT THESE RIGHTS ARE
ONLY AS GOOD AS A CONSUMERS
POWER TO ENFORCE THEM AND A KEY
COMPONENT OF TAKING CHARGE IS
TO SIMPLY KNOW. WHAT BUSINESSES
ARE HOLDING YOUR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. TO THAT END THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT DATA
BROKERS. TO FIND GENERALLY AS
BUSINESSES THAT ARE COLLECTING
AND SELLING THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF CONSUMERS WITH
WHOM THEY HAVE NO DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP. IT WILL REQUIRE
THAT THESE DATA BROKERS
REGISTER WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SO WE KNOW WHO THEY
ARE. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD
THEN BE REQUIRED TO CREATE A
REGISTRY AND HOST THAT
INFORMATION ON ITS WEBSITE. BY
REQUIRING DATA BROKERS TO
REGISTER WITH THE STATE WE CAN
TAKE A SMALL LEGISLATIVE STEP.
THAT IMPOSES MINIMAL BURDENS ON
THE BUSINESSES THAT BENEFIT
FROM THE EXCHANGE OF OUR
INFORMATION AND IT POWER
CONSUMERS TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT ON
THIS I DON'T SENATOR TO BURKE.
YEAH I THINK IT'S A COMPLETELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE UNDERLYING
ARCHITECTURE AND PURPOSE IN
FRAMEWORK. OF THE PRIVACY ACT I
ASK YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU IN
ADDITION IS SCRIPTURE TO BET ON
THIS ITEM. XENON SENATOR
JACKSON'S OUGHT TO CLOSE THIS
THANK YOU I AGREE I WISH THIS
WERE STRONGER I WISH WE HAD. A
GREATER ABILITY TO KNOW WHO
THESE DATA BROKERS ARE BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT PEOPLE WITH WHOM WE
HAVE A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP BUT
THIS IS A GOOD START TO REQUIRE
THAT THE DATA BROKERS WHO DO IN
FACT TAKE AND USE AND SELL OUR
INFORMATION. AT LEAST HAVE TO
REGISTER WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SO THAT WE CAN THEN GO
FROM THERE TO TRY TO FIND OUT
WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WITH THAT INFORMATION
WITHOUT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
RESEARCHER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. NO BELL BY PORGES.
BRADFORD ALRIGHT I CAL GYRO HI
CHANGE NO DALY NO DODD I DORADO.
HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
AYE AYE HILL. BY WITH SO I TADO
HI JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI
MONNING HI MORE LOCK NO MERRELL.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH I RUBIO. AYE
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NO NUMBER. WHAT CASKEY HI I
WINNER AYE WILK NO NO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS PORTANTINO I.
ATKINS GORGEOUS. THE MEASURE
PASSED ICE TWENTY SEVEN NO NOS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS
THERE WAS THE ERROR I IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO ADDING SENATOR
UMBERG TO THE LAST ROLL CALL
YES. NO THERE'S NO OBJECTION.
ICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES
. THE EVERYBODY'S.
MEMBERS WE'RE JUST GOING TO
SUSPEND ACTION FOR ABOUT FIVE
OR TEN MINUTES SO WE CAN GET TO
THE FILES FROM ON BOTH HOUSES
AND WE JUST ASK FOR YOU TO STAY
CLOSE BY BECAUSE WE'LL BE READY
TO ROLL SHORTLY. WE'RE ASKING
EVERYBODY STAY PUT IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM PLEASE. WE'RE
NOT ASKING TO GO BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE AND STAY IN THE
COMMITTEE RUMOR. JUST OUTSIDE
THE HEARING ROOM
. ALL RIGHT.
MEMBERS WERE READY TO GET BACK
TO WORK. WE'RE READY TO TAKE UP
UPPLEMENTAL FIVE NUMBER TWO
OUR FIRST ITEM UP IS ITEMS FILE
ITEM SIXTY ONE SENATOR HILL SB
TWO TWO TWO OR YOU PREPARE
CHECK SENATOR HILL. MISS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE BILL
TWO TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR HILL
AN ACT RELATING TO
DISCRIMINATION BERRYHILL THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT CALLING
THIS BE TWO TWENTY TWO WILL
PROTECT OUR VETERANS AND
MILITARY FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
MADE TECHNICAL CHANGES AND ADD
CHAPTER IN LANGUAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON. THE CONCURRENCE OF A
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEE NONE. I'M
SORRY. OUR MEMBERS WE WERE
DOING RECALL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE WORLD. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES BELL.
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD HI HI KELLY
HERO. CHIANG. CHIANG ARI DELI.
DOT MIND HI DORADO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ OUR
GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO HI TADO. HI JACKSON I
JONES. HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL. HI MONNING HI MORE
LUCK. RAIL. NIELSEN AYE PAN BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE. I
NUMBER IOWA CASKEY AYE AYE
WIENER AYE WILK AYE I. CENTERS
WILL MOVE THE CALL TWENTY EIGHT
ZERO. NEXT ITEM UP IS I DON'T
FILE I'M SIXTY TWO BY SIR WHY
BECAUSE HE MISSED SECTOR PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY AND
ACT REALLY INTO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. THE WHITE KASKI
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB AT THREE TWO THREE
ADDS MUCH NEEDED PARAMETERS
AROUND HOW HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS RENDER ELECTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FURTHER
NARROWED THE BILL AND
INCORPORATED LANGUAGE OFFERED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION I REGION
I VOTE. HE HEY DID SHOOT
DEBATER DISCUSSION ON THIS I
DON'T. SEE NINE MISS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ARCHULETA HI HI ATKINS. EIGHT
NO BILL HI BURGESS. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DELHI. NO
DODD AYE AYE DORADO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ OUR
GROWTH HERTZBERG. HILL HI I
WITH SO I BY TADO HI JACKSON. I
JONES. NOTE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL HI MONNING. I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER AYE STERN. STONE
STONE NO. NUMBER I HAVE FIVE A
CASKEY HI I WINNER HI WILK NO.
ICE TWENTY THREE KNOWS EIGHT
THE MEASURES ON CALL NEXT ITEM
UP IS FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR DODD MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOR
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD ANAK
RULING THE STATE PARKS. WHAT
TIME IS VERY DOT. THIS BILL HAS
NO NOVO TASKER I BOTH. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. WAS SIX OR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS HI BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALY HI
DODD HI FI DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
I HERTZBERG. HILL AYE AYE HUESO.
HI TADO BY JACKSON I JONES HI I
LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE. MITCHELL HI
FI MONNING I'M MORE LUCK HI I'M
A REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO AYE
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
HI NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY I
WIENER AYE WILK HI. THIRTY SIX
OUR EYES NO ZERO MEASURES ON
CALL NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVES SENATOR GLAZER. YEAH WE
JUST. SIXTY FIVE SB SIX THE SIX
YES SIX OH SIX. THE SECTOR
PLEASE READ THE BILL SIX OF SIX
BY SENATOR GLAZER AND NATURALLY
NAY PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
GLAZER I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AT. THIS THAT
BILLS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S ADDED A
SUNSET DATE FOR THE BOARD OF
BARBER IN COSMETOLOGY EXTENDED
THE GOVERNOR'S AUTHORITY TO
APPOINT AN EXECUTIVE OFFICE FOR
THE BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING
AND PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS. NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EITHER. USE CAUTION REBATE
HEARING TING ON MISS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS BATES HI
BILL. I BRIDGES ARE BRADFORD HI
BY CABALLERO BY CHAIN I DALY.
DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROWTH I
HERTZBERG. HILL AYE AYE HUESO
AYE TADO. JACKSON I JONES. I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK. MORRELL
AYE AYE NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG I WORK OUT SEE I
WIENER AYE WILK HI. DALY AYE
PLEASE CALL PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS HERTZBERG. ALLEN.
ATKINS TADO. MCGUIRE WARLOCK
WELL I GOT THIRTY FIVE. THEN
REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
SENATOR BRADFORD. YEAH.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
SORRY PLEASE READ YEAH SENATE
BILL. FIVE NINETY FIVE A
SENATOR BRADFORD ENACT RELATED
CAMPUS THAT ARE BRADFORD THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB FIVE
NINE FIVE IS BACKING
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENT SIMPLY
PUSH BACK TO IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENTATION DATE. AT A CO
AUTHOR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. BELL I'M BY
PORGES NO BRADFORD HI KELLY
HERO I CHAIN NO DALY. DOT HI I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL. WITH SO I
TACO. JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL HI MONEY
I'M MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO
NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE STONE NO BURKE
I'D OUR CASKEY I WINNER. HI
WILK I BY. ALL THE ICE TWENTY
FIVE NO SEVEN SENATOR MOVES A
CALL
. NEXT UP IS FOLLOW UP ITEM
SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR MORE LOG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MORE LOCKED ENACT
REALLY IN A COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE MORE
LOCK. MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES. SENATE BILL SIX
FIFTY FOUR ARE PROVIDES
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT
ADDRESS CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES
AND IT'S ON CONCURRENCE WE HAVE
HAD NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SEVEN SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR SB SEVEN FIVE
FOUR IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS I DON'T. NINETY
NINE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. MARCH ELEVENTH AYE
AYE ATKINS. BATES. HI BILL I
PORGES ARE BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I
CABALLERO BY CHAIN AYE DALY AYE
DODD AYE AYE DORADO. GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO. I TADO I JACKSON. JONES
JONES HI LABOR. I MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL. MONNING I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. I AMBERG I AM I WHAT
CASKEY. WIENER. I WILK HI BY
THREE THIRTY. THIRTY TWO I
THIRTY TO THE GUYS KNOW KNOWS
THE MEASURES ON CALL
. MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A FIFTEEN
MINUTE RECESS THIS IS TIME IF
YOU NEED TO RUN TO YOUR OFFICER
HANDLE ANY BRIDGE THE BUSINESS
THAT WE ACTUALLY DO IT NOW. AND
WILL BE STARTING BACK UP IN
FIFTEEN MINUTES WILL. WE STAND
IN RECESS
. DOWN TO FORTY TWO OR
THREE WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE
IT
. MEMBERS WERE TRYING TO
RECONVENE THIS THE SENATE. WE
HAVE ITEMS THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE UP OUR FIRST ITEM OF
BUSINESS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE.
GIVE CENTER SKINNER MINUTE. TO
PRESENT FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE.
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE SB BABY.
FIFTY FOUR. THE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AN
ACKERLEY TO RECYCLING MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE AND
CLEARING THEIR THROATS TAKE
FACSIMILE THIRTY SKINNER
PERCENT DESIGN YES RED HAT
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB FIFTY FOUR IS AN
URGENCY BILL TO HELP US DEAL
WITH THE RECENT CLOSURE OF OUR
TWO HUNDRED FOR EIGHTY FOUR
RECYCLING CENTERS IT WOULD FIND
MOBILE RECYCLING PILOTS IN.
AREAS IMPACTED BY THE CLOSURES
AND WITH THAT I ASK YOUR RIVALS.
ANY DISCUSSION OF THE BAN ON
THIS I DON'T. HEARING SEEN ON
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA HI BY.
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BELL HI
PORGES ARE BRADFORD HI KELLY
HERO I CHIANG I DALY AYE DODD
AYE DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG HI I HILL AYE
HUESO AYE ENTIRE TADO I JACKSON
BY JONES. HI LEYVA I'M ACQUIRE
BY MITCHELL. MONEY. I'M MORE
LUCK I'M A REAL BY NIELSEN AYE
PAN. BY PORTANTINO HI AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE. I AMBERG IRAQ OWSKI
I WINNER I WILK I. THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I MITCHELL. CALL CENTERS
SKINNER MOVES A CALL NEXT ITEM
UP MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR AB SEVEN NINE TWO CENTERS
SKINNER YOU PREPARE FOR THIS
ITEM YES I AM OUR SERVER WAS
FORTY FIVE MY GOD FORTY FIVE.
AB SEVEN NINE TWO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE LET ME
PERCENT FOR OUR LOW LET ME
PERCENT FIRST. I MEAN I'M SORRY
PLEASE READ THE BILL I'M SORRY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN NINETY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO RECYCLING. CENTERS
SKINNER. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THIS BILL.
HELPS ADDRESS THE FACT THAT OUR
RECYCLING MARKETS HAVE
COLLAPSED DUE TO THE COUNTRIES
IN ASIA THAT WE USED TO RELY ON
TO SELL ALL OF OUR RECYCLING
PRODUCTS ARE NOT BUYING THEM
ANY LONGER. AND SO INSTEAD WHAT
WE EXPECTED TO RECYCLE ARE
FILLING OUR LANDFILLS THIS IS A.
BILL THAT SENDS A MARKET SIGNAL.
THAT WILL BENEFIT OUR IN STATE
PLASTIC BOTTLE OF MANUFACTURERS
TO HELP US CLOSE THE ROUTE LOOP
IN RECYCLING. IT ESTABLISHES A
TIME FRAME FOR BOTTLED BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURERS TO ACHIEVE A
MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT. THE
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVED THE LOW
THE 75% CONTENT HAVE PULLED OFF
THE FOLLOWING OPPOSITION THE
CAL CHAMBER IS NO LONGER
OPPOSED THE MANUFACTURING
ASSOCIATION IS NO LONGER OPPOSE
THE INTERNATIONAL BOTTLED WATER
ASSOCIATION IS NO LONGER
OPPOSED AND NESTLE WATERS HAS
COME BOARD IN SUPPORT. AND WITH
THAT I ASK BUREAU VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM CENTER WHY COLLEGE YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR I WAS
SENT SUCCESSFUL LAST YEAR IN A
MINIMUM CONTENT BILL ON IN THE
OTHER HOUSE IT'S A IT'S A GOOD
BILL IT STARTS US DOWN THE ROAD
TOWARDS A- MEETING MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS. EMINEM CONTENT ON
OUR PRODUCTS ALL RIGHT WELL I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT. NUMBER HAD TO BE
REMOVED IT'S GONE IT SAID IT'S
A GOOD START IN A I WOULD URGE
OTHER MEMBERS TO VOTE I. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN
NINETEEN ON CENTER SKINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
ADDITION AND A. I THINK THE WE.
THIS IS AN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
BILL AS WELL AS A WASTE
REDUCTION BILL IN THAT IT
STIMULATES THE MANUFACTURING IN
STATE AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY OF
PLASTIC BOTTLES SO WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOUS. SIX THIRD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL I
BARGES NO BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I
CABALLERO. I CHIANG HI DOLLY I
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO. NO. JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MERRELL NO NIELSEN NO PAN HI HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY I
WIENER AYE WILK BY. BOB THIS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. BATES ROVE. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES
. MEMBERS WERE NOW
LOOKING TO CALL ON FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE. I'M I'M SORRY FIFTY
ONE SB. FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX SB
ONE THIRTY SIX. CAN REMOTE
ALRIGHT MISS SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ATKINS I BY GLAZER BY
PORTANTINO. RUBIO. ICE TWENTY
TWO NO SIXTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. THEN I WOULD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERTAIN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND
. MEMBERS WERE
LOOK DEAN THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE. AB FIFTY FOUR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MITCHELL. OUR
MITCHELL I. FORTY NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY. ON THE MEASURE.
ICE FORTY NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS REMOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS SENATOR
SKINNER. YES I WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE FILE ITEM TWELVE S. C. R.
SIXTY ONE. TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
AND. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
FOR SB. THREE THIRTY IT IS BEEN
APPROVED BY BOTH CAUCUSES AND
IT RACES IT JUST. CLEAR FIRES
AN INTENTION REGARDING SB THREE
THIRTY. YEAH OBJECTION
. MEMBERS
ARE THERE ANY OTHER ACTIONS ON
THE MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
HEARING SHEENA THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA LOOK THE
CALLS FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE SB TWO TWO TWO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ATKINS HI HI BATES.
REBEL. BY BURGESS. FOR JUST.
CABALLERO. HI DALY HI I GROWTH.
MCGUIRE HI MORE LUCK MORRELL.
RUBIO HI RUBY I. GROW BY.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN HI BATES.
BURGESS WARLOCK. I. ZERO HIGHS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IT'S OUR CONCURRED IN.
THE THING CALL ON FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO SB THREE TWO THREE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I ATKINS
BY BURGESS. NO CHIANG NO GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
HI RUBIO I STERN. HI STERN AYE.
THOSE WERE CUT THE MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS. HERTZBERG HI. TWENTY
NINE BILLS ELEVEN LIMITS ARE
ICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MINUTES ARE
CONCURRED IN. OUR LIVE THE CALL
AND FOLLOW FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE SB. FOUR FOUR TWO MY
CORRECT. EXCERPTED SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN HI HI ATKINS I HERTZBERG
BY MCGUIRE HI. FOURTEEN ZERO
THE SENATE KNOWS OUR CURRENT
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN
NEXT WERE LIFTING THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR SB. FIVE
NINE FIVE SIX OR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THESE
PEOPLE WERE. FOLLOWING SIXTY
FOUR FIVE NINE FIVE. ALLEN AYE
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES NO. SALLY
ARE BY HILL ALL RIGHT BY HER
TADO. MCGUIRE BY MORE LOCK.
THIRTY MINUTES ARE ICE THIRTY
KNOWS EIGHT THE SOME AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXUS FILE
ITEM SIXTY FIVE SB SIX OLD SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN. HI I ATKINS BY TADO. I
MCGUIRE AYE HI. WAS KNOWN AS
THE ICE THIRTY NINE KNOWS ONE
ASSEMBLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS FALL ITEM SIXTY SIX SB
SEVEN FIVE FOUR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN. I ATKINS
I TO ROSS SO. HERTZBERG ALL
RIGHT I JACKSON. MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. BLACK OWSKI. I THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WERE READY TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM TWENTY FEW. AB TWO
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR JACKSON.
SENATOR JACKSON'S READY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
AND ACT REALLY TO CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULT SENATOR
JACKSON'S. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES TODAY I PRESENT TO
YOU AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ THIS
MEASURE WOULD EXTEND THE CIVIL
STATURE IT'LL LIMITATIONS FOR
VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT. FOR MAGE TWENTY SIX TO
AGE FORTY AND IN CASES OF THE
LATE DISCOVERY FROM THREE YEARS
AFTER THE DISCOVERY TO FIVE THE
BILL WOULD ALSO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF DAMAGES RECOVERABLE
IN INSTANCES WHERE THERE WAS A
COVER UP. WHICH LED TO THE
ABUSE AND ALLOW FOR SHORT THREE
YEAR WINDOW FOR PAST VICTIMS
WHO A SLIP THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WE KNOW IN THE RESEARCH CLEARLY
SHOWS THAT IT CAN TAKE DECADES
FOR MOST VICTIMS TO BE READY TO
COME FORWARD TO ACTUALLY EVEN
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS EVENT
WHICH SHAPE IN SUPPRESSING THIS
HORRIFIC EVENT OR EVENTS. HAD
THEY BEEN SUPPRESSING FOR
DECADES WERE IN FACT UP PART OF
THEIR LIVES AND IMPACTED A
GREAT DEAL OF THEIR LIVES. IT
IS THEN WHEN THEY COME FORWARD
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE STATUTE
DOES ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE TO
SEEK REDRESS. SO THIS DENIES
JUSTICE TO VICTIMS IT ALLOWS
THE PERPETRATORS OF THE ABUSE
IN THOSE COMPLICIT TO CONTINUE
PRAYING ON CHILDREN OR
OTHERWISE TURNING A BLIND EYE
WE ALL OF HEARD THE STORIES.
AND THE POWER THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE HAD OVER THESE
USUALLY YOUNGSTERS BRINGING
THIS ABUSE IN THE SHAME AND-
DIFFICULTIES CONNECTING WITH
LIFE AND BEING ABLE TO LIVE A
NORMAL LIFE. UNTIL THEY GO
THROUGH THERAPY. WHICH CAN TAKE
SOME TIME SO THE LAST TIME
CALIFORNIA OPEN THE WINDOW FOR
OLD CASES. IN TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND THREE NINE HUNDRED
VICTIMS CAME FORWARD THE
EXPOSED OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY CHILD MOLESTERS AND SAVE
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN FROM
BECOMING FUTURE TARGETS.
HOWEVER WE KNOW THERE ARE MANY
WHO ARE STILL OUT THERE. WHO
WOULD NOT MADE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THEIR ABUSE AND CURRENT
PSYCHOLOGICAL INJURY AT THE
TIME. OF THE OPENING WHEN THEY
WOULD HAVE QUALIFIED TO BE ABLE
TO BRING THESE CASES BECAUSE OF
OUR HOW OUR LAWS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN THEY WILL NEVER HAVE A
CHANCE TO COME FORWARD AND
PURSUE LEGAL CRANE CLAIMS. WE
KNOW WE CAN NEVER A RACE THE
PAIN BUT THIS MEASURE WILL
EXPAND ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR
VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT BY GRANTING THE MORE
TIME TO PURSUE THEIR LEGAL
REMEDIES. THIS HOPEFULLY WILL
HELP EXPOSE PERPETRATORS WHO
HAVE BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS
AND DE DECADES ABUSING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH. AND THIS WILL
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY DESCRIPTION OF THE
BAIT ON THE SIDE ON SENATOR
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. I AGREE WITH THE
POOR MANAGER THAT ARE WRITING
THE WRONGS OF PAST SINCE IS A
RIGHT JUSTIN AND JUST THING TO
DO. AND I CONCUR THAT THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL ILLNESS CAUSED
BY. CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSES IS
NOT DISPUTED. THIS HARM
REQUIRES EXPENSIVE AND TIME
CONSUMING COUNSELING AND
INCLUDING FOR SOME SPIRITUAL
COUNSELING COLLEAGUES THERE IS
NOTHING MORE FRUSTRATING THAN A
SELF INFLICTED WOUND ALL THE
MORE SO IF IT IS INTENTIONAL.
AB TWO ONE EIGHT EXPOSES
CALIFORNIA STRAP SCHOOL
DISTRICTTHE POTENTIAL LAWSUIT
SETTLEMENTS THAT ARE NOT
COVERED BY INSURANCE AND IN THE
REMOTE CHANCE THAT THEY ARE.
WE'LL SEE INSURANCE PREMIUM
SKYROCKET. OR CARRIERS
DISAPPEAR. WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
THAT WITH THE HOMEOWNERS IN W.
YOU AYE AREAS. OF CALIFORNIA'S
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY AUDITED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ONLY 9510%
HAVE POSITIVE UNRESTRICTED
DEPOSITIONS WHAT FURTHER CUTS
WILL HAVE TO BE MADE. WE SHOULD
NOT SHOULD THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE FOOT I URGE A NO VOTE.
ON AB TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. THE FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
ITEM. AS A PERSON WHO WAS
SEXUALLY ABUSED AS A CHILD. AND
WHILE I NEVER FORGOT ABOUT THAT
ABUSE I. WAS ON ABLE TO DEAL
WITH IT OR. GET MYSELF THE
THERAPY I NEEDED I DISPIRITED I
WAS NOT ABLE TO DO SO UNTIL I
WAS ADULT AND IN FACT WHAT
TRIGGERED. MY ABILITY TO
CONFRONT IT. WAS WHEN MY OWN
DAUGHTER BECAME THE AGE THAT I
WAS WHEN MY BI<c.cyan> STARTED. THE</c>
DATA SHOWS. THAT MOST PEOPLE
WHO WERE ABUSED AS CHILDREN. IT
HAPPENS BECAUSE THEY THEY ARE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF BY SOMEONE
WHO THEY TRUST AND THEY'RE NOT
IN A SETTING IN A HOUSEHOLDER
OTHER SETTING WHERE THEY FEEL
THEY ARE ABLE. TO CONVEY WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM AND BE
PROTECTED. AND SO YOU CARRY
THAT WITH YU WHICH KEEPS YOU
FROM BEING ABLE TO CONVEY IT
AND THUS ACT TO PROTECT
YOURSELF UNTIL THE MOMENT THAT
YOU ARE EITHER IN ADEQUATE
THERAPY. OR YOU BREAK. THAT CAN
BE. THIRTY FORTY FIFTY YEARS
AFTER THE ABUSE. SO TO DENY
ANYONE FROM BEING ABLE TO SEEK
THE APPROPRIATE DAMAGES TO DEAL
WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
ABUSE IS WRONG I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. IT IS
STILL TESTIMONY SENATE BILL.
YES THIS THIS SIR ISSUE IS BEEN
LEGISLATED IN THE PAST I%
INTRODUCED THE BILL TWICE
VETOED TWICE BY GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN I HOPE OUR NEW GOVERNOR
HAS A DIFFERENT OPINION ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AND I YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS THIS THIS IS A LONG
TIME COMING WITH WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET THIS BILL
ESTABLISH FOR THE LAST. EIGHT
OR NINE YEARS AND ARJUN AYE
VOTE ON IT IT WAS A BI PARTISAN
SUPPORT WE PUT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK I THINK TWO OR
MAYBE THREE TIMES AND IT WAS
ALWAYS VETOED SO LET'S GET THIS
BILL SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
ARJUN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. TESTIMONY
AND THIS ON THIS ISSUE. HERE
NINETEEN NINE CENTER JACKSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
THANK YOU YOU KNOW THIS IS A
HORRIFIC. CRIME THAT IS BEEN
PERPETUATED ON FOR TOO MANY OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. WITH THE
COMPLICITY OF GROUPS LIKE THE
CHURCH. AND IT IS BEYOND TIME
THAT WE MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
THESE VICTIMS DESERVE THEIR DAY
IN COURT DESERVE THEIR
VINDICATION AND THEIR TRUST US.
IT IS A BEYOND TIMES THAT WE
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO CONDONE OR
TOLERATE THIS BEHAVIOR GOING
FORWARD. THIS BILL HELPS THOSE
VICTIMS TRY TO HEAL AND GET THE
JUSTICE THEY SO RIGHTLY DESERVE
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION HAVEN'T SEIZE
INSTRUCTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE SIDE. ALAN. ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL RIGHT BY
PORGES. BRADFORD HI I CABALLERO
I CHIANG I DALY. DODD I DORADO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZERAYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO I TADO. I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA I'M
ACQUIRE. MITCHELL HI I'M MONEY
I'M MORE LOCK MORRELL. NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO ROTH I
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE ALL RIGHT BY NUMBER. I
LIKE OWSKI HI BY WINNER. WILK
WELCOME. PETER JACKSON MOVES
CALL. NINE THERE ARE PLENTY OF
.
WE'RE GONNA GET BACK TO WORK.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP SB ONE BY
CENTER ATKINS WHAT OUT WHICH
CAN BE WARPED WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE. THE SECRETARY. THESE
RICH SENATE BILL ONE BY SENATOR
ATKINS AND HACK RELATING TO
PUBLIC WELFARE. ATKINS MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO MUCH
YET AGAIN FOR YOUR PATIENCE. SB
ONE AN AXE THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WORKERS DEFENSE ACTIVE TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS RESOLVE NUMEROUS
CONCERNS OVER THE CLEAN AIR
CLEAN WATER WORKER SAFETY AN
ENDANGERED SPECIES PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL. AS AMENDED SB ONE
MAKES FEDERAL BASELINE
STANDARDS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
WORKER PROTECTION ENFORCEABLE
AS A MATTER OF STATE LAW ONLY
WHEN THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
IN WASHINGTON ROLE IN DC ROLLS
THEM BACK TO BE CLEAR. SB ONE
AND WE SAID THIS AGAIN AND
AGAIN IMPOSES NO NEW
REGULATIONS OR REQUIREMENTS ON
BUSINESS AGRICULTURE OR THE
STATE'S ECONOMY IT SIMPLY KEEP
SOME PLACE THE SAME STANDARDS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN PACE AND IN
SOME CASES FOR DECADES. BEFORE
THE ARRIVAL OF THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON
AND THE ROLL BACKS THAT THEY
HAVE PUSHED FORWARD SB ONE IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD CROSS
SECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH WORKER
SAFETY IN ORGANIZED LABOR
BUSINESS. AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS. I KNOW THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN LAKE CONCERNS RAISED BY MY
FRIENDS IN THE WATER IN THE AG
COMMUNITY OVER THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT OF THE BILL. ON THE
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
AND OTHER ACTIONS TO PROTECT
BILL TO WATER. I WOULD DIRECT
MY COLLEAGUES TO PAGE THIRTEEN
LINE NINETEEN OF THE BILL WHICH
IS EXPRESSLY STATES THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT AFFECT THE
PROCESS BY WHICH THOSE
AGREEMENTS ARE ENTERED INTO. I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS A BIG
AND IMPORTANT MEASURE I THINK
WE ARE LIVING IN TIMES THAT
DEMAND OUR URGENT ACTION TO
PROTECT OUR STATE'S NATURAL
RESOURCES OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
WORKER SAFETY. I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR FIVE VOTE IN THE
CONCURRENCE OF THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THIS
ISSUE CENTER NIELSEN. THIS
PRESIDENT LADIES JOURNAL OF THE
SENATE I HAVE TO LOSE
VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION IS IN A SENSE I
HAVE BEEN SERVING. IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. IT'S ROLLING BACK
TWENTY YEARS OF PROGRESS
TOWARDS ENDING THE WATER WARS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WILL
REIGNITE THOSE WATER WARS. IT
IGNORES PROVISIONS OF LAW THAT
INDICATE THAT HUMAN BEINGS HAVE
A WATER RIGHT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SEEMS TO BE A
HYSTERIC REACTION TO THINGS
THAT HAVE GONE ON IN WASHINGTON
DC. AND IF THAT'S IT. IT'S
GOING TO LAST A LOT LONGER.
MEETING. THE DEFICIENCIES AND
THE HARM DONE HERE. THEN A
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION. IT WILL
DO NOTHING TO HEAL. OR TO HELP
PROVIDE A WATER AROUND TO THE
NEEDY AREAS OF CALIFORNIA OR TO
REPLENISH OUR GROUNDWATER. OR
TO GREECE IS. ON THE MOMENT I
I'M. ON THE MOMENT IN THE
COMMENTS THE. BIG OF THE THAT
WAS THAT ARE HERE. THEY ARE ON
THE AMENDMENTS HERE SENATOR.
JUST MAKE SURE. THANK YOU OF
SENATOR DODD SENATOR NELSON V.
JUST BE GERMANE TO THE BILL TO
SPEAK TO THE MEMBER TO
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU THAT'S
WHAT I'M DOING. NOTHING IN THAT
THAT IS IN THIS BILL THAT HAS
BEEN AMENDED. WILL DO ANYTHING
BUT FANNING THE FLAMES. OF THE
WATER WARS AND MAKE IT WORSE.
IN CALIFORNIA. THE BILL READ A
FEW. SECTIONS HERE IF I MAY.
THAT CREATES PRIVATE RIGHTS OF
ACTION. AND MANY ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE COME TO THE LEGISLATURE
EXPRESSING THEIR CONCERNS.
ASKING FOR SOME ACCOMMODATIONS
OF THOSE CONCERNS. AND I WOULD
SAY THAT THE BACKS OF BEEN
RUDELY TURNED UPON THEM. AND
NOT ACCEPTED ANY SUGGESTIONS TO
IMPROVE THIS LEGISLATION. THAT
HAVE BEEN IN GOOD FAITH. WHAT
TALK ABOUT VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT IS IN THE FUTURE. AND BUT
BASED ON PROVISIONS HERE IN AND
AS AMENDED. WHO IS GOING TO
DARE. HAVE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS.
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT TRUST THE
STATE THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS IN THIS STATE AND
NATION TODAY. THE CITIZENS
CANNOT TRUST GOVERNMENT TO KEEP
ITS WORD. AT THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY THROUGH THE VALLEYS OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BE AGREE JUSTLY
HARMED BY THIS. ONE OF THE MOST
SWEEPING ATTACKS. ON THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY THAT IS
SO DEAR TO ME. THAT I WOULD
HAVE EXPERIENCED IN MY LIFETIME
IS EMBODIED. THIS LEGISLATION
AS AMENDED. I ASK I IN TREAT.
FOR THE GOOD OF THE GENERATIONS
THIS ISN'T ABOUT NOW THIS IS
ABOUT YOUR CHILDREN AND YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE WHEN WE'RE NEGOTIATING
A NEW WATER PLAN FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THAT WAS MUCH ON
OUR MINDS THOSE WHO DID THE
NEGOTIATION. WHAT WOULD BE THE
WATER FUTURE FOR THE STATE
EVERYBODY. NOT JUST GROUPS AND
NOT JUST WATER FOR FISH WATER
FOR EVERYBODY. IN ALL SPECIES.
THIS WILL NOT GET US THERE. IT
IS ILL FOUNDED. A ROLL BACK THE
PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE MADE. AND
HERE WE GO REIGNITING. THE
WATER WARS. ANY ADDITIONAL.
VERSION OF IT ON THE SIDE ON
SENATOR BORDERS. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. I THINK SO
MANY OF US GOOD. COULD FIND
ISSUES WITH SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS LEGISLATION
SOUL ARE PROBABLY JUST PICK ONE
OR TWO. F. I MADE DIRECT
QUESTIONS TO. THE AUTHOR.
SENATOR ACTIONS WE TAKE
QUESTION YES THE ABORTION SO
REPRESENTING THE CENTRAL VALLEY
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
IMPASSIONED WORDS OF MY
COLLEAGUE WATERS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT DYNAMIC IN OUR
REGION FOR OBVIOUS OBVIOUS
REASONS. IN ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE HAD A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME DEALING WITH IS OF COURSE
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT. AND
ONE OF THE PROVISIONS IN HERE
THAT CONCERNS ME GREATLY IS THE
IDEA THAT. THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION COULD ADOPT
REGULATIONS THAT ADD SPECIES TO
THAT ARE ON THE ENDANGERED LIST.
BETTER FEDERAL ACTION RESULTS
IN A DECREASE OF PROTECTION SO
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS WOULD IT
NOT BE. EFFECTIVE TO MONITOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS BY
BRING BACK ANY STATUTORY
REQUEST THAT DOESN'T CREATE A
BASELINE AS THIS PIECE
LEGISLATION DOES. GIVEN THE
SMELLED ISSUE THE SALMON ISSUE
THE DYNAMIC AND THE CHANGING IN
THE EVOLVING SCIENCE THAT THIS
KIND OF FREEZES IN TIME WOULD
NOT BE MORE EFFECTIVE TO BRING
BACK ANY THESE CONSIDERATIONS
TO THE LEGISLATURE RATHER THAN.
ARE CREATING A BASELINE. THE
WAY THIS LEGISLATION IS
PROPOSED THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND ADD TO MY
COLLEAGUES THERE WERE MANY MANY
AMENDMENTS I IN IN. THE PROCESS
OF SIX POLICY HEARINGS INTO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES WE
SOUGHT TO ADDRESS A NUMBER OF
THOSE CONCERNS THE BASELINE HI
I MEAN WE ARE NOT CHANGING
REGULATIONS WE ARE ADOPTING THE
BASELINE WE'VE ADDED LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL. TO ADDRESS THE
BEST POSSIBLE SCIENCE THAT IS
THE CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED AGAIN AND AGAIN WE
ADDED THAT INTO THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL AT THE REQUEST AS WE
DID. NEGOTIATIONS THROUGH THE
PROCESS. FISHING GAME HIS GIVEN
DISCRETION BUT IT THEY HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THE REGULATORY
PROCESS TO DO ANY CHANGE WE ARE
TRYING TO HAVE A BASELINE SET
OF STANDARDS WE ALSO TALKED
ABOUT INTO MY OTHER COLLEAGUES.
THE VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS WHICH GETS TO THE
ISSUE OF YOUR THE BOTTOM LINE
OF YOUR QUESTION WHICH IS
WATER. THIS BILL DOESN'T IMPACT
THE VOLUNTARY CELL AGREEMENTS
WE PUT IT INTO THE INTO THE
LANGUAGE OF. THE BILL IT IS SO.
WE REALLY AND TRULY DID WORK IN
GOOD FAITH TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS. IT'S FOR IN
TERMS OF THE DISCRETION THAT
FISH AND GAME. IS GIVEN IT'S
FROZEN UNTIL FISHING GAME IS
ABLE TO REVIEW IT'S NOT
PERMANENT SO WE ARE CONTINUING
TO DO THE REVIEW THAT'S NEEDED
TO BE DONE. AND WE ARE TRYING
TO PUT INTO PLACE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
OUTLINED IN TERMS OF THE
VOLUNTARY SELL AGREEMENT. AS IT
RELATES ALSO TO THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT LET ME MAKE MAY BE
HELPFUL FOLLOW UP ON THIS IF I
MAN MISTER PRESIDENT. WHEN I
FIRST MOVED TO WHEN I FIRST
MOVED TO FRESNO I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLERK. FOR A
FEDERAL JUDGE WHO IS REGARDED
NATIONALLY AS- THE WATER JUDGE.
IN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
EXPERIENCED WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH ALL THE LITIGATIONS
INVOLVING. THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT WAS THE BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS. AND WHAT WE REALIZE
OVER TIME IS THAT THE GREAT
LATITUDE THE REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES HAVE IN DETERMINING
THEIR INTERPRETATION OF
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS WHICH IS
WHY THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAS
SPENT YEARS LOBBYING. THE
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES TO RE VISIT
THEIR SCIENTIFIC INTERPRETATION.
AND IT IS. UNFORTUNATELY COME
TO LITTLE AVAIL BUT WHAT I'M
CONCERNED MOST ABOUT THIS IS
THAT IF WE DO SUCCEED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WE WILL THEN LOSE
AGAIN AT THE STATE LEVEL. AND
THAT IS WHAT I'M TERRIBLY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION IS THAT WE HAVE
FOUGHT FOR A DECADE OR MORE
TRYING TO GET THEM TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT THE HUMAN
ELEMENT IS A KEY COMPONENT IN
UNDERSTANDING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS WHEREAS BEFORE IT WAS
ONLY ABOUT LET'S SAY A DELTA
SMELT. BUT WE WERE TRYING TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT THERE WAS A
HUMAN ELEMENT THAT WAS
CALCULATED IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT. SO NOW AFTER A DECADE A
DECADE OF FIGHTING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WE COULD VERY
WELL SEE OURSELVES WINNING IN
WASHINGTON AND THEN LOSING IN
CALIFORNIA. IN I DON'T KNOW
WHAT. JUST TO COME HERE AND SAY
WE SHOULD OPPOSE THIS I THINK
IS OVERLY SIMPLISTIC I THINK
THAT THERE ARE THERE ARE DEEP
SYSTEMIC AND FUNDAMENTAL BY
BY VIRTUE OF THAT BASELINE ON
DOES ALL THE POLITICAL WORK
THAT WE HAVE SEEN AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THAT COULD BE OF
GREAT VALUE TO THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY AND IN ALL THOSE
INTERESTED PARTIES INVOLVING
THE WATER WARS. SO ALL IN ALL
IN MY COMMENT MY COMMENTS HERE.
WITH ONE LAST QUESTION TO YOU
IF I MAY. THERE WAS IN THE
MEDIA REPORTS THAT DEMOCRAT
FEDERAL REPRESENTATIVES
FEINSTEIN IN OTHERS HAD
EXPRESSED GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
SB ONE. HAVE YOU ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS OR DO YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE TO. THE LETTER THAT
WAS SENT TO YOUR OFFICE
REGARDING SB ONE. THANK YOU.
WELL HI I WOULD SAY. THE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT OUR AS
IT RELATES TO WATER FLOWS AND
THE VOLUNTARY SETTLE AGREEMENTS
HAS BEEN LONG AND DISCUSSION
AND SETTLED AT AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND THE FEDERAL LEVEL
UNTIL WE GOT A NEW
ADMINISTRATION. THESE ARE THESE
ARE PROTECTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IN PLACE FOR. FORTY YEARS SO I
WILL SAY. WE A THE BUT THE
POINT IS TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO PROTECT ENDANGERED SPECIES
THAT WAS THE INTENT OF THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATIONS ROLLING
OUT THAT WE HAVE LIVED UNDER
FOR QUITE AWHILE. OUR DELEGATE
AND THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THAT
OUR REPRESENTATIVES AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND OUR
DELEGATION THAT WANT TO SEE
THOSE STANDARDS ROLLED BACK TO
THIS IS WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME AT
THE STATE TO PROTECT SOME
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND THE
DELTA ECO SYSTEM. I DON'T SEE
THAT YOU FIND THIS ISSUE BEING
DETERMINED ALONG POLITICAL
LINES IT'S DETERMINED ALONG
SOME GEOGRAPHICAL LINES AS IT
RELATES TO THE ISSUES AND
CONCERNS ABOUT WATER FLOWS. SO
WE HAVE DEBATED THESE ISSUES
TIME AND TIME AGAIN AT THE
STATE LEVEL. AND SO I DO
BELIEVE THAT. THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO ROLLBACK.
PROTECTIONS THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE FOR OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
ARE ENDANGERED SPECIES SO THAT
IS THE POINT OF A LARGE PART OF
THIS LEGISLATION. I EIGHT
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS DON'T ALWAYS AGREE I
MEAN IF IT IF IT IS A POLITICAL
IF YOU'RE SAYING THIS IS A
POLITICAL THING AGAIN SEE
ADMINISTRATION OBVIOUSLY IT
ISN'T IT IS ABOUT. THE
PROTECTION IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
DISAGREE. HI AND IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE RATHER
THAN HAVE CROSSED DEBATE. I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THE VERY
REASON THIS LEGISLATION IS
NECESSARY IS TO PROTECT. OUR
RESOURCES AND MAYBE FIVE THERE
ARE OF POLITICAL CONSIDERATIONS
BY DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
WHO DISAGREE BUT THESE THINGS
HAVE BEEN DEBATED. OF FOR WELL
OVER FORTY YEARS IN TERMS OF
CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT AND THE
LET THE POINT OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS TO. KEEP THOSE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE. OR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING THE
MY INQUIRIES ALL MY FINAL
COMMENT IS. IF EVER THERE WAS A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT I
THINK COULD BENEFIT FROM MORE
ANALYSIS IN MORE DISCUSSION I
THINK YOU'D BE SB ONE. THIS
WOULD BE A PERFECT CANDIDATE IF
THIS WERE ROLLED OVER INTO THE
NEXT LEGISLATIVE CYCLE. I LEAVE
THAT TO THE VOTE COUNT AT THE
END BUT I THINK MORE
CONSULTATION ESPECIALLY FROM
FOLKS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
COULD MAKE THIS A BETTER PIECE
OF LEGISLATION WITH MORE WORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SINISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. I
DO APPRECIATE THE LINE OF
QUESTIONING IN THE RESPONSES
THE WATER CHAIR THE SENATE I
DID WANT TO WEIGH IN IS JOIN
AUTHOR THIS LEGISLATION. THE
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY. UNDER WAY
BEING NEGOTIATED THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY APPROPRIATED FUNDING
FOR IN OUR BUDGET THIS CYCLE. I
BELIEVE ARE NOT ONLY CRITICAL
ELEMENTS OF OUR STATES WATER
STRATEGY BUT. THEY ARE NOT
IMPEDED BY THIS LEGISLATION.
WHAT IT REALLY COMES DOWN TO IS
WHETHER YOU TRUST THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO IMPLEMENT
THIS LEGISLATION IN A
MEANINGFUL FASHION. THAT UP
HOLD THOSE AGREEMENTS. BIT
INTERPRETS THE BASELINE
STANDARDS AND THAT. INTERPRETS
EXISTING LAW WHICH ALREADY
APPLIES THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT FOR
INSTANCE TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT. THERE IS PLENTY OF
DISCRETION UNDER EXISTING LAW
AND OF SB ONE PASSES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN FIND SMART
NEGOTIATED SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURING THAT CENTRAL VALLEY AS
ADEQUATE WATER SUPPLY. THAT
AGRICULTURE IS PUT IN A
SUSTAINABLE POSITION. BUT THAT
WE ALSO DON'T UNDER CUT. AN
EXTINCT OUR MOST SACRED
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
THE CALIFORNIA ECOSYSTEM. WE
DIDN'T WANT TO GET PUT IN THIS
POSITION. WE GOT FORCED INTO
THIS LEGISLATION. AND YOU MAY
CALL POLITICS. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WASHINGTON. HAS
DECIDED TO SINGLE OUT THIS
STATE. AND TRY TO MAKE AN
EXAMPLE OUT OF US. AND THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT INTENDED TO
POKE THIS ADMINISTRATION IN THE
I'D. BUT IT DIDN'T INTENDED IS
STATUS UNCERTAINTY TO SAY THAT
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO GO BACKWARDS.
AND THE TRACK WE WERE ON WAS
WORKING AND IS STILL CAN WORK
AND I BELIEVE THIS GOVERNOR CAN
MAKE THIS LEGISLATION WORK. IF
THEY PUT THEIR MINDS TO SO I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
TODAY AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
PRO TEM'S. COURAGEOUS
LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN A TOUGH CONVERSATION
THAT. WE NEVER WANTED TO HAVE
TO HAVE IN THE FIRST PLACE. BY
THIS INSURANCE POLICY FOR THE
GREATER GOOD OF THE STATE'S
NATURAL RESOURCES. AND
AGRICULTURE RESOURCES IS
CRITICALLY NEEDED AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER Y. COSBY. IS
RISEN AYE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE IN AND I ECHO MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE DIDN'T BRING THIS
ON INTO OUR SET UPON OURSELVES
THIS IS BROUGHT TO US IN I
WOULD REMIND MEMBERS THAT THIS
MEASURE SUNSETS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AND- MY READING OF
THE FLOOR ANALYSIS TALKS ABOUT
THE- EXTRA INSURANCE YOU KNOW.
ADD TO LEGAL INTERPRETATION
PROVISION REGARDING THE
DEFINITIONS OF WASTE AND WATER
OF THE STATE AND- THE POWER OR
THE AUTHORITY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND GAME HAS
SO AS NOT TO AFFECT EXISTING
INTERPRETATIONS WE ARE SIMPLY.
KEEPING THE STATUS QUO AND AS A.
SELF PROCLAIMED PROGRESSIVE AND
LIBERAL IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
I THINKS THE KEEPING THE STATUS
QUO IS NOT A BIG STRETCH AND I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR GROWTH THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
IF THIS BILL PASSES THE SENATE
WITH ITS CURRENT AMENDMENTS THE
ONLY HOPE FOR FARMERS AND THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED FOOD AND FIBER
IS GOVERNOR'S SOME TO VETO THIS
BILL. THIS PROBLEM POLICIES
PURPOSELY DESIGNED TO GET EVEN
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
STRIVING TO BRING COMMONSENSE
BACK TO CLEMENT WATER. A
SCIENCE. AND IT'S BEEN STATED
BY THE AUTHOR AND ALSO ANOTHER
MEMBER THAT SPOKE. THAT THIS IS
FORTY YEARS OF THIS POLICY IN
PROTECTION IS BEEN IN PLACE FOR
FORTY YEARS BUT THERE'S NEW
SCIENCE OUT THERE THAT'S
AVAILABLE. AND THAT'S WHY THESE
DECISIONS WERE MADE. SB ONE
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS FREEZES
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE REGARDING
HOW BEST PRODUCED A REBOUND OF
AN ENDANGERED SPECIES AND NON
INDIGENOUS FISH. IN THE DELTA
BAY AREA IGNORES AT LEAST
FIFTEEN YEARS WORTH OF NEW
SCIENCE AND DATA. THE SCIENCE
WILL BE MADE PERMANENT WITH
THIS BE ONE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
FOR THE SINGLE FISH SB ONE WITH
THE AMENDMENTS. WILL CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE PREVENTING FRESH
WATER FROM BEING CAPTURED AND
STORED FOR MANY FAMILIES AND
FARMERS. BEFORE IT FLOWS INTO
THE PACIFIC OCEAN. DURING THE
LAST DROUGHT IT LED TO ALMOST
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
FARMLAND COMING OUT OF
PRODUCTION. IN TWENTY 5% OF
MANDATORY WATER RUSHING FOR
FAMILIES. WITH PEOPLE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND MY COLLEAGUE
AND I SERVE. THAT DON'T HAVE
RUNNING WATER IN THE PORTER
BILIARY AND THEN ALSO THERE'S A
TO LEE TRIBE DOWN THERE THEY
HAS TO BRING A TRUCK TO WATER
INTO THEIR- THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY SERVE BECAUSE WATER SHUT
OFF. ADDITIONAL CUTS TO THE
WATER SUPPLY IN INCREASE WATER
WEIGHTS WILL CONTINUE. TO RISE.
SB ONE WITH THE AMENDMENTS
PREVENT SURFACE WATER
DELIVERIES NECESSARY TO COMPLY
WITH THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER. MANAGEMENT ACT WHICH WAS
PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO WHICH
MANDATES WATER EXTRACTED TO THE
PUMPING. MUST BE REPLACED WITH
AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF RAINFALL. A
AND IT WITH AN EQUAL AMOUNT AND
RAINFALL IS NOT ENOUGH TO
ACHIEVE THIS. AND IT'S
ESTIMATED WAS CIGNA ALONE THAT
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
FARMLAND WILL GO OUT OF
PRODUCTION. I SUBMIT TO MY
COLLEAGUES AT THIS IS FARM LAND.
THAT PRODUCES THE FOOD THAT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS EAT. AN. THE
AMERICAN FOOD SUPPLY AS A LOSS
ON THE ECONOMIC IMPACT IN JOB
LOSS WILL BE STAGGERING
ESPECIALLY FOR CENTRAL VALLEY
SB ONE WITH THE AMENDMENTS I
STILL BELIEVE REX VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS WERE INITIATED TO
COMPLY WITH 40% OF THEM PAIRED
FLOWS AND PLANNED APPROVED A
PLAN THAT WAS APPROVED IN
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THAT ALONE IS
ESTIMATED TO TAKE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND ACRES OF FARM
LAND OUT OF PRODUCTION THE
ECONOMIC IMPLACABLE ON THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND THAT FARM LAND
GOING OUT OF PRODUCTION WILL
AFFECT OUR SCHOOLS. ARE TAX
REVENUE FOR FIRES ARE FIRE
CHIEFS ARE POLICE CHIEFS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
LAND IN PRODUCTION FOR FOOD TO
GROW FOOD THERE'S NOT REVENUE
TO PAY TAXES TO SUPPORT THAT
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT FROM MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD ALMOST TWO POINT
TWO MILLION PEOPLE WILL A CASE
ESTIMATED THAT THESE ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES COULD BE DEVASTATED
FROM MERCED TEMP TO BAKERSFIELD
AND IN FACT ALMOST TWO MILLION
PEOPLE FROM SAN FRAN IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WILL ALSO
LOSE. WATER IN C. DRACONIAN
WATER REDUCTIONS. SB ONE IN
THESE AMENDMENTS TAKES AFFECTS
IMMEDIATELY ANY REMAINS IN
EFFECT UNTIL THE PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S HE LEAVES OFFICE AND IT
GIVES CALIFORNIA'S SO
CONTROLLER THE VAST AMOUNTS OF
WATER PREVENTS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S. INTERVENTION
INTERVENTION ASSISTANCE IN
RESTORING BALANCE FOR
BENEFICIAL WATER USE FOR ALL
USERS. THIS IS REALLY. YOU KNOW
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS. WE
PRODUCE THE ENERGY THAT THE
CALIFORNIANS IN CONSTITUENTS
CONSTITUENTS USE ON A DAILY
BASIS. AND WE PRODUCE THE FOOD.
THAT YOUR CONSTITUENTS EAT AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO IMPORT MORE
ORAL BECAUSE OF BILLS WERE
PASSED EARLIER THIS WEEK AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO IMPORT MORE
FOOD IF THIS BILL PASSES.
READING THE ANALYSIS IT JUST
CAME OFF THE FLOOR WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THERE'S A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT ALLOWS A
PRIVATE RIGHT ACTION AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES THAT
ALLEGEDLY CZ EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS ADOPTED BY THE OR
BE. THE COST ANTICIPATD FOR
THIS PARTICULAR FEE INCREASES
BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND THREE MILLION ANNUALLY.
THERE IS ANTICIPATING A SIX
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR IN
SPECIAL FUNDS ONE GOING COSTS
ARE ESTIMATED POTENTIALLY FOR
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE IS ESTIMATED SIX
MILLION FOR THE FIRST YEAR AND
IMPLEMENTATION AND ELEVEN
MILLION TO ON GOING COST. THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD ANOTHER STATE
AGENCIES VESTED MEDIAN ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PLUS TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE AIR
POLLUTION FUND THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD SAYS
IT'S ANTICIPATING THE FISCAL
IMPACT ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS
A SPREAD ACROSS VARIOUS SENDING
FUNDING SOURCES. THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE'S IT'S LIKELY TO
COST NEARLY THREE OR FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS A D. R. SAYS IT'S.
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN RANGE. IT'S A HAS X.
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACT ON
OUR STATE BUT IT HAS A BIGGER
IMPACT. ON YOUR FOOD SUPPLY.
AND SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTERS ACTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M I'M NOT SURE WOULD
BILLS THE MINORITY LEADERS
REFERRING TO BUT BASICALLY WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. AS I UNDERSTAND
IT AND WHAT THE AMENDMENTS TO.
IS IT SAYS IT REQUIRES THE
STATE TO ADOPT TO BE
REGULATION. ANY FEDERAL AIR
STANDARD THAT IS WEAKENED. SO
WHAT WE'VE GOT NOW THE HIGHEST
LAWS THAT ALREADY EXIST WE'RE
GOING TO PROTECT. BECAUSE WE
KNOW THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE A POINT TO TRY TO
UNDERMINE EVERY ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW IN THE STATE. I AM TALKING
TO THE ISSUE AND THE ISSUE WAS
THE AMENDMENTS. WHAT'S MORE
BACK IN DC ON YOU GUYS. IT IS
VERY WE KINDA LIKE. WE WOULD
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN RECOGNIZE
FIRST AND WE ASKED FOR DECORUM
AND WE ASK NOT DIRECTED TAX ON
EACH OTHER SO VISIT. STATE YOUR
POINT OF ORDER. IS BEING IN THE
NATION. TO MAINTAIN THE HIGHER
FEDERAL AIR STANDARDS. THAT
EXIST NOW IF THEY ARE WEAKENED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
IS PART OF THIS BILL SO WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF THOSE WHO. ARE
TALKING ABOUT SB ONE WOULD TALK
ABOUT SB ONE AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE AMENDMENT IT SAYS WE
WILL THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND OTHERS
WILL ADOPT VARIOUS PROTECTIONS
THAT WERE IN PLACE IN FEDERAL
LAW OR REGULATION AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IF THEY ARE
SUBSEQUENTLY WE CAN TO OR
REPEALED IN OTHER WORDS WE HAVE
A BASELINE. WE DO NOT WANT TO
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS ERODED
BELOW THOSE BASS LINES WHETHER
IT'S STATE LAW OR WHETHER IT'S
FEDERAL LAW THAT WE HAVE BEEN
USING THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ALL ABOUT THAT'S WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ABOUT AND IF I
COULD REFER YOU. TO THE SECTION
REGARDING A THE AMENDMENT TO
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IT
DOESN'T CREATE A NEW ONE EACH
ASSEMBLY SAYS THAT THE PROVIDES
A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION TO
ENFORCE CERTAIN ERROR WATER
STANDARDS WITHIN CALIFORNIA IF
THE EXISTING PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WITHIN FEDERAL LAW OR
REGULATION IS WEAKENED TO OR
REPEALED BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING ON IN
WASHINGTON WE WANT TO PROTECT
OUR LAWS WE WANT TO PROTECT OUR
STATE THESE NOTIONS. THAT THE
WORLD IS GOING TO COME TO AN
END OUR FOOD SUPPLY IS GOING TO
COME TO AN END IS TRUST FALLS.
THIS BILL SAYS WE WANT TO
PROTECT THE STANDARDS THAT ARE
IN EXISTENCE AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BEFORE THIS
ADMINISTRATION CAME IN AND
STARTED UNDERMINING AND
WEAKENING THOSE REGULATIONS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES THIS
IS TOTALLY ON POINT BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS THE
REDUCTION IN THE WEAKENING QUE
TO FIGHT YOUR POINT OF ORDER
SENATOR. OKAY OKAY ALL OVER THE
STATE. WATER BASED ON WHAT YOU
GUYS. THANK YOU. WERE YOU STILL
STE CONTINUES SPEAK TO THE
MEMBER SENATOR JACKSON THANK
YOU I AM SPEAKING TO THE
AMENDMENTS AT LEAST AS THEY
EXIST HERE AND IT PROVIDES ANY
STATE REGULATION THAT'S ADOPTED
TO ENSURE PROTECTIONS OF
FEDERAL LAW SO OF JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WILL SUNSET IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE ARE
PROTECT TRYING TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS OF THE STATE
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
THAT'S WHAT THESE AMENDMENTS DO
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
DOING THIS WE HAVE SPENT
DECADES TRYING TO CREATE STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS TO
ADVANCE TO PROTECT THE FUTURE
OF OUR GREAT STATE WE DO NOT
WANT THEM UNDEMIND. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IN AND
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER HUESO. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THE POINT OF ORDER.
BASICALLY CONFIRMED IN MY MIND
THAT THE OPPOSITION DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS BILL IS
REALLY ABOUT SO. I WAS GOING TO
GET UP AND CAL CLARIFY BUT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
DID A GREAT JOB BASICALLY.
EXPLAINING WHAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY DOES AND WE TALK ABOUT
SCIENCE COMING OUT OF
WASHINGTON RIGHT NOW I'M SORRY.
THE SCIENCE IT HAD NOTHING
COMING OUT OF WASHINGTON IS
BASED O SCIENCE RIGHT NOW. AND
WHAT THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO DO
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS
UNDERMINING OUR ABILITY. TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR STATE. THE DEAL WAS SALT
WATER INTRUSION THAT SEAL WITH
THAT DEAL WITH THE PROTECTION
OF ENDANGERED SPECIES THAT DEAL
WITH OF SUBSIDENCE IT'S ALSO
AFFECT THE IN. THE PRODUCTION
OF CROPS IN OUR STATE.
SUBSIDENCE WE VOTER ON A BILL
THAT'S FUNDING THE FRYING CANAL
THAT IS BEEN AFFECTED BY
SUBSIDENCE WE TALK ABOUT. THE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT THIS IS
A CRITICAL ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA
AND OUR SURVIVAL OF SALT WATER
INTRUSION OVERTAKES. OUR WATER
SUPPLY IN THE ENTIRE VALLEY
THERE GOES ALL OF AGRICULTURE.
EVERYTHING IS DESTROYED THIS
ALSO IS AN ISSUE THAT DEALS
WITH OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
ABILITY TO PRODUCE. OF FOOD IN
THE STATE SO. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND I APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON THIS
ISSUE CREATING THE BASELINE
THIS BILL. WILL NOT CHANGE
ANYTHING IT WILL NOT BUT OF. IT
WILL NOT. DESTROY OUR STATE'S
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO PRODUCE
FOOD BUT IT WILL. PROVIDE THOSE
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS MAINTAIN
THEM IN PLACE THE ONE SET OF WE
WANT WE'VE WORKED FOR. FOR
DECADES TO PUT IN PLACE TO PUT
OUR STATE ON A BETTER PATH AND
WE ARE THE LARGEST AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCER IN THE COUNTRIES WE-
THINGS ARE GOING WELL WAR WAR
GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
SCIENCE TELLS US THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS REAL WE GOTTA DO OUR
PART THIS ADMINISTRATION'S TERM
DEBT THOUGH THAT BUT WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND A IN OUR COMMUNITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE
FIGHTING FOR OUR SURVIVAL HERE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THIS IS A
GOOD BILL. THIS BILL SUPPORTS
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR ECONOMY OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR QUALITY OF
LIFE PLEASE VOTE YES. TO
SENATOR MINING. YOUR PRESIDENT
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT I WANT
TO THANK THE PRO TEM FOR HER
COURAGE AND LEADERSHIP BRINGING
THIS FORWARD A LOT OF THE FOCUS
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE
VOTING ON HAS BEEN ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS THAT
WERE TRYING TO PROTECT. THEY DO
HAVE SOME AFFECT POTENTIALLY ON
WATER ISSUES BUT I JUST WANT TO
FOCUS. THE FUTURE OF
AGRICULTURE. DEPENDS IN LARGE
MEASURE ON THE WORK FORCE THAT
CULTIVATES AND HARVEST THE CROP.
IN THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS TO
AUTHORIZE THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS
BOARD IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO ADOPT
VIA REGULATION ANY WORKER
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE IN PLACE
IN FEDERAL LAW OR REGULATION AS
OF JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
WERE SUBSEQUENTLY WEAKENED OR
REPEALED. I WOULD SUBMIT THAT
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY THE
PROTECTION OF WORKER PROTECTION
STANDARDS ARE ALSO AN EQUALLY
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THIS
BILL AND I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. JEAN HEARING ON MADAM PRO
TEM WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD. YOU KNOW THE WHOLE
INTENT IN POINT OF THIS BILL IS
TO PROTECT US AGAINST ROLL
BACKS THAT ARE OCCURRING. ON
CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER
ENDANGERED SPECIES WORKER
PROTECTIONS. SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS ARE I THINK A LITTLE
BIT OVER BROAD OUR STATE I'M
I'M GONNA MAKE A FEW POINTS
JUST TO. RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
HOPEFULLY. IT BECAUSE THIS IS
SUCH A LARGE BILL AND WE TOOK
SO MANY AMENDMENTS. OUR STATE
HAS LIVED AND THRIVED UNDER THE
CURRENT ESA LIMITS THE ONLY
THING THIS BILL AFFECTS AGAIN
IS ROLL BACKS NO NEW
REGULATIONS NO HOLD SCIENCE. AS
IT RELATES TO THE ESSAY NOTHING
PRECLUDES NEW SCIENCE FROM
BEING USED WE'RE JUST SAYING
THAT CALIFORNIA WILL REVIEW THE
SCIENCE AND JUST NOT TRUST THAT
THE SCIENCE COMING. OUT OF THE
FED'S THE FED FEDERAL
MINISTRATIONS TRUE AND THAT'S
WHY THE FINAL DISCRETION REST
WITH FISH AND GAME. I WOULD
POINT OUT. THE AT FIVE IN THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS. THE
PROVISIONS WERE TALKING TO THAT
ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE
OVERARCHING PURPOSE OF THE BILL
PARTICULARLY IN RESPONSE TO
RECENT. THE RECENT ACTIONS I
DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE TO SAY IT
OUT OF THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION. IS TO SIDELINE
FEDERAL SCIENTISTS AND WEAKENED
PROTECTIONS FOR SEVERAL SPECIES
WE SAW THAT THERE WAS THESE THE
NEW REGULATIONS WERE COMING OUT
THEY WERE OVER WRITTEN BY THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION. TO GET
NEW REGULATIONS BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T LIKE THE REGULATIONS
WERE COMING FROM THE SCIENTIST.
THE FIRST PLACE SO THEY WERE
OVER WRITTEN BY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS ABSOLUTE
EVIDENCE THAT THERE IS AN
ATTEMPT TO ACTUALLY OVERRIDE
THE BEST SCIENCE. PEOPLE KEEP
ASKING ME OF OUR TALKING ABOUT
THIS BILL AS IF WE ARE TRYING
NOT TO ACCEPT THE NEWEST. AND
MOST UPDATED SCIENCE WE JUST
SAW EVIDENCE OF EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE OUT OF. WASHINGTON.
THE BILL TOTALLY PRESERVES FULL
DISCRETION FOR OUR STATE
AGENCIES TO ASSESS AND APPLY
THE MOST CURRENT SCIENCE
AVAILABLE WE PUT IT IN THE BILL
IT'S THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
IT DOES NOT IN ANY MANNER LOCK
IN OLD SCIENCE. REFERENCES TO
RUSHING A BILL THIS BILL HAS
BEEN HEARD IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
SIX POLICY COMMITTEES THREE IN
A EACH HOUSE IT'S BEEN
REVIEWED. EXTENSIVELY AND WHEN
YOU SAY STICK TO THE AMENDMENTS
THERE BEEN SEVENTY FIVE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. IN
REFERENCE TO THE LETTERS YOU
KNOW THERE BEEN MORE LETTERS
FROM HI CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS
TO ACTUALLY ONE IN SUPPORT. THE
BILL OF THE BILL AND ONE THAT
ASK FOR AMENDMENTS WE'VE MADE
AS I SAID AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS RAISED IN ONE
LETTER BUT WE STAYED FAITHFUL
TO THE SUPPORT EXPRESSED BY THE
OTHER. SB ONE DOESN'T IN ANY
MANNER AFFECT THE STANDARDS
THAT APPLY TO THE WATER SYSTEM.
IN CALIFORNIA UNLESS AGAIN
THEIR ROLLED BACK THAT'S THE
WHOLE POINT. OUR SYSTEM HAS
WORKED WELL FOR DECADES SB ONE
ISN'T THE PROBLEM I THINK IT'S
THE IMPACT AND ATTACK. ON THE
FORTY YEARS WORTH OF WORK THAT
WE HAVE DONE WITH STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGH AGENCIES PROCESS. THAT
IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT
AND I WOULDN'T. I HAVE A GREAT
DEAL OF ADMIRATION AND RESPECT
FOR PEOPLE IN THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY WHICH IS WHY WE MET A
NUMBER OF TIMES AND FOR MANY OF
THESE. AMENDMENTS COME FROM. IT
PAINS ME THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO COME TO AGREEMENT.
PERSONALLY ARE BUT THIS IS THE
CRUX OF THE DISCUSSION THAT WE
HAVE BEEN HAVING. FOR DECADES.
WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO WILL
BE IMPACTED WHEN WE HAD THE
LAST DROUGHT WE ALMOST LOST THE
ENTIRE SALMON POPULATION IN
PARTS OF OUR STATE. BECAUSE WE
NEEDED THAT PROTECTION IN PLACE
WE NEEDED THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES WE HAVE A YOU KNOW
PEOPLE LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
LITTLE FISH THE SMELL. WERE
TALKING STEEL HEAD TROUT WERE
TALKIN SALMON WERE TALKING
RESIDENT KILLER WHALES. BOB
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE DELTA
ECOSYSTEM. I GET THE DIALOGUE
AND DISCUSSION I UNDERSTAND HOW
HARD THIS IS WE ARE ASKING
FRANKLY NOT TO HAVE A RUSH IN
JUDGMENT ON CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER. WORKER PROTECTIONS THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES OR ASKING
NOT TO HAVE A RUSH TO JUDGMENT
AND REDO IN SIX MONTHS NINE
MONTHS ONE YEAR ALL OF THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE DONE FOR DECADES.
AS CALIFORNIANS AND IN FACT
WORKING WITH FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS BOTH DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS SO. I
APPRECIATE THE DEPTH OF FEELING
HERE AND I GOTTA TELL YEAH I'E
NEVER FELT MORE CONFLICTED IN
TERMS OF ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT FEEL FEEL
INTIMATELY THE IMPACT OF WHAT
THIS LEGISLATION IS DOING BUT
FRANKLY IT IS BECAUSE THERE WAS
THE DESIRE TO TRY TO ROLL BACK
COMPONENTS OF THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT BECAUSE. ARE THERE
IS SOMETHING YOU THAT MANY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ON DONE IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO SUPPORT THIS. I DON'T KNOW
MUCH MORE WHAT WE COULD HAVE
DONE TO ADDRESS EVERY CONCERN.
IN GOOD FAITH I SAID I WOULD WE
WORKED INCREDIBLY HARD AND- I
WOULD AT THIS VERY EARLY HOUR
IN THE MORNING ON THE
FOURTEENTH. IT'SAFTER MIDNIGHT
WE'RE NO LONGER ON THE
THIRTEENTH THAT MIGHT BE GOOD
GIVEN THE THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED ALL DAY AND INTO THE
EVENING. BUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB ONE WE
SHOULD BE INCREDIBLY PROUD OF
THE WORK THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
DONE ON ALL OF THESE ISSUES AND
WE MAY NOT ALWAYS AGREE BUT
THERE HAS BEEN A PROCESS. AND
EXTENSIVE PROCESS ON EACH OF
THESE AREAS. AND THIS BILL
REFLECTS. JUST THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT WORK HAT WE
HAVE DONE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZE THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. NO BELL BY PORGES. NO
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. NO CHIANG.
NO DALLY NO DODD I DORADO. BY
GALGIANI NO GLAZER. BY GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
HI HUESO I TADO NO JACKSON HI
JONES. NO LEYVA BY MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL I BY MONNING BY MORE
LOCK NO MERRELL NO NIELSEN NO
PAN. I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NO NUMBER IOWA CASKEY I
WINNER. WILK NO NO. YES. TWENTY
FIVE FOURTEEN SENATOR ATKINS
MOST THE CALL
. MEMBERS YOUR
DOLLAR TO CALL ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE. AB TEN SIXTY SIX.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN BY ATKINS
BY CABALLERO. GALGIANI GLAZER
HERTZBERG. I TADO. PAN
PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO. THE
TEAM. NINETEEN YES FORTINOS.
WERE PUT IT BACK ON CALL
.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS CENTER
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU ARE
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO
THE SENATE JOURNAL FOR SENATE
BILL THREE TWENTY EIGHT. THE
OBJECTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE ADDITIONAL MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU WE'RE GONNA TAKE A LITTLE
FIVE MINUTE. WHEN WE HAVE
SENATOR DOLLARS ON THE BALLOT
THE CONDITION OF THE FILE. HOW
MANY BILLS DO WE ACTUALLY HAVE
LEFT WE KNOW THAT THIS IS THIS
IS NOT APPROPRIATE TIME WHERE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IT'S.
ONE THIRTY IN THE MORNING AND
I'D I'D LIKE TO LEAST KIND OF
GET AN IDEA YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING. THIS IS A I JUST GO
HOME IF I DON'T WANT TO VOTE ON
THESE BILLS. I'M SERIOUS
.
SENATOR DELAWARE WE DO NOT HAVE
THAT INFORMATION AT THIS TIME
SO. WE'RE WE'RE GETTING A SHORT
LITTLE WHITE
. I DO A REAL QUICK
UPDATE WORK WE HAVE FOUR MINUTE
MEASURE STILL TO BE DEALT WITH
BE DEALT WITH THIS EVENING WE
HAVE ONE A. B. AND THREE ESPYS
BUT WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT
SPEECH TO COME OVER SO. WE'RE
WE'RE JUST GOING TO BE IN A
TEMPORARY HOLDING PATTERN INTO
WE HAVE. HOW THOSE MEASURES
HERE AND WE'RE HERE BECAUSE OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES. AND AS YOU
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
EARLIER TODAY THAT PRETTY MUCH
DICTATE PUT. PUT US BEHIND
SCHEDULE SO HAVING TO RELOCATE
AND SET UP HERE SO PLEASE
UNDERSTAND
. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBER. WIENER BY TWENTY. ALL
EYES TWENTY SIX NOTE FOURTEENTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER
AMENDMENTS KURT AND I CAN TALK.
I DON'T TWENTY TWO AB TWO
EIGHTEEN WILL LOOK TO CALL HIS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN HI BATES.
GORGEOUS DALLY GROVE JONES
MCGUIRE HI BY MORLOCK MERRELL
PORTANTINO WHAT IS THIS. WIENER
AB TWO EIGHTEEN. RETURN WINNER
I. AND YOU KNOW WHY. FIVE
THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. YEAH
.
CARDMEMBERS SHOULD WE WERE
TAKING OUT FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN. AB TWENTY NINE SOONER OR
LATER YOU'RE READY I'M READY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY NO HIGHWAYS. EARLY
THIS FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS BEAR
WITH ME MY COLD IS KICKED INTO
HIGH GEAR I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE A BILL
THAT RESOLVED THE PROBLEM THAT
HAS BEEN DIVIDING THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY FOR FAR TOO
LONG. THE BILL REALLY REMOVES
THE MOST DISPUTED LAND OF THE
S. R. SEVEN TEN FROM THE
FREEWAY AND EXPRESSED CODE
EXPRESS WE CODE A LINE THE LAW
WITH THE DESIRES OF THE CITIES
AND THE FINALIZED CALTRANS III
ARE. FOR TO LONG THE STATE HAS
ATTEMPTED TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY. CAN DO WITH
THIS AREA. I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. SINCE THEY FELT
IGNORED LOCAL RESIDENTS TOOK
THE ISSUE TO COURT AND A
DECADES LONG BATTLE BEGAN. THAT
KEPT THIS LAND STAGNANT FOR
YEARS WHILE THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY GREW AND DEVELOPED
AROUND IT. LAST YEAR LA METRO
CALTRANS TO CLEAR THE- LOCALLY
PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE. TO BE
TRAFFIC DEMAND MANAGEMENT NOT A
FREEWAY THIS IS REFLECTED IN
THE FINALIZED YEAH THEY ARE NOW
ALL OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT
USED TO BE AT ODDS ARE IN AT
THE TABLE TOGETHER. DISCUSSING
HOW TO MOVE FORWARD IN A
UNIFIED FASHION THIS IS
SOMETHING HAT WAS UNFATHOMABLE
JUST ONE YEAR AGO. AB TWENTY
NINE WILL ALLOW THEM TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOP
GREEN SPACES CREATE BIKE LANES
AND DEDICATED BU ROUTES
INSTEAD OF CROWDED STREETS. MIX
TO BUILD MIXED USE SPACES FOR
RETAIL HOUSING ENTERTAINMENT.
AND WHATEVER ELSE THE
COMMUNITIES DECIDE THE AUTHOR
HAS WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CALTRANS LA
METRO. THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CAL STATE LA AND
MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR TO GET
THE BILL TO WHERE IT IS TODAY.
HE HAS WORKED ON FOR THREE
YEARS TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE
THERE IS CONSENSUS ON THE GOAL
AND NO OBJECTIONS TO THE
LANGUAGE. IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL THAT WOULD MEAN A LOT TO
THE RESIDENTS OF SOUTH
PASADENA. AND PASADENA THIS
BILL SUPPORTED BY LOCAL CITIES
ALSO WE WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
THANKS TO THE SENATORS WHOSE
DISTRICTS ARE IMPACTED BY SR
SEVEN TEN NORTH. WHO ENGAGE
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS ISSUE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING INSANE NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN HI HI ARCHULETA AREN'T
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL FIVE
LARGEST BRADFORD HI I CABALLERO
HI CHAIN I DALY. DODD I DORADO.
GALGIANI GLAZER. I GONZALEZ BY
GROWTH. HERTZBERG. HILL I BY.
WITH SO I'VE HIGHER TADO. HI I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA HI I'M
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LOCK NO MERRELL.
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH I'M BY RUBIO AYE AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER HI IOWA CASKEY BY WINNER.
WILK HI HI. TWENTY SIX ALL EYES%
NOSE TO THE MORE MODE MEASURES
ON CALL
. MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO MOTIONS RATHER
RESOLUTIONS. MANNA PRO TEM
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL AND THIS WAS IS IN
RESPECT TO SB ONE AND THE SANTA
CLARA PROJECT IN VENTURA COUNTY
I WOULD ASK FOR. AN AYE VOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THIRTY TO
CALL CALL THE ROLL CALL THANK
YOU MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE.
SEC PLEASE CALL THE WORLD. ALAN.
ARCHULETA ART BY SO ATKINS HI.
THE BASS. BELL. BY BURGESS NO
BRADFORD HI HI CABALLERO. I
CHIANG. DELHI NO DODD HI DORADO
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI I HILL AYE HUESO BY TADO HI
JACKSON. I JONES. LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL BY MONNING
HI MORE LOCK NO MERRELL.
NIELSEN. NO PAN BY PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS I RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. NUMBER OUR
CASSIE I WINNER. WILK YEAH NO
NOW I ALLEN AYE. CIRCULAR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES. CHANGE GROWTH JONES WELL
STONE WIENER. AND THE CALL WAS
THE RADIO CAM. AS A- OUR. HI
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS FIVE THE
MOTION CARRIES
. MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA LOOK THE CALL ON ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE.
BATES NO GORGEOUS. DALY DORADO.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE. OR JUST
DIE DORADO GROWTH. HERTZBERG
BYE BYE JONES. MORRELL.
PORTANTINO I STONE. WIENER.
YEAH MOVE THE CALL. THE ICE
THIRTY KNOWS THREE. MOTIONS
BACK ON CALL
. COLLEAGUES WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM TO.
EXCUSE ME AB. SB TWO EIGHTEEN
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
SENATOR BRADFORD COLLEAGUES AB
SB TWO EIGHTEEN WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. SB TWO
EIGHTEEN SENATOR BRADFORD
RESIDENT SB TWO EIGHTEEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENT WITH A
SIMILAR EXCUSE ME MY APOLOGIES
WE NEED TO READ IT FIRST SB TWO
EIGHTEEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE BILL TO
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD
ENACT RELATED DISCRIMINATION
SENATOR BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MEMBERS SB TWO
EIGHTEEN IS BACK FROM
CONCURRENT IT DEALS WITH FEE OF
FOR ONE POINT POINT IN IN
DISCRIMINATION IT NARROWS THE
BILL DOWN TO ONLY THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES AND IT ALLOWS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO CREATE THEIR
OWN. ALL SEIZE AS IT DEALS WITH
OP EMPLOYMENT AND I
DISCRIMINATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL I PORGES. ORIGINS BRADFORD
HI I CABALLERO. CHIANG I DALY.
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL. BY HUESO I
HEARD TACO HI I JACKSON HI BY
JONES. LEYVA HI BY MCGUIRE. BY
MITCHELL BY MONNING HI MORE
LUCK. MORRELL. NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH BY RUBIO
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER ALL RIGHT IOWA CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK WE'RE DESIGN HI
WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WORDS I. BATES ZERO I
DALLY GROWTH. JONES MORE LOCK.
MORRELL STONE. TO CALL. RECALL
HAS. THIRD MOVES TO CALL. OF
THE VOTE COUNTED SIGHTS THIRTY
THREE NO ZERO. MATTERS ON CALL
.
COLLEAGUES GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE. ITEM THE TWENTY
SEVEN AB. TWENTY NINE MR SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
DOLLY. DORADO HI GROWTH. JONES
RAIL. STONE WIENER WIENER WHAT.
I WAS THREE BY AGE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS THREE MEASURES BACK ON
CALL
. ON FILE LIVE WORK ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN AB. TWENTY NINE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY I
DON'T KNOW GROWTH JONES RAIL
STONE. I'VE THIRTY TWO NOTES
FOR THE MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS
WHO WERE GOING TO TAKE UP SB
SEVEN BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FOLLOW
CENTER PORTANTINO. READY FOR
THAT MEASURE. AREA GOOD FOOD IN
HAND
. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SB SEVEN SENATE BILL SEVEN
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE PROPERTY AND
HIGHWAYS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
PRESENTING SB SEVEN ON
CONCURRENCY MEMBERS TAKING THE
ASSEMBLY MAKE. MANY TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING CHANGES THEY ALSO.
RESPECT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
FOR CONSIDERING A FREEWAY OR
TUNNEL ONLY AFTER SIXTY YEARS
DOES THIS BILL PUT A STAKE IN
THE HEART OF THE SEVEN TEN
TOMALIN MY RESPECT GOES OUT TO
SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE STILL
LIVING WHO STARTED THIS FIGHT
SIXTY YEARS AGO. WHO MADE US
ALL THIS HAPPENED IT ALSO
RESTRICTS CALTRANS FROM
CONSIDERING A FREEWAY TUNNEL
WERE GAP CLOSURE HAND IT
PROHIBITS THE I. R. FROM BEING
USED IT ALSO GREATLY HELPS THE
NON PROFITS IN THE DISTRICT. TO
BUY THEIR PROPERTIES INCLUDING
AROUND MCDONALD HOUSE AND A
TECHNICAL GARDEN INTO SCHOOLS
IT REDEFINES HAD AS JANUARY ONE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR
PORTIONS OF THE SEVEN TEN. PART
INCLUDED IN THE STATE FREEWAY.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IT
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. TO
RELINQUISH TO THE CITY OF
PASADENA THE STOPS AND THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE PASADENA
WANTS TO. DELIVER THE STUBS.
AND NO OTHER BILL NO OTHER BILL
HAS THAT PROVISION FOR PASADENA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS I DON'T. HEARING AND
SEEING ON MISS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BY BATES.
BILL ARE BY BURGESS. BRADFORD
ALL RIGHT I CABALLERO I CHIANG
I DALY. DODD HI BY DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI
HILL AYE HUESO BY TADO. I
JACKSON. HI BY JONES. LEYVA AYE
AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI BY
MONNING. HI MORE LOCK. MORRELL.
NIELSEN AYE AYE AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN. AYE
STONE. NUMBER I WORK OUT SKI I
WIENER. WILK WILL GUY DALY AYE.
IS THERE. ICE THIRTY TWO NO
ZERO THE MEASURES ON CALL
.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA LET THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE AB
TEN SIXTY SIX. THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
GALGIANI. GLAZER TADO. PAN ROTH.
RUBIO. CALL THE ROLL MORE TIME.
CABALLERO GALGIANI. GLAZER THE
AUTO. PAN ROTH RUBIO. COLLAPSE
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
CABALLERO GALGIANI. GLAZER TADO.
PAN ROTH RUBIO. THE END OF THE
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME CALVET ZERO. GALGIANI.
GLAZER TADO. PAN ROTH. RUBIO
NUMBER. NINETEEN ICE NINETEEN
KNOWS. WAS FOURTEEN THE MEASURE
FAILS WITHOUT OBJECTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION. NO. THE MOTION TO
RECONSIDER THEIR MOTION TO
RECONSIDER. IS THE FIRST YEAR
PROCESS. FOR NEXT YEAR YEAH. IS
THERE OBJECTION TO THIRTY TWO
MEMBERS GRANTING
RECONSIDERATION. WE SAY NINE
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANITE.
ZERO FIVE THIRTY TWO NO ZERO
.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA LOOK TO CALL
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY AC A
FOURTEEN. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. JACKSON MONNING. ROTH
RUBIO. PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERSHIP. GALLON JACKSON
MONNING ROTH RUBIO. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OVER ALLEN.
JACKSON MORNING ROTH RUBIO. I
THREE FIVE TWENTY THREE TWELVE
KNOWS TWELVE. MAJOR FILLS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED. ONE
I IS THERE ANYONE KNOWS ZERO
FIVE THIRTY ONE NO ZERO
.
MEMBERS WERE LOOKING THE- CALL
ON S. B.
BUT I REFERENCE TO
FILE WE'RE LOOKING TO CALL IN
SB SEVEN CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES GORGEOUS
GROWTH JONES MORLOCK WELL STONE
WIENER. I WANT WE ARE DRY.
THREE THREE NINE ZERO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. ICE THIRTY
THREE KNOWS THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY I
THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ALL. CCAC WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO OUR LOOKED IN A
CALL ON SB TWO EIGHTEEN MS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. SALLY
GROWTH JONES LOCK RAIL STONE.
ZERO FIVE THIRTY THREE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TALKING. ALL YOU HAVE
.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS WILL BE MOVED
TO THAN AN ACTIVE FILE FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN. FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX SIXTEEN TWENTY NINE.
THIRTY THIRTY ONE. MEMBERS
NOW THE DUST IS CLEAR MADAM PRO
TEM. AS PRESIDENT THANK YOU
THIS WOULD BE THE TIME WERE
TYPICALLY THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
AND I WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY DOES IT. TO EXPRESS
OUR THANKS TO A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. HI IT IS CLEARLY BEEN A
UNIQUE I DAY ONE IN WHICH ARE.
MEMBERS WHO'VE BEEN HERE A LONG
TIME YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVEN'T
EXPERIENCED ANYTHING LIKE THIS
SO IT'S A FIRST I WOULD CALL IT
AN OUTWARD BOUND EXPERIENCE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ONLY IT'S
INWARD BOUND THIS TIME. I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE PATIENCE. AND
FRANKLY YOUR CIVILITY GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES CLEARLY YOU KNOW.
IT'S BEEN A DIFFICULT DIFFICULT
WEEK I WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
THANKS ON BEHALF OF THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER AND I. TO
FIVE OUR ASSISTANT. SECRETARY
OF BURNING AND MELTING AND THE
ENTIRE STAFF
. YOU NEEDED A NEW
EXPERIENCE YOU NOW HAVE ONE. TO
THE SERGEANTS AT OUR SERGEANT
OF ARMS AGAIN WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE JOB YOU'VE DONE FOR
US FOR THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS
MORE THAN YOU TYPICALLY WOULD
BE EXPECTED AND HAVE TO DO. TO
THE SERGEANTS AND SPECIAL
SERVICES I NEED TO SAY THANK
YOU. HAS MEMBERS. WE HAVE
INCREDIBLE STAFF AND THEY ARE
STILL WITH US IF NOT IN THIS
CHAMBER THERE IN OUR OFFICES
WATCHING AND WAITING TO MAKE
SURE THEY CAN HELP US FINISH
UP. APPROPRIATELY AS WE END OUR
LEGISLATIVE YEAR SO WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
STAFF AND THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE THIS YEAR. THANK YOU.
AND OF COURSE SIZE THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY THE LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER LDC FIVE WHO ARE
OBVIOUSLY WE COULDN'T DO
ANYTHING WITHOUT THEIR WORK
THEIR BEHIND THE SCENES BUT
CLEARLY IN FRONT OF US ALL THE
TIME AS WE DO THE WORK AND
CERTAINLY LET ME SEND OUT
THANKS TO OUR LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL WHO I HAD WRITTEN IN
SOME NOTES HOW MANY PIECES OF
LEGISLATION. THEY HAVE HAD TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT FOR US MORE
THAN TWO THOUSAND I THINK IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY WE WANT TO
SEND THANKS TO THEM AND WITH
THAT COLLEAGUES I HOPE YOU MAKE
IT HOME AND APPRECIATE THIS
HARD YEAR THAT YOU'VE HAD
BECAUSE REGARDLESS WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED A GREAT DEAL HERE
FOR OUR RESIDENTS FOR THE
CONSTITUENTS. AND SO SAFE
TRAVELS HOME ENJOY YOUR
COMMUNITIES YOUR FAMILIES AND
WE WILL SEE YOU IN JANUARY.
MISTER PRESIDENT. MEMBERS WE
ARE A TURN FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN LEGISLATIVE YEAR